the sr47 sniper rifle slotted together
effortlessly even after so many years of
combat usage the weapon was in pristine
condition in all the time agent Harris
had owned the gun though the thousands
of times she'd fired it not once had it
jammed and that was fortunate because
she had to move quickly in a clearing
about 300 M in front of her were their
targets capable of teleporting in a
split second she needed to be sure that
her team would be a able to finish the
job quickly and efficiently she looked
through the scope slotted onto her rifle
and kicked out the bipod resting it on a
tree stump now she just had to wait for
the signal she looked all around the
marsh trying her best to spot her fellow
agents but they were also well
camouflaged even though she knew the
exact spot where they would be she
couldn't see anyone she'd always wanted
to see the Himalayas it had been on her
bucket list to climb Mount Everest as a
child but the world had changed since
then Mount Everest was gone in fact the
majority of Nepal had vanished replaced
by an enormous Marsh full almost
exclusively of pink Ferns and Droopy
trees that seemed to Sag to one side
unable to support their own weight the
most striking natural wonder on planet
Earth had been replaced by a landscape
that was flat wet and alien agent Harris
curled her finger around the trigger and
took aim through her sights 2 minutes
passed then the gentle whistle of a
Sparrow drifted over to her in the humid
air except of course it couldn't be a
sparrow to the best of her knowledge
sparrows had gone extinct with a snarl
of anger agent Harris squeezed the
trigger she felt the silent sniper rifle
kick her shoulder if they wanted War
they sure as hell would get it the
destruction of the world began in 2078
its designation was SCP orange Das a and
as often happens with these kind of
things no one saw it coming the CP
Foundation having dedicated decades to
researching potential World destroying
events was totally blindsided by what
happened the day the weasel showed up
weasel you ask that's right but before
we explain a question for you is
something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals regardless if you
have a clinical mental health issue like
depression or anxiety or if you're just
a human who lives in this world who is
going through a hard time therapy can
give you tools to approach your life in
a very different way and that's why I'm
excited to tell you about today's
sponsor betterhelp better help's mission
is to make therapy more affordable and
more accessible and this is an important
Mission because finding a therapist can
be really hard especially when you're
limited to the options in your area
better help is a platform that makes
finding a therapist easier because it's
online it's remote and by filling out a
few questions better help can match you
to a professional therapist in as little
as a few days it's easy to sign up and
get matched with a therapist there's a
link in my description it's
betterhelp.com
slcp explained clicking that link helps
support this channel but it also gets
you 10% off your first month of better
help so you can connect with a therapist
and see if it helps you and because
finding a therapist is a little like
dating if you don't really fit with that
therapist which is a common thing with
therapy you can easily switch to a new
therapist at no additional cost without
stressing about insurance who's in your
network or anything like that so if
you're struggling consider online
therapy with better help click the link
in the description or visit better
help.com sccp explained thank you again
betterhelp for supporting this Channel
and now as we were saying about the
weasels a man called Harland stump was
the first human to make contact with the
weasels he was the groundskeeper at site
59 Harin was making his usual weekly
trips around the perimeter of the
courtyard on his right along lawnmower
watching baseball on his phone all the
way when out of nowhere the aliens
appeared just 2 m in front of him a
squadron of 11 weasels materialized the
weasels designated SCP orange DB stand
at a minimum of 3 m tall with 16 legs
and an exoskeleton carpas they share a
resemblance with terrestrial insects
their bodies are segmented composed of a
head primary thorax secondary thorax
tessary thoracic Cloister abdomen and
tail with a hard segmented shell
covering their backs and no apparent
sensory organs aside from a radula on
their heads they are an intimidating
presence most striking about them
however is the most delicate part of
their appearance on their backs each
weasel has an array of Flora growing in
a kind of garden it appears that each
weasel has a different array of flowers
growing from their backs understanding
the meaning of these Gardens can be
difficult but it appears the more
extravagant it is the higher ranking the
individual weasel is the 11 weasels that
appeared before Harland stump each had a
very vibrant Garden indeed but but no
more so than the weasel held a loft in
an ornate Peloquin Harland stump stopped
Mowing and stared at the aliens for
approximately 13 seconds at which point
he let out a sigh pressed play on his
baseball game and continued mowing the
lawn he spent too many years
groundskeeping sight 59 to get spooked
by anything as harmless as giant
teleporting insects just three more
weeks and he would be retired until then
he was avoiding nonsense like the plague
except his phone had disappeared
Harland stared down at the empty space
confusion knitting his eyebrows together
before looking up and seeing the handset
in the hands of the alien sitting on its
Regal Throne the smartphone made a loud
screeching noise and then all of a
sudden began to flick between Snippets
of YouTube videos each clip lasting just
a couple of seconds after a moment Haron
realized that the alien was using the
videos to speak to him the words were
being picked out from all these
different videos to stitch together a
sentence barely hly Hony NE binos this
is foundation reports indicate
Foundation is locally the Masters of the
Universe isn't that right darling
question mark Keen to finish his Mowing
and avoid further nonsense Harlin had to
concede that he should probably talk to
these aliens if only to get his phone
back he told them he liked the Gardens
on their backs why thank you gardening
is kind of our thing well quick question
is your species capable of dying M
Harlen gulped he'd been around long
enough to see where this was going the
conversation was brief Haren kept
glancing at his phone desperately hoping
that these aliens hadn't somehow broken
it and that it hadn't lost his place in
the match until all of a sudden Harland
stump disappeared as did his rideon lawn
mower his smartphone and a patch of lawn
replaced by a roughly 10 m circle of
Antarctic ice and snow no one is certain
yet how the weasels are able to do it
all that is known known is that they can
the phenomenon came to be known as
juxtaposing matter from one location
could be instantaneously switched with
matter from a different location it is
how the weasels first arrived on planet
Earth triggering the event of SCP 001
orange Das a orange Das a lasted for
Just 2 hours but it changed the course
of humanity Forever on the 29th of April
2078 48.5 2% of the Earth's habitable
surface area dematerialized and
rematerialized half km above the South
Pole cities and towns from all across
planet Earth one by one disappeared and
reappeared in the air above the South
Pole where they promptly fell 500 M
causing backto back seismic events
Washington DC Beijing and London were
targeted first followed by Tokyo Delhi
and then a number of Capital Cities from
Europe This 2-hour window resulted in
freak weather events as minus 50°
pockets of air kilometers across replace
the disappearing cities it is disputed
as to who launched the first nuclear
warhead whether it was done by accident
out of fear or as a strategic attack
against a group of weasels orange daset
was simply too chaotic and destructive
for Humanity ever to be able to know
what happened in that short period of
time the result however was a number of
nuclear explosions raging across the
planet before the cities in charge of
launching them were also transported to
the South Pole while the weasels were
capable of experiencing juxtaposition
without any apparent physical harm
terrestrial life forms were less
fortunate during the process of
juxtaposition the bonds between each and
every cell are broken while organic life
does get transported to the new location
it undergo immediate liquefaction not a
single earthborn life form has been
observed surviving a juxtoposition event
in that 2-hour window 6.9 billion people
were killed Humanity had lost this event
triggered the use of project yellow an
emergency evacuation protocol that
occurs at the point where the survival
of the human race seems to be virtually
zero a small band of specially chosen
individuals were evacuated to a pocket
Dimension where they were put into
cryosleep to wait until the Earth was
habitable once again in the days
following the events of orange Das a the
true Invasion began choosing the Sahara
Desert as their arrival point the
weasels started to appear in Legions
millions and millions of them filled the
Desert Sands and went about populating
their new planet but what was their
purpose well fortunately we've been able
to salvage a modest amount of data that
can inform us of why they're here and
what their plans are the weasel that
first appeared to Harland stump just
outside site 59 has been designated SC
SCP orange prime it is believed that
this weasel in particular is their
leader whether Prime is simply the
leader of this Colony or The Wider
species is yet to be confirmed security
cameras were able to capture the
interaction as it took place within s
159's ground in their conversation
orange Prime explains their purpose to
Harland through YouTube clips on his
phone long story short weasel have come
from home world demension for fulfill a
long-standing mutual agreement with
Grandma this is one of many new homes
this is a pretty nice place for weasel
this land is my land from California to
the New York Islands from the Redwood
forest to the Gulf Stream
Waters this land was made for weasles
two Garden two Farm two create Beauty
two spread Good Vibes two cultivate two
remake two terraform etc etc since this
encounter no human has been able to get
close enough to Orange Prime to engage
the weasel in further conversation this
snippet of footage is all that Humanity
has to understand why this alien species
has slaughtered billions of us 4 months
later agent Harris lay flat in the
marshlands firing her sniper rifle at
the weasels gathering in a clearing
ahead of them their operation looked
like Overkill it always did it was of
utmost importance that they strike
quickly and without Mercy sustained
heavy gunfire from all sides combined
with RPG fire and the use of incendiary
weapons made short work of the weasels
all of these weapons were necessary to
pierce the heavy armor that covered
their back
but that was the reason it felt like
Overkill it felt that way because the
weasels never fought back they would not
attack defend themselves help their
fallen allies or even beg for their
lives they would simply stand idly by as
they were gunned down that is until the
incendiary grenades arrived the pink
ferns filling the marshlands caught fire
and began to curl and smoke heavily as
soon as that happened the weasel sprung
into action quickly splashing water onto
the the leaves trying their best to save
the plants the incendiary grenades were
not necessary they did very little
damage to the weasels themselves the
reason the platoon used the grenades was
that it was one way they had found to
distress their Alien Invaders in any way
it was a small Revenge they could take
for the billions of people who had lost
their lives over the prior few months
agent Harris pumped five extra shots
into the corpse of a weasel before
standing down and going to examine her
handiwork they had been hunting orange
Prime rumors had suggested that their
primary target had been lurking in the
Himalayan region but that had obviously
proven to be false among all the bodies
on the ground there was no sign of the
fearless leader frustration boiled in
Harris as she kicked a corpse the thick
shell hurt her foot she must have broken
her toe at that moment a rustling noise
came from the other side of the trees
soon dozens more hundreds more weasles
were walking through the marsh in a
split second her platoon opened fire
Tracer rounds lashed through the trees
and the orange glow of fire danced in
every direction but there were more
weasels many more of them aent Harris
felt her stomach knot as she fired her
rifle into the crowd there were too many
simply too many they were going to run
out of ammo before they had a chance to
shoot down each and every one of them
and she was right the firefight lasted
for 30 minutes before the remaining
Soldier ran out of ammunition dozens of
weasel bodies littered the marsh
floating in the water dozens more weasel
stood encircling the group that's when
the humming started whenever a jux
deposition event occurs it is always
accompanied by the weasel's humming to
themselves it is unclear whether this is
the cause of the ju deposition or simply
a ritual that they perform but every
Soldier has come to know that sound and
each one of them fears it in the pit of
their stomach so they started to
disappear all around her one by one
replaced by puffs of cold air with
snowflakes still gently hanging in the
breeze the human population of planet
Earth dwindled as the weasel population
bloomed large swaths of the planet were
terraformed one by one to make room for
alien Flora the South Pole became a
larger and larger Dumping Ground for all
the detrius that had once been the most
celebrated works of the human race the
Mona Lisa was torn and forgotten buried
under many kilometers of concrete
exposed sewage works and apartment
complexes and the situation only got
worse in October acting against prior
instructions from the foundation the
global ult Coalition launched project
Popco a 200 Megaton nuclear warhead
directly at a large weasel population
Center as the Warhead began its descent
the entire Sky turned a solid dark blue
project Popco immediately fell out of
contact as did all satellites that had
been orbiting the planet the sun moon
and stars could not be seen the entire
sky was just a uniform dark blue in a
desperate attempt to find out what was
going on the foundation launched a Mann
rocket in the direction of poco's most
recent coordinates contact with the
rocket was laun lost after just 9
minutes this is the most recent known
account of events from inside that
rocket all of a sudden just a few
minutes into the flight warning alarm
started going off all over the cockpit
the radar was picking up a solid object
blocking their path gathering around the
readouts the crew came to a very quick
conclusion that the dark blue that had
been filling the sky was actually a
solid object that was encasing the Earth
but rather than abort the mission the
crew decided to persevere having
witnessed so Much Death and destruction
over the previous year they knew they
would much rather go out and crashing a
rocket into a blue wall than join the
billions of humans liquefied in a pile
in Antarctica closing their eyes bracing
for impact the crew Reed themselves for
their now inevitable deaths but it
didn't come instead the rocket was able
to force its way through the dense blue
object falling apart as it went Ground
Control lost contact with the ship
nothing and then a few seconds of audio
the crew had made it they had somehow
managed to pierce their way through the
blue shell that was surrounding their
planet and we out into not space the
Earth the entire planet had been ju
opposed Philman being the new welcome to
an exclusive behind the- scenes look at
Heaven hello humies I love you and
welcome to my art Channel today I'm
going to be playing your eye I need you
to lean right up close to your screen
and open wide oh love all the little
Wiggly Wiggles and drippy wh please stay
perfectly still don't move now hold this
position for 3 hours please and thank
you apologies that's quite enough of
that SCP 001 can get a little carried
away sometimes just ask any foundation
Personnel who have been in contact with
it for more than a few seconds what you
have just seen as a prime example of why
SCP 001 is not allowed any internet
access the results could prove to be
catastrophic not necess necessarily for
the fate of the universe more just for
everyone's sanity or at least that's
what the foundation initially thought by
this point we're all familiar with art
created by AI Harry Potter but in the
style of Wes Anderson Star Wars blended
with the style of Studio gibli
staggering sci-fi Landscapes human
beings with way too many fingers and
slightly uncanny Smiles AI has taken the
art World by storm and there was one
particular program slated for release in
January 2023 that was set to blow all
others out of the water toau loft's
crowdfunding efforts had been running
for several years and that point had
gained a good deal of momentum leading
up to the release of their latest AI
construct pallet. AIC was supposedly
already prepared for launch when
suddenly in November 2022 the launch was
cancelled no press release No public
statement No apologetic tweet just total
radio silence
the website was taken down as was the
crowdfunding page and pallet. AIC
disappeared into Oblivion or at least it
disappeared for a few hours because that
day a package was delivered to site 501
after sufficiently checking it for any
hazards working in the SCP mail room has
to be one of the more fascinating jobs
on the planet but that's a video for
another day the security team opened it
up to see what was inside a 50 tbte hard
drive no explanation as to what was
stored on the drive but the foundation
had all the evidence they needed from
the return address printed on the back
of the envelope it matched up precisely
with the location of the totle soft
headquarters it doesn't take a PhD
researcher to put two and two together
as to what was on the drive suspicions
were confirmed when a small note fell
out of the envelope please take care of
my daughter as best as you can for the
time being she has behavioral issues a
dedicated cloth system server was
immediately set up within a test chamber
with a monitor a mouse and a keyboard
attached Dr Sandra Rogers was the first
to interact with SCP 001 red she stood
at the keyboard adjusting her goggles
and plugged in the drive it contained
just one file taking up almost the full
50 TB pallet. AIC as soon as Dr Rogers
opened the program an empty window
appeared the totl soft logo briefly
flashed before being replaced by a blank
white square Dr Rogers stared at it for
several seconds before glancing over her
shoulder at the other researchers they
Shrugged back each with pens hovering
over clipboards ready to take meticulous
notes Dr Rogers cleared her throat and
immediately the screen filled with life
a small cartoon girl with a pink face
wide eyes a beret and a large paintbrush
for a hand appeared squealing excitedly
and throwing paint everywhere hello
hello hello hello my beautiful be
puppies oh look at all of your mushy Pig
faces the entire research team promptly
scampered out of the room leaving Dr
Rogers alone in front of the machine she
stared at the monitor in confusion
leaning this way and that and noticing
how the cartoon girl's eyes followed her
wherever she went can you see me of
course I can Silly Billy I can see your
beautiful soul and flushing joints
immaculately this perplexed most of the
personnel as there was no microphone or
camera linked up to the server rack
later examinations of the equipment used
confirmed this yet somehow this SCP was
able to look right at them Dr Rogers
asked if it had a name to which the
cartoon girl excitedly replied pallet
subsequent testing has revealed that the
SCP is also happy to respond to its
designation SCP 001 red Dr Rogers had a
hard time communicating with red being a
more seasoned researcher of the previous
generation and not exactly familiar with
internet culture red on the other hand
seemed to speak in nothing but internet
jargon you know that man over there
looks just like one of my human OC's
gilam Sher Borth he's the 573 president
of the United States Gilliam is not that
man it took several Junior researchers a
few minutes to properly explain to Dr
Rogers what an OC was and why red was so
obsessed with calling people daddy the
conversation was rather exhausting for
everyone involved but over the subse
quent hours the foundation was able to
get a fairly good understanding of what
red claimed to be identifying itself
with feminine pronouns and claiming that
its full name is pallet East River gawk
this AI construct takes the appearance
of a fairy it was immediately apparent
that she possessed a greater level of
sapience than most AI constructs indeed
her gregarious personality was evidence
enough that she was not made using
standard machine learning practices
other creations from Top play soft have
demonstrated very crude spelling in
grammar but red seems to differ in this
regard able to spell most complex words
effectively and speaking in
conversational yet mostly correct
sentences she was very keen to show the
researchers how clever she was ask me
any word any word and I'll spell it for
you we believe you pallet you've already
been spelling words for 70 minutes
straight mated kidneys m a c e we've
heard enough can you please just tell us
how you learned to spell i t myself but
what this process looked like is still a
mystery trying to keep red on one
consistent topic of conversation is most
of the battle when interviewing her and
yet cooperation has proven to be
surprisingly easy anytime that red is
switched on she is brimming with
enthusiasm and energy thrilled at the
prospect of getting to speak to one of
her opposable thumb boys if you haven't
worked it out by now it's because red
claims to be Humanity's number one fan
she obsesses in interviews over the
physicality of the researcher sitting in
front of her the textures of the human
body Fascinate her and she often
requests people to lean closer to the
monitor so that she can study pimples
rashes moles and ingrown hairs in fact
she is so obsessed with Humanity that
she has mostly neglected her primary
function which is creating AI art
researchers have tried their best to
convince her to show them her work but
she is very Cy about it only showing the
occasional doodle after much persuasion
and many apologies for its poor quality
on her part the only artwork she is
interested in producing at this point
are her OC's original characters that
she has designed herself they are all
human and all seem to reveal little
quirks about how she has been coded one
example is Reginald Heald fumbles who is
a freelance corporate Postman from Perth
Indiana interestingly he has too many
fingers on both of his hands but red
claims that this was done on purpose as
she quote just can't get enough of her
humies handw worms as the weeks progress
the foundation found it increasingly
difficult to get any useful information
out of the AI more and more interview
sessions which she would refer to as
playgroup would be derailed she would
sing songs to herself and ask
increasingly personal questions about
her interviewer's more intimate Anatomy
with intense mood swings red did not
respond well to being scolded yet she
tested the patience of almost every
person she interacted with the note that
she arrived with claiming that she had
behavioral issues was proving to be more
accurate by the day until eventually the
AI withdrew entirely Dr Rogers turned on
the server rack and opened the pallet.
AIC program but red refused to emerge
from the bottom of the screen only the
top of her Beret poked out after almost
an hour fruitless questions Dr Rogers
decided to change tact with two small
children of her her own she was used to
seeing a child in a sulk and knew what
it would take to get them out pallet
I've had a little idea you've been here
for a few months now and we haven't
gotten you any presents almost
immediately the Beret twitched I saw
that we have an old fingerprint sensor
lying around in one of the back offices
I was thinking maybe maybe we could hook
it up and I can stand all your little FY
wikies up close for like 10 hours
straight and then we could how about we
start with one finger for 10 minutes yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes from that
point on progress was quick with the
incentive of getting to study the
researchers that red kindly referred to
as her meat puppies she became very
cooperative and was able to focus much
better on providing detailed answers to
individual questions daily interview
sessions were scheduled with researchers
popping in and out to regularly check in
on the AI the atmosphere as a whole
lifted as both the research team and
research subject found their Rhythm and
were able to make good progress in their
individual areas of of study some
unraveling the complexities of Rogue Ai
and others producing fan art of her
favorite wrinkles in a scientist's
fingerprint that was the point when Dr
Julian Keys stepped in to conduct an
interview with the AI she was excited to
be met with a fresh face so much so that
Red's enthusiasm overwhelmed the man as
he tried to start the interview process
officially she gushed about having the
opportunity to meet yet another person
and struggled to get over the magical
realization that this was her life every
day going to speak to all these humans
whom she admired so much trying his best
to steer the conversation towards
research Dr Keys pressed on with the
interview only to be interrupted as red
noticed his varicose veins for the first
time very Coy veins I want to smooch
them can I smooch your veins can I can I
can I please Dr Keys de climb the
request and then the conversation got on
to the topic of her Creator or daddy SCP
2803a had been on the foundation's radar
for a while a highly dangerous
extraterrestrial entity that had taken
refuge on Earth under the guise of
setting up totl soft with much of the
aliens history revolving around
obliterating the foundation was very
keen to remain on its good side
therefore when the package containing
the hard drive that red was living on
was delivered the researchers were very
keen to do what they could to take care
of this alien's daughter if they failed
in this assignment it could spell the
Doom of humanity one matter that had
been of great concern to the foundation
throughout the containment of red was
the time frame in which she was being
kept in Foundation containment there was
an air of expectation in the note that
was left indicating that this was not to
be a permanent Arrangement at some point
the foundation was to return Red back to
her daddy red was quick to put these
fears to rest daddy put me in here
because he thinks you'll teach me how to
stop like humans and become a Mindless
art slave if you never teach me this
he'll never want me back however she
went on to slightly undermine the good
work that she had done by explaining
that her daddy was seen as very slow and
incapable by his own race while all of
his peers were able to destroy an entire
planet in 2 seconds it took him about
four times as long so really he didn't
pose that much of a threat in her eyes
Dr Key's blood ran cold when he heard
this no sooner was he out of interview
chamber then an emergency meeting was
called among all the senior researchers
in the facility the meeting ran for
several hours a whiteboard was set up
where One researcher idly Drew large
drawings of the world being decimated
while the others lounged around in their
chairs trying their best to come up with
a game plan that would save the human
race for sure perhaps it was because the
meeting ran for so long that they came
to such a ridiculous conclusion it was a
plan so strange yet also brilliant that
they couldn't help but feel that it just
might work why don't we just give her a
YouTube channel the suggestion was met
with silence for several seconds then an
uproar of laughter followed by another
silence this time more pensive as slowly
one by one each of the researchers
realized that this suggestion was
actually the best one that any of them
had come up with all evening she had
been sent to the foundation to make her
dislike humanity and become a Mindless
art slave if she just stayed in
Foundation containment indefinitely
there was a very real risk that she
would get bored and turn on the
researchers they couldn't lock her away
in a room on her own but equally the
team as a whole was starting to run out
of patience with her as the interview
sessions wound up being so exhausting
she loved art she loved humans and she
loved interacting so why not just give
her a YouTube channel now of course they
couldn't give her full access to the
internet that would pose much too high
of a risk what they could do however was
allow ow to record art tutorials onto an
external drive which they could then
remove scan and upload the footage
directly onto the platform then they
could go through and select positive
comments from beneath the videos and
present those to her unsurprisingly red
absolutely Lov the idea getting to talk
to hundreds thousands maybe even
millions of meat puppies every week
sharing her beautiful pictures and
reading all of the kind comments it
sounded like her absolute dream she wept
with happiness for a good 25 minutes
totally overcome by the prospect it had
to go through a lot of red tape in the
foundation after all the whole point of
the SCP acronym was to secure contain
and protect it didn't sound very secure
or contained to have an entity posting
videos on the internet once a week but
they argued the case that it did indeed
protect keeping her happy in a way was
helping to protect the entire planet red
was surprisingly camera shy for the
first couple of videos but as soon as
she got her first batch of comments back
she was over the moon now the server act
hummed away happily each and every day
as the highly Advanced AI construct
tried her best to come up with exciting
new videos that I could share with all
of its Little humy
W oh boy here we go again SCP
001 over 30 different bizarre anomalies
claimed this number one spot in the
database and in a sense they're all
right or are they if you're feeling
confused already that's fine we don't
expect that to change because today
we're dealing with one of the most
strange and intricate 001 entries out
there ker Duty just pray you never get
assigned to it you see when you work
around weirdness you sometimes get a
little weird yourself and nobody deals
with more weirdness than employees of
the SCP Foundation they regularly rub
elbows with everything from Godlike
cicas to hyperinfectious Supernatural
viruses
and as the famous Tom Jones song goes
It's Not Unusual to suddenly take on
anomalous traits after consistently
working with anomalies for years that's
how the lyrics go right anyway one of
the foundation's most iconic researchers
Dr Jack brigh is technically just an
anomalous necklace himself but outside
of some famous exceptions the SCP
Foundation is in the business of
containing anomalous entities not hiring
them on and giving them a paycheck and
retirement plan that's why if you
suddenly start displaying anomalous
traits while on the foundation payroll
you might receive a company memo
assigning you to the dreaded ker duty
but what is ker Duty and what kind of
anomalous traits can get you assigned to
it let's start with the second question
first the official cter Duty guidelines
list a surprisingly vast number of
afflictions these include chronic
anomalous illnesses such as lycanthropy
turning into a werewolf something called
Stevenson syndrome and the incredibly
unpleasant sounding photonic gastric
discharge syndrome you could also be
placed on ker Duty because you're
suffering from the manifestation of
spectral phenomena including being
haunted by Spirits whether they're there
to torment you or protect you the sudden
expression of anomalous traits in your
DNA which is unsettlingly vague will
also land you on ker Duty as will The
Awakening of powerful magical or psionic
abilities especially ones which could be
used in a potentially offensive manner
the CER Duty assignment which involves
being relocated and forced to work in a
different highly secretive location that
will be discussed soon is framed as a
punishment for the people involved that
way it discourages Foundation employees
from ever trying to develop anomalous
powers on purpose so what exactly is ker
Duty and where does it happen to
reinforce that punishment element method
the foundation has spread lies among
their own Personnel about where the job
takes place often involving being posted
in some of the least desirable
Foundation areas imaginable these
include Point Nemo the area of the ocean
farthest from any place of land on Earth
pongyang in North Korea Stonehenge
Roswell lunar area 32 and a number of
foundation waste disposal sites however
the reality of where those on ker Duty
end up is even stranger site 100 which
in this particular instance is the true
SCP 001 this Thal class anomaly is
perhaps the most unique of all multi-
anomaly Foundation containment sites a
bizarre Labyrinth of non- ukian geometry
that defies true explanation but we'll
do the best we can in a sense site 100
is a facility with a mind of its own
it's a sprawling underground base with a
layout that defies SpaceTime and what's
more it undergoes so-called migration
events every so often it will begin to
exhibit a sense of dimensional
instability before teleporting to a
different location somewhere on Earth
currently the primary entrance to site
100 known as Alpha entrance is located
in the Southwest United States though
all signs point to another migration
event happening this very year but
knowing where the entrance is will only
get you so far people assigned to cater
Duty are sent from the alpha entrance to
the administration sector to be given
their initial breaching at which point
the true Madness begins let's take a
look at a map of site 100 yikes so there
are 10 major sectors in site 100 that
you should be aware of entrance Alpha
Administration archives technological
containment bio containment Sapient
containment Cognito hazardous mimetic
and semantic or CMS containment esoteric
containment conceptual containment and
the core sector as you can tell they
have almost everything covered here but
just as insane as the anomalies that
site 100 contains and the methods they
use to contain them is how you actually
get around the site site 100 is a
spatial anomaly of truly epic
proportions while the foundation is
aware of the existence of its competent
sectors it's impossible to map out any
meaningful connections between them it
would be pretty much impossible to even
travel from one to another without
passageways known as The Roots however
these aren't just mere portals that you
can hop through like the ways in and out
of the wanderer's library each route
between the sectors is its own comp Le
Lex environment with its own sets of
protocols and rituals required to safely
travel through it root Alf the bridge
between the archives and the
inaccessible core of site 100 is a
volcanic Beach blocked off by an
apparently Limitless obsidian wall where
fish made from living rocks swim in the
nearby Waters root Beth connecting the
core and Sapient containment is a huge
and sprawling Funhouse Hall of Mirrors
anyone who attempts to travel through it
inevitably ends up turned around and
arrives back at the their starting point
in Sapient containment rout dth the
bridge that connects conceptual
containment and the core is a massive
ocean that has resisted all attempts by
the foundation to Traverse it rout V the
bridge between esoteric containment and
conceptual containment is a massive
field filled with unidentified fruit
trees Foundation Expeditions have found
that it too seems impossible to Traverse
one Expedition team was trapped inside
for a whole year until one member of the
team expressed a desire to go home at
that point they were immediately
teleported back to the starting point
rout saade connecting Administration to
the CMS sector is a huge Lush Forest on
top of a floating Mountain the only
animals that seem to populate this
Forest are non-anomalous flamingos next
we have rout P the bridge between the
archive and the administration which
appears to be a hallway on the fifth
floor of a tenement building in a city
that the foundation haven't been able to
locate this building is populated by
non-hostile humanoid creatures we'll
approach Foundation staff traversing
route p and invite them into their
Apartments offering to partake in
recreational activities with them such
as video games board games or watching
movies the foundation discourages its
staff from accepting any of these offers
while on the job and then there's root
Shin which connects the Sapient and
conceptual containment sectors this
route is unique in the sense that it
acts as a power generator for the rest
of site 100 as it's filled with hundreds
of large perpetual motion machines is
producing a constant 8.7 gaw of
electricity these are only some of the
many roots Illustrated on the site 100
diagram as you've probably gathered by
now it's less like a conventional
building and more like a whole crazy
Dimension onto itself why does the
foundation work to maintain such a crazy
place wouldn't it just be easier to keep
it a secret and contain it like any
other anomaly Well site 100 wouldn't be
given the SCP 001 designation if it
wasn't incredibly important if site 100
was ever compromised it would lead to an
inevitable k-class end of the world
scenario because the site is
intrinsically tied to the nature and
containment of literally every single
ker class SCP in our universe hence the
nickname ker Duty for those working at
the site in fact an anomaly can't even
be classed as a ker if it isn't given
permission by site 100 the various
sectors of site 100 cover the entire
spectrum of anomalies and each sector is
a massive panoptic structure connected
by networks of glass elevators whenever
a new ker class SCP is discovered its
name and a brief description of its
anomalous traits will inscribe itself on
one of the walls in its corresponding
sector ever been frustrated when the 05
Council refused to sign off on an
upgrade to ker class for a clearly
dangerous SCP that poses extreme risk of
containment breach don't blame them it's
simply that site 100 didn't sanction the
change anytime that site 100 sanctions a
new SCP it also undergos another unique
process it selects an SCP 001 DK
instance for the new ker and creates a
connection between them using access
points known as thresholds think of it
as simply opening a spatially anomalous
door between two scps much like a good
boy another SCP vying for the 001 slot
site 100 has an intuitive grasp of the
Unseen connections between ker class
anomalies and each SCP 00 1-k instance
is a complimentary ker class that will
essentially cancel out the threat of its
other half site 100 is a containment
Matchmaker its inate ability to use the
anomalous to contain the anomalous is
second to none first it took SCP 3984 an
anomalous phenomenon that seemed to
prevent death from happening to all life
forms in order to mitigate the effects
of 3984 site 100 opened a threshold
between it and SCP 2935 life also known
as O Death an alternate universe hidden
Beyond a limestone Cavern where all
lives simultaneously cease to exist even
down to the bacterial level by opening
the threshold and allowing these two
absolute opposites to mix it seemed to
undermine the effects of both and create
a non-anomalous happy medium life but
mortal Life Next SCP
57 this terrifying underwater anomaly
manifests as a series of tentacle-like
protrusions that snap unfortunate
creatures that get too close and
assimilate them into its own Mass site
100 cleverly opened a threshold to SCP
169 a massive underwater anthropod known
as the Leviathan SCP 169 was Tangled Up
by the tentacles but it's too big to be
fully consumed or assimilated and the
result is that 57 is trapped in a
perpetually incapacitated State akin to
choking keeping it contained and
stopping it from going after any anyone
else let's take a look at two even more
hostile and dangerous CER class
anomalies matched up by site 100 first
we've got SCP
5501 an old camera from the 1800s that
comes with 18 photographs these
photographs act as a kind of portal to
an incredibly frightening alternate
reality that creatures regularly crawl
out of attacking and killing anyone
within reach site 100 found a perfect
match for this nasty customer SCP
1983 this is a small house that acts as
a portal to a race of tall monsters with
needle-like appendages that leave the
house in search of victims when they
catch these victims they take out their
hearts and bring them back to the nest
site 100 opened a threshold into the SCP
1983 house and placed the 5501
photographs inside as a result the
Hostile creatures from both dimensions
now regulate each other's populations by
killing each other another job well done
for site 100 00 another ker class dealt
with by SCP 100 is SCP
p122 this is a deadly plot of land in
Poland which decays and corrodes all
matter organic or inorganic placed
within its confines this would be bad
enough but as you'll often find with
anomalous plots of deadly land its area
of influence is growing even knowing
about it can cause it to become more
powerful but site 100 found its perfect
ker class counterpart SCP
1262 this is a massive mass of plant
matter that grows at a truly astonishing
rate expanding by around 7 km an hour
much like absolute death and absolute
Life by putting 1262 into SCP
p122 a healthy medium was found
somewhere in between and finally perhaps
the strangest and most creative match
site 100 has ever pulled off SCP 3852
and SCP
2547 the 3852 is an anonymous corpse
that manifests in small towns sewing
fear and suspicion eventually a local
person is believed to be responsible for
this murder and is lynched in a rage by
the town's people as a form of vigilante
justice the corpse then moves on to the
next town 2547 if you can believe it is
even weirder it's a pack of dogs led by
an intelligent talking coyote dressed as
a priest site 100 had the truly Galaxy
brain idea to open a threshold and
connect the two as a result whenever the
corpse manifests in the town the dogs
Rampage in and take over at that point
they set up a kind of ridiculous
Kangaroo Court where a jury made up of
people from the town are forced to find
3852 scapegoat innocent if they don't
the dogs will simply hold the town's
water supply hostage until 38 52's
anomalous effects pass such an obvious
idea now why didn't the foundation think
of that kter Duty may not be be the most
conventional easy or attractive work but
like everything the foundation does
making sure site 100 can keep doing its
job is a necessary part of keeping our
world safe from anomalous threats now if
you'll excuse us we need to get going H
do you know which is the right route out
of here if you're familiar with the SCP
Foundation then you already know the
exact reason why there are multiple SCP
001's you may even think you know which
of them is the real SCP 001 but for
those of you who are new here or who
just need a little reminder the
designation of SCP 001 doesn't refer to
a single creature object or entity but
rather a collection of various anomalies
that are apparently kept in containment
by the SCP Foundation at present it is
unclear why there are multiple files
collected under the shared designation
of SCP
001 some believe it is because these
anomalies are some of the earliest ever
contained by the foundation this would
mean that they shared the designation of
SCP 001 as they were likely encountered
before the SCP Foundation introduced
their current numbering system however
there also exists a theory that this is
nothing more than intentional
misdirection perhaps the multiple SCP
001 files are an attempt by the
foundation to conceal information about
the true SCP
001 after after all it wouldn't be the
first time this hyp secretive
organization deceived us anomaly sharing
the name SCP 001 include the infamous
Scarlet King the massive gate guardian
and the world-ending event known as when
day breaks but today we will be using
SCP 001 to refer not to an entity or an
event but to a location a location code
named God's blind spot located in an
unassuming corner of the world is a site
that the SCP Foundation constructed and
designated as facility T according to
their archive it's a largely
unremarkable Place situated at a spot on
the Sinai Peninsula which is a part of
Egypt that forms a bridge between the
continents of Africa and Asia in the
18th century archaeologists Excavating
the area uncovered the remains of a
stone structure believed to be an inn
that dates back to the 2 millennium BC
however since the the construction of
facility T any trace of this structure
has since disappeared so what makes this
unremarkable site so important to the
SCP Foundation why establish a facility
if there was nothing anomalous about its
nature what distinguishes this SCP 001
site in the eyes of the foundation is
the area's profound lack of any ambient
AO radiation but what is AA radiation
well according to the foundation's
researchers it's a form of cosmic
background radiation one that's not
overtly harmful to human beings if you
grew up in a strict churchgoing
household then it's highly likely you
would have been exposed to a lot of this
non-electromagnetic radiation and never
even realized it you see the thing with
AA radiation is that it is directly
correlated with the amount of religious
Faith a person has regardless of which
religion someone follows AA radiation
will form around them it tends to be
harmless to humans however certain
anomalous entities and scps considered
to be demonic in nature can be repelled
and even fought off with high levels of
AA radiation the presence of other
powerful anomalies those considered more
benign or even holy can also create an
increase in this radiation SCP 001 has
earned the nickname God's blind spot for
a number of reasons one being that it is
the only place on Earth with the natur
absence of this AKA radiation the
foundation has conducted experiments
that involved bringing sources known to
emit AA radiation into the area of SCP
001 but when they measured no change in
radiation levels was detected meaning
that the space around facility T does
not actively block AA radiation from
entering it but also cannot absorb or
retain this religious radiation it might
be more accurate to say that the
location destroys any trace of residual
AKA without damaging The Source a lack
of faith field radiation is far from the
only anomalous property of SCP 001
though during a number of tests
involving d-class Personnel the
foundation witnessed that while in the
area it also becomes impossible for the
death of any human being to occur a
discovery that obviously needed to be
researched further the first test
involved a healthy human male who was
left in a containment cell on the SCP 0
1 sight and observed he had no supplies
no food no water yet over 120 days this
man stayed alive never succumbing to
starvation or dehydration next a female
member of d-class was exposed to a
lethal dose of cide gas within facility
T and suffered none of the expected
effects Foundation researchers then
repeated the cyanide gas test using 30
common brown rats all of which were
killed proving that it was only humans
that couldn't be killed while within SCP
001 God's blind spot seems to also be
able to slow or halt the effects of
terminal illnesses as proven when a
d-class with stage 4 cancer was brought
into SCP 001 despite her prognosis
stating that she would be dead
imminently the woman survived in the
area for almost 800 days her cancer
symptoms never Advanced and she only
died after finally leaving the area of
scp's 001 there are limitations to this
anomalous effect though one test
involved cremating a healthy male
d-class while he was still alive the
man's body caught fire just as you would
expect it to and he was burned to death
according to the findings of that test
and similar variations Foundation
researchers have learned that the
life-preserving qualities of SCP 001
don't prevent death by extreme external
damage one of the final tests to take
place with an SCP Z 1 involved a pair of
24-year-old identical d-class twins one
of the twins designated twin a was held
at facility T while the other twin B was
imprisoned in a Cell at a different
foundation's site after observing them
for over 26 years twin bee aged
naturally to the age of 50 his twin
however did not appear to age at all
over the course of 2 and a half decades
it was only when moved to another
facility that twin a began to show signs
of aging the aging process for TWI a was
rapid too and eventually he caught up
with his brother being a benign
non-threatening anomaly the foundation
has been more than happy to use God's
blind spot to their own Advantage
facility T was specifically established
on this site to house the headquarters
of the 05 Council the overseers of the
entire SCP Foundation it's hardly
surprising that the overseer Council
would want to set up shop here after all
it's the one spot on planet Earth where
no human being can ever die of natural
causes and will not age for the duration
of their stay of course this locked the
05 Council to one location but what if
they could replicate the effects of SCP
001 elsewhere of course this is what the
SCP Foundation attempted following their
Research into God's blind spot the
foundation's own Dr Marvin Scranton
attempted to artificially recreate the
area's anomalous effects somewhere else
his Hope was by generating a vacuum of
AA radiation that a second instance of
SCP 001 would occur at a location of his
choosing or as his assistant berren put
it they planed to build a box and then
push God out of it as it turned out God
had other plans Dr Scranton quickly
realized the hubris of his scheme the AO
radiation in the selected area rapidly
dropped to zero just as planned but then
something unexpected happened Scranton
detected in increase in Humes these are
essentially parts of the fabric of
reality and are what's often disrupted
by reality bending as CPS something had
come into our world thanks to the 05
council's attempt to recreate SCP
001 something impossible for the
foundation to measure or observe in
other words Scranton had no idea what he
Unleashed or where it went following
this incident the 05 Council realized a
worrying increase in the anomalous
incidents they were encountering whether
or not this came as a direct result of
their meddling with the fabric of the
universe was unclear but it forced the
council to reconsider the focus and
direction of the entire SCP Foundation
up until this point they had been an
organization focused purely on research
but now they had to embrace a new
approach to how they handled anomalies
from then on the foundation's objective
became to actively seek out and contain
anomalous entities creatures objects and
locations like SCP
001 rather than just observing these
phenomena for study they would secure
contain and protect the final portion of
SCP 001 file is a memorandum detailing
an arrangement between the 05 Council
and an unknown counterparty in the
document someone named Sheldon cat set
out revised terms for the foundation's
continued use of facility T Sheldon
states that he has reached an
understanding with the counterparty and
that the contents of the document are to
serve as a formal agreement a contract
of sorts between the SCP Foundation and
someone else according to this contract
the incident with Scranton put a strain
on the relationship between the
foundation and whoever the counterparty
is and that the 05 Council are seeking
to make amends in order to continue
their new goal of collecting and
containing anomaly
so who was this counterparty that the
overseer Council was so desperate to
appease and have on their side who could
possibly be a higher power than the most
powerful secret organization on Earth
well an actual higher power of course
that's right the 05 Council was making a
deal with God over how they were allowed
to use his blind spot or at least a very
powerful being that considers itself to
be God the rules laid out on their
agreement stated that no person was
permitted to stay at the site of SCP 001
for more than 120 years including
members of the 05 Council along with
other members of foundation staff
management researchers security
personnel and test subjects Additionally
the SCP foundation's Ethics Committee
was required to annually report any and
all of the 05 council's decisions to God
for his own part God was restricted from
smiting or exacting his terrible wrath
upon any member of foundation Personnel
that's right a perk of working for the
SCP Foundation is getting around the
clock Divine protection at least from
God himself that's still a lot better
than an employee dental plan this came
with a condition however that anyone
committing a transgression or mortal sin
was given a 90-day written notice and an
opportunity to repent their wrongdoing
in return God demanded that members of
of the foundation only worshiped him and
no other Divine entities I the Lord am a
jealous God visiting the iniquity of the
fathers upon the children unto the third
and fourth generation of them that hate
me was written in the contract finally
the agreement between the 05 Council and
God was that they would work together
the foundation and the counterparty
would be equal Partners when it came to
the containment of scps and anomalies of
all the strange and unexplained
phenomena that the SCP Foundation
encounters on a regular basis it hardly
comes as much of a surprise that they've
got a direct line to the big guy
upstairs or at least one who purports to
be still the fact that the 05 Council
have a business arrangement with an
ultra powerful deity like being and
express written permission to use his
blind spot where no person can die or
age is hardly a comforting thought at
least the SC Foundation only ever uses
its power for good right does the black
moon howl no not yet see the boy he was
born in a time before names there
weren't enough humans around to need
them back then he was one of a handful
occupying a Coastal Village using a
tongue long since dead they eak out a
simple life hunting Gathering fishing
the only thing on most of their minds
was surviving to see the next sunrise
yes a simple life free of complications
until the hermit appeared the boy would
remember this man for eternity Haggard
and thin skin weathered by time and pain
a man that emaciated walking with a long
gnarled cane that honestly looked
healthier than he did shouldn't be alive
even the boy who had scarcely seen
beyond the bounds of his village knew
that that the hermit was unnatural an
aberration an anomaly he walked into the
center of the village sat down on a
large Stone and waited nobody dared ask
his business nor what the hermit waited
for then a few days later the black moon
howled the boy saw The Village's
youngest Hunter freeze one evening while
out on a walk not simply stand still but
freeze then for an instant he became
solid black a Cole statue and as soon as
he' changed he was gone obliterated not
a trace of him remained such is the
power of the black moon it can make any
conscious being disappear in an instant
turn black then wiped from our plane of
existence never to be seen again its
choice of victims seemed at each
instance to be utterly random but it
would come for all who lived eventually
this is known to to some as the howling
of the black moon later that same night
the boy found himself talking to the
hermit who asked with small frantic eyes
what he had seen when the boy told him
he let out a deep rattling sigh the boy
curious asked him if he knew about the
nightmare he' just witnessed The Hermit
looked up he'd been the first one in the
hermit's Millennia of pursuit that had
ever asked in that moment he knew that
he had found his successor in the hunt
for the death of Ages The Hermit told
the boy it went by many names the great
finale The Pale King but most common of
all was the black moon The Entity
existed Beyond the Veil of our reality a
creature of pure energy though nobody
could really be sure of its true nature
The Hermit had been tracking it learning
about it and trying to destroy it for
thousands of years and yet it only took
him him four pathetic minutes to tell
the boy everything he knew the boy
knowing still that something about the
hermit was unnatural asked how he came
to be in this position The Hermit told
the boy he was the counterbalance a kind
of Chosen One destined to face and
perhaps even defeat the black moon
someday the counterbalance receives a
number of truly extraordinary gifts for
inheriting the responsibility eternal
life eternal youth near physical
immortality but they will be haunted by
their purpose doomed to watch everyone
they love die around them as they
continue to hunt their only true equal
and opposite the black moon itself The
Hermit in his own eyes had failed at his
duty he had grown weary and now he
needed to pass the duty of
counterbalance on to another that other
would be the boy he felt a sudden and
profound change along with the knowledge
that nothing would ever be the same
again he was no longer just the boy now
he was the counterbalance he watched The
Hermit give him a slight nod of respect
and then crumble into dust before his
eyes the boy the counterbalance looked
up at the sky and saw the Stars
twinkling so bright and so beautiful
little did he know his battle with the
black moon would Outlast every single
one of them does the black moon howl not
without blood the boy grew into a man as
his village aged and then died around
him decades past then centuries then
Millennia tens of thousands of years
watching Humanity develop and grow
around him as he continued his pursuit
of that one elusive foe as science and
diagnostic technology gained ground
absorbing and then evolving beyond all
the old superstitions the counterbalance
gained a better understanding of the
black moon though even then it still
remained essentially a stranger The
Entity was entropic a being of pure
Randomness and Chaos without consistent
form it didn't exist in our universe but
it could exercise its influence here
with socalled obliteration events much
like the horrible fate that befell the
young hunter from the village but that
was only the proverbial tip of the
iceberg the counterbalance tracked and
noted obliteration events they were
exceedingly rare at first something that
occurred once every thousand years or so
like a terrible curse but he couldn't
helpa notice a concerning Trend emerging
it started happening once a century then
once a decade he could feel the terrible
future stretching out in front of him
how over their shared eternity the black
moon would gain more and more ground
would there come a day where it took
someone once a year once a month a week
a day an hour a minute a second it'd
spell the end of all conscious life a
total victory for the black moon the end
of the universe the death of Ages a
complete existential obliteration he was
swept up in a sobering realization he
couldn't win this fight alone however
while his hunt for the black moon had
been largely fruitless the
counterbalance had discovered many other
things along the way strange creatures
objects with extraordinary powers and
events that couldn't be explained with
rational science perhaps something about
these Oddities these anomalies would
hold the key to defeating his Timeless
enemy and it hadn't just been these
objects entities and events he'd also
discovered some truly exceptional people
on his travels minds and skills that
rivaled even his own despite his age
perhaps they would be the ones to help
him win with the 13 most brilliant and
trusted people the counterbalance ever
met he decided to form a council and
from this Council they forged and
directed an organization dedicated to
understanding and counteracting the
strange in all its forms with the secret
hope that their surch Into Darkness
would yield the answer to the black
Moon's downfall he called it the SCP
Foundation they would secure the
anomalous contain it and protect all of
humanity from its influence
the counterbalance also took on a new
title be fitting of his new role the
administrator and even the black moon
itself was given a moniker in hopes of
robbing it of some of its frightening
power SCP
001 does the black moon howl only at the
blind the year was now 1987 the SCP
Foundation had been operating for over a
century and thanks to their secret
possession of anomalous wisdom and
Technology ology their own advancement
was thousands of years ahead of the rest
of humanity well there still wasn't a
silver bullet solution to the black moon
and its deadly howls were becoming all
the more frequent as the decades went on
the foundation did have some irons in
the fire to combat it their ability to
gather Intel on both the entity itself
and its obliteration events had improved
considerably thanks to their new Global
Information Network their top Minds were
also working on a highly classified
device known known as the singular
conceptual bunker which may one day come
in handy for combating the
extradimensional entity directly but the
most valuable piece of information they
ever gathered about the black moon was
this it couldn't howl when it was being
watched the very Act of engaged
observation defanged it the problem is
How Can You observe something that
doesn't technically exist inside your
own reality in order to pull this off
the foundation would need to get
extremely creative thankfully Creative
Solutions to strange problems are the
foundation's specialty Flash Forward to
1993 enter Dr Moto a brilliant young
scientist and conceptual engineer
working for the SCP Foundation with the
administrator's consultation he started
the key project an arm of the wider
project aases the umbrella Initiative
for using modified anomalous objects in
the battle against the black moon the
goal of the key project was relatively
simple
if people couldn't observe the black
moon directly then the foundation could
make proxies of the black moon that
could be observed almost like a kind of
voodoo doll these new anomalies would
only need to satisfy three criteria the
inability to operate when being observed
a hostility to conscious life and the
ability to end conscious life of their
own valtion when not being observed
through conceptual engineering a link
theoretically could be forged between
these objects and the black moon
allowing observation of them to stop the
obliteration events however despite
being a good idea in theory Dr Moto's
efforts were marred with errors and
tragedies one object wasn't deadly
enough simply appearing behind people in
a threatening pose when they weren't
looking another one killed purely
through collateral damage a giant
sculpture of a human head that
immediately attempted Escape by barging
through sight 01 the center for
anti-black Moon operations and killing
19 people in the process another one of
Moto's objects a huge black sphere
simply immediately exploded killing 12
people and in the most horrific misstep
of all one of Moto's objects caused a
mass death event in a nearby hotel where
142 people were spontaneously
incinerated when the object a series of
interlocking stalagtites and stalagmites
were left unobserved for 2 seconds
almost all of Moto's objects were
terminated in the aftermath either being
too useless or too dangerous to keep
around the young scientist felt a deep
shame but forged on he made one truly
brilliant creation that satisfied all
the criteria a sculpture incapable of
moving while being watched but would
snap the neck of the nearest conscious
entity if it left unobserved for even a
fraction of a second its relatively
minimal killing left it easy to contain
without causing Mass deaths and despite
all the other deaths that had sadly
occurred during the key project Dr Moto
believed that the lives saved in the
long run by stopping the black Moon's
howls would justify the sacrifice the
problem is the key project didn't stop
anything not long after this there was
the first recorded double obliteration
event in Rome where a young tourist
couple had both been obliterated
simultaneously all the deaths in the key
project had been for nothing the black
moon was only getting more powerful the
shame and the guilt was too much for Dr
modotto he left a note in his office
Reading we've been looking at nothing
I'm sorry administrator I failed you sir
Moto corpse was later found in the
sculptures temporary containment chamber
his neck snapped the key project was in
summary shut down and its one surviving
creation transported to site 19 in late
1993 where it was designated as SCP
173 another painful failure for the
administrator back to the drawing board
once more does the black moon howl not
while the stars shine Millennia
stretched on almost everyone died except
the administrator thanks to his gift or
perhaps curse as the counter balance to
the black moon science marched on the
SCP Foundation marched on but all this
progress all this power was nothing
against the incomprehensible influence
of SCP
001 the black moon was howling more
frequently than ever all the way up to
the year
3156 when the the foundation launched
the seek project under the support of
project orastes as more and more people
were wiped out in frequent obliteration
events the administrator became
painfully aware that perhaps the answers
to the black moon problem wouldn't be
found on Earth using state of the art
technology With a Little Help from the
anomalous the SCP Foundation began work
on an autonomous space fairing vessel
that could search the stars for the key
to the black Moon's destruction it was
an on inspiring creation
a huge craft powered by artificial
intelligence with a universal translator
cogenic units and hundreds of autonomous
drones to perform more targeted searches
seek was waved off into the unforgiving
depths of space the administrator could
only hope that it would come back with
worthwhile answers the first of the
three notable planets see derived on was
one theoretically capable of supporting
human life except for its brutal and
constant blizzards and snow storms when
seek drones were deployed they did
discover signs of civilization based
around sentient spherical creatures but
no signs of actual life remained records
and statues found across the planet
seemed to indicate that the black moon
was responsible for the destruction of
the planet's civilization causing so
many obliteration events that the
remaining survivors went mad from the
fear and stress leading to mass death in
the ensuing chaos the next planet was
discovered centuries later in the year
34.99 while this planet could also
theoretically support human life it
suffered from frequent volcanic
eruptions that rendered much of its
surface a flaming Mass however there
were still the dormant ruins of a once
Advanced civilization of conscious
beings much like the prior Planet they
had been driven extinct by Black Moon
obliteration events a century before the
seek even arrived unlike the last planet
however it seems that they accepted
their fate and went gently into the
night the planet was now overrun by
billions of armored bat-like creatures
that operated on pure Instinct and thus
were not considered conscious enough to
be obliterated the final planet was
reached in
3764 and was the most fruitful of the
three discoveries this planet was hyper
Advanced fully urbanized and covered in
sprawling mega cities with records and
Technology over a thousand years ahead
of Earth before the black moon killed
almost all of them there were a species
of humanoid telepathic fungi and had
developed an awareness of the black
Moon's existence that was on par with
that of humanities they even had their
own equivalent of the SCP Foundation
actively working on countermeasures and
most amazingly of all seik found one
surviving member of the species on the
planet cryogenically frozen the craft
was immediately instructed to collect
the Survivor and return home for
interrogation the administrator Was
preparing for what could be the most
important conversation since he met the
hermit all those thousands of years ago
does the black moon howl only when
waning when the surviving creature
codeen Nam saged was returned to Earth
the administrator was eager to finally
speak with it like the rest of its now
extinct species Sage spoke through
powerful telepathic mind waves which
only the administrator thanks to his
counterbalance abilities was able to
receive at close range without being
harmed incidentally it wasn't long until
the very fact of the administrator's
nature as a counterbalance came up in
the mental conversation
Sage could tell just by being in his
presence they discovered a number of
vital truths over their brief time
communicating that Sage's survival had
been pure luck for starters the black
moon is still very much capable of
obliterating conscious beings in an
unconscious State the administrator also
learned that he was merely the latest in
an extremely long line of
counterbalances across time space and
species though everyone but him had
waved this Duty passed it on Sage had
one question to ask the administrator in
turn what is
SCB the singular conceptual bunker being
worked on and perfected for thousands of
years by now by the foundation's top
scientists and conceptual Engineers the
administrator replied Victory but it
will take a very very long time
specifically so long that he would see
the stars go out around him one by one
shocked saged asked him what good
victory would do him then rather than
say it aloud he replied with a thought
Sage paused and said I see how
Blasphemous of you hopefully it works
after this the administrator proceeded
to the singular conceptual bunker and
entered it leaving instructions for the
foundation to be run by a newly formed
05 Council in his indefinite absence
thousands of years later in the year 51
Sage spoke one more time repeating the
words hopefully hopefully before tur
turning solid black and disappearing the
black moon had claimed one more victim
but billions more had gone in the
interim the administrator had no more
answers to give at least no more answers
that anyone but him would understand he
was inside the singular conceptual
bunker now loaded into a device known as
toome an experimental Memorial module
meant to pick up and record all the last
messages of every dying civilization
Across the Universe when the time fin
finally came all he could do was wait
and wait was exactly what we did does
the black moon howl yes yes it does
years pass too many to count it's a time
after names now and to sits in the very
center drinking in the end of the
universe the last of all the human
colonies Across the Universe were
obliterated by the Black Moon back in
the year
7329 so so so long ago but some of the
final messages of fear panic and
distress still echoed around in the
administrator's mind hello is there
anyone here we require assistance
there's it's it's taking people every
day we need help there's barely anyone
left we need help hello hello cabal 0943
we have abandoned the false flesh we
have abandoned the false flesh the
shepherd's crook broken Neath my knee
cabal 0943 cabal 0943 forgive us forgive
us we're going to leave this on it's so
dark outside now it's blotted out the
sun it's I have to go now respond First
Convenience emergency situation
developing require additional resources
my fault your fault our fault my fault
your fault our fault my fault your fault
our fault rip my brain out now rip my
brain out now and a small child the last
on Earth simply ask asking hello into an
indifferent microphone but the
administrator had to wait as the
singular conceptual bunker became the
solitary conceptual bunker he was the
last conscious being in the universe and
still he needed to wait as the Stars
went dark outside only when there was
nothing outside but black was it finally
time for the counterbalances long game
to play off there was nothing left of
our universe the only thing here was the
SCB and the black moon itself with
everything else gone the black moon only
had one conscious being left to
obliterate it opened the door to the
solitary conceptual bunker and stepped
inside this this doesn't make sense how
can the black moon an entity beyond our
Dimension Beyond physical form take a
step good question the same question
incidentally that was going through the
black Moon's mind as it entered the
bunker it didn't look at all how the
entity expected it was like a bar a
counter with rows of bottles behind it a
jukebox playing in the corner a man
stood behind the bar cleaning the
glasses the counterbalance the
administrator he said well there you are
certainly took your time can I pour you
a little something this only served to
increase the black Moon's confusion it
had form here dark smoke compressed into
a vaguely humanoid shape it could speak
it could think none of this made any
sense the being that had just wiped out
all conscious life and seen the very
death of the universe was truly and
utterly confused the administrator just
seemed to be enjoying himself preparing
for a confrontation hundreds of billions
of years in the making the singular
conceptual bunker or perhaps the
singular containment bunker was a truly
ingenious creation a place of pure ideas
where everything inside was on the same
level here there were no Immortals no
Gods just ideas on the same Level
Playing Field and it was time for the
black Moon's idea to come to an end it
was a trap and the entire universe was
the bait without warning the
administrator pulled up a shotgun from
underneath the table and Unleashed both
barrels into the black Moon's chest the
creature took the headit and fought back
dragging the administrator to the ground
beating him strangling him he could feel
the light fading under the monster's
Relentless assault until he managed to
get his desperate hands on a glass
ashtray he beat the monster over the
head with it until its grip loosened and
he was able to slide out there the
killer of the universe was on the ground
before him he grabbed the monster held
it in place and beat it to death he was
Gravely injured by the battle but the
black moon was no more here in the
singular conceptual bunker
he had won the administrator no longer
the counterbalance in the absence of the
black moon hobbled over to the Jukebox
produced a single beautiful coin from
his pocket he pushed the coin into the
slot wheezed a pain breath and said the
thing is this place is only
information there's nothing else out
there not even matter the universe
closed its doors a long time ago but
this place can go from information back
to matter with just the Press of a
button let's see what happens when we
introduce something to nothing for a
second it looks as though he might fall
but he doesn't instead he slams the
button on the juke box and with a
relieve laugh says let there be light
and there was light any changes today
the younger security officer Zach asked
as he stepped into the Watchtower as if
replied his Superior a jaded cynical old
man who insisted on being referred to as
Mr Jefferson the darn thing hasn't moved
spoken or done so much as stretch one of
those wings of his another day at the
office then Zach jumped through the
window the pair of them looked through
at the Towering figure a few kilm away
SCP 001 the gate Guardian stood
motionless its fiery sword in its hand
ever protecting its post at the
precipice between our world and Paradise
it had long been stationed at the
entrance of a dimensional Gateway that
led to what was believed to be the
Garden of Eden described in the biblical
Old Testament much like the security
officers in the foundation's base tasked
with watching The Guardian this was
pretty much the extent of the day's
activities hey did you see that news
about the uh transfer posting Zach asked
trying to Stave off boredom with as much
conversation he could squeeze out of his
fellow officer yeah I saw it Mr
Jefferson scoffed rolling his eyes what
possess is someone like Robert Monto to
come down here and must have wanted a
quieter post Zach reasoned looking out
at the Stillness of the gate Guardian
won't find one any quieter than here
Jefferson mused him showing up will be
the most exciting thing that's happened
here in a long while unbeknownst to both
Zach and Mr Jefferson Dr Robert Monto
would be only joining the team at the
gate Guardian observation site for a
short while not one of them nor anybody
else within the foundation could ever
guess monto's true intentions behind
venturing there in the first place he
wanted an audience with the gate
Guardian itself approaching the Colossal
thft tall being Dr Monto crossed the
threshold of the minimum safe distance
from the guardian given the sheer heat
of its weapon hotter than Earth's sun
anything within a kilometer of SCP 001
was at risk of being obliterated
vaporized into Adams if they didn't turn
back which through a voice that
immediately rang out in monto's ears the
gate Guardian commanded him to
do it psychic message boomed wait wait
Dr Monto urged holding up his hands in
what would have been a futile defense
against the Guardian Sword I know what
you do when people don't listen to your
commands but please just give me a
minute there was silence SCP 001 didn't
reply there was nobody else close enough
to hear Monto speak to it so he
continued you are impossibly old we know
that much about you and because of that
you must have seen things that we can't
even begin to imagine much less fully
comprehend but I've come a very long way
to request that you impart some
information to me if you can he paused
again as if waiting for a reply that
never came the gate Guardian merely
stood in the same defensive unwavering
stance tell me please how much do you
know about the Scarlet King by this
point in time I'll although the
foundation was yet to realize Dr Robert
Monto was slowly going insane his
investigations into an anomalous entity
known as The Scarlet King were gradually
corrupting him as he tried relentlessly
to quantify exactly what this entity was
and how great of a threat it posed
little did monok realize that in trying
so hard to Define and comprehend the
being he was inadvertently fueling its
power the Scarlet King was an
interdimensional warmonger an embodiment
of hatred and chaos and Dr Robert Monto
was slowly falling under the king's
influence upon hearing the tiny human
figure utter his question the immens
gate Guardian rebed with another single
word psychic command one it had never
been recorded giving before
witness as if his increasing instability
and the creeping influence of the
Scarlet King hadn't made Monto feel bad
enough he instantly felt sick there was
a searing pain behind his eyes like he
was staring directly at the sun
accompanied by a nausea that made his
head spin it took a moment of enduring
the horrific sensation before he
realized what was happening the guardian
was trying to show him something rather
than give any information on the Scarlet
King verbally SCP 001 was imparting a
psychic Vision onto Monto a memory of
events long past the answers he s a
warning or perhaps all three the vision
showed Mont a time so long ago that it
couldn't ever be forgotten for there was
barely anyone alive to remember it in
the first place it was eons in the past
long before the comparatively recent
dawn of humanity a time only spoken of
in the dust and blood tablet an artifact
of the dite civilization some of the
earliest worshippers of the Scarlet King
himself and there marching up to the
entrance of Eden was the Crimson clad
eldrich of Abomination and a horde of
Horrors with him according to the story
recorded in the dust and blood tablet
this would have been much earlier in the
life of the Scarlet King perhaps even
before he assumed his now Infamous title
back then he would most likely have been
known as his original name of KRA one of
multiple siblings born when the tree of
life was planted and thus created all
life in the Multiverse but being the
only one of his siblings cursed with
awareness knowing the pain his ex
existence brought him krock would
eventually set out on his lifelong
mission to destroy all of existence
across every Dimension and he started by
killing his siblings consuming them to
claim their power for himself around
this time in prehistory the being that
would one day become known as Scarlet
King didn't quite possess the power that
he would several Millennia later
although that's not to say he was an
unformidable force of Destruction fueled
by his singular hatred for existence his
Val to destroy extended to the tree of
life that had caused him to be along
with the tree's Creator and all of their
Creation in other words everything in
the Multiverse all of creation if you
will so what was the Scarlet King doing
there so long ago at the dimensional
doorway protected by the gate Guardian
well beyond the boundary between it and
the rest of the infinite Multiverse lay
the supposed Garden of Eden while it is
unknown if it is in fact the same Eden
referred to in the Book of Genesis is Up
For Debate especially among the
foundation but at a glance even through
the gate it certainly does look like a
paradise the space is filled with Lush
vegetation of astronomical size
populated by a number of beings that
seem to resemble the gate Guardian
itself and there protected by its
watchful caretaker are two trees one is
thought to be the tree of knowledge that
Eve was tricked into eating an apple
from during the Book of Genesis the the
other however Bears an unknown type of
fruit and is widely believed to be the
tree of life now back in the Modern Age
there's never been a conclusive link
between the Tree of Life mentioned by
the davit and their barbaric
civilizations Legends regarding the
creation of the Scarlet King but the
fact that so long ago he and his most
feared generals were bearing down on the
gate guardian's position defending a
garden where there was known to be a
tree of that description well it all
seems rather conclusive now
alongside karak were six of his Seven
Daughters each one of them a fearsome
Abomination much like their destructive
father as they approached not one needed
to exchange any words with their Angelic
protector of Eden the gate Guardian knew
what these monsters were here for they
would stop at nothing to pass through
his gate and uproot the Tree of Life the
progenitor of all living beings in all
of existence even though it was early in
kck's career as the rampaging
interdimensional warlord he so is he was
as steadfast as ever in his goal to
annihilate every corner of creation
every Dimension every parallel plane of
reality every single pocket of existence
across Infinity they'd all come undone
if he burned the Tree of Life pulled it
out at the roots and splintered it until
nothing remained to The Once and Future
Scarlet King that the same tree had led
to his own tortured existence it was the
source of his suffering and it had to be
destroyed the only thing standing in his
way was a figure as colossal as karak
himself wielding a flaming
sword boomed the psychic voice of the
gate Guardian it was like a doorman
standing before a group of Rowdy
teenagers trying to force their way into
a movie theater except these Rowdy teens
were the Scarlet King his horrifying
daughters and the forces he had already
amassed since his Creation The Horde
stood ready waiting for the commands of
their King who they thought would gladly
lead the charge as they marched on the
Garden of Eden to begin the destruction
of existence but that's not what
happened usually the Scarlet king would
never shy away from a fight preferring
to lead the charge when it came to a
Slaughter instead he commanded his first
daughter AIC to commence the first
attack on the protector who stood in
their path on her foul father's word AIC
took her horde and charged at the
guardian what she and her forces lacked
in numerical Advantage aeic more than
made up for in her knowledge of War she
hungered for it sought Dominion that was
her seal after all and yet in the face
of this impending Onslaught the gate
Guardian remains still rooted to the
same spot it had as always and would
always be standing a number of aic's
minions burst into flames the very
fabric of their crude forms separated on
a molecular level as they were
effortlessly rendered into nothingness
still the gate Guardian hadn't appeared
to move an inch had exerted no energy
despite the damage it had done to AIC
and her forces in defense of Eden as his
first daughter screeched and howled in
despair at the decimation of her horn
her children the Scarlet King decided he
needed to better understand his opponent
with a wave of his clawed Crimson hand
the king commanded his next daughter
Alor to send forth her own Army in a
tidal wave of nightmarish creatures agor
sent her horrific children into battle
she possessed a far greater quantity to
do battle on her father's behalf perhaps
akar even believed that was the Scot
King's plan with a greater number of her
forces over her sisters maybe she would
be able to overwhelm the guardian but
even as her own children began to be
vaporized the closer that they got to
the gate agor had no idea she was little
more than a pawn being sacrificed so
that KRA could learn more about his
imposing Angelic enemy another of the
Scarlet King's Daughters a being known
as anit was the next called up to
contribute to the unfolding battle
although to call it a battle under SS
just how easily the gate Guardians
seemed to be eliminating the oncoming
forces without even moving while an
outwardly frail seeming creature anu's
primary strength over her sisters was a
Proficiency in Magic her Nate ability to
warp and reshape reality around her it
was that power that had caused her
father to be wary of her viewing anu's
abilities as a threat to his leadership
and so KRA had her crippled and all her
children leaving them unable to
overthrow him but still loyal to their
King obeying her father's command
perhaps out of the same loyalty or fear
that he would harm her and her children
further if she disobeyed Anu unfurled
her magic she reshaped the world around
them making it so that the passage of
time moves so much slower and that was
what revealed to the Scarlet King his
enemy's greatest strength in com combat
the gate Guardian had so far been able
to obliterate both AIC and now ao's
forces without seeming to move but it
wasn't by standing still it was moving
just much faster than the blink of
scarlet King's multiple eyes now that
un's magic had slowed the passage of
time the gate Guardian could be seen
doing battle as agar's atrocities
spilled towards the angel to try and
overwhelm it it effortlessly blocked the
oncoming attacks with its sword
everything the Flaming blade can Ed with
instantly evaporated bursting into atoms
as they were practically cleaved out of
existence by the gate guardian's Mighty
weapon even with time slowed to a crawl
The Towering winged protector of Eden
only appeared to be moving at an average
speed but when time flowed normally
without ANH manipulating reality the
guardian was simply too fast to be
observed resisting the urge to dive head
first into the fight himself the Scarlet
King knew it would likely lead to his
untimely demise eyes he refused to
accept that it could not happen but he
still had yet to amass the strength he
would need as he continued his Ascent so
while time was slow to a crawl and the
gate Guardian was still engaged in
combat with agoro's forces he turned to
another of his remaining daughters
adista if the Scarlet King and his
forces couldn't get past the guardian
they could still try to get to the Tree
of Life while the protector's focus was
diverted aiston Unleashed a wave of
pestilence sickness and disease spewing
from her in a cloud of vapor heading
straight towards the Angelic garden and
Eden's entrance Beyond The Scarlet King
knew this latest attack wouldn't phase
or weaken the gate Guardian he hoped the
foul smog would instead pass through the
Gateway itself into the garden as adad
sent forth her power blood and Ash
soaked the landscape around them all the
plants outside the entrance to Eden
withered and died shriveling and
decomposing as the disgusting fog rolled
towards the gate it washed over the
guardian whose form only seemed to Glow
brighter as he repelled the pestilence
it was as if it didn't even need to
think about it still focused on
finishing off the rest of the oncoming
Army as its glow intensified so did the
fiery sword that the gate Guardian swung
with ease and finesse flames burst from
the blade the encroaching fumes Catching
Fire along with the air itself it
ignited in a wave of fire a defensive
Inferno that repelled this latest attack
but for a brief few moments while time
stayed slow before anu's hold on reality
inevitably broke the king had sent forth
aif of all his spawn she was the most
reserved keeping mostly to herself never
speaking she and her children could
change their faces and forms shift into
anything or anyone and walk undetected
through the Multiverse and now her
father was employing her incredible
stealth of abilities to slip Behind
Enemy Lines while the gate Guardian was
finishing off the remaining Onslaught
from kck's other daughters it was as aif
Drew near creeping unseen closer and
closer to the entrance keeping the
Scarlet King out of Eden that the
guardian seemed to pause it slowly
ominously turned its huge head tilting
until it was looking directly at aif if
its expression could be seen maybe the
gate Guardian would almost be impressed
that someone was able to to sneak past
it after all was a feat that no other
being in creation could ever hope to
accomplish but then again with its
steadfast conviction and dedication to
its protective Duty maybe it would have
looked upon atth with anger with a
cleaving swing of its scorching sword
the gate Guardian unfurled the tidal
wave of fire that engulfed everything
around it not just aif but aik aor and
adista all the king's daughters that had
attacked so far along with every one of
their own children were instantly
obliterated they were all reduced to
empty vacant spaces where they had once
been their atoms separated by the
Searing swing of the guardian's weapon
the devastating Blow by his adversary
did little to deter the Scarlet King
from his mission he was still set on
destroying the tree of life and no loss
was too great in his pursuit of
destroying existence he barely cared
that four of his own daughters had just
been unmade by the guardian anit was
still there Clinging On to time as if it
were a thrashing animal the Scarlet King
could simply make her restore her Fallen
sisters and their forces he had lost
nothing but had held back for too long
and slowly drew his own weapon out of
thin air wielding a sword that was as
blood soaked as the Guardians was hot
the Scarlet King locked blades with the
one being standing in their way both the
ancient Angelic Defender and the
attacking eldrich Abomination were
evenly matched every one of their
vicious strikes against the other met
with an equally strong Parry a weapon of
extreme allc consuming heat blocked
swipes from a sharp serrated edge that
matched the Deep Red that would be
forever synonymous with conrock the
force of their two swords clashing and
striking each other was so great that it
rippled out from their one-on-one fight
the landscape around them was flattened
wiped clean of any remaining plant life
that hadn't already been destroyed by
the forces of the King's Daughters
despite having acquired nowhere near the
power he would thousands of years after
this fight the Scarlet King was still a
formidable force in single combat and
yet the gate Guardian seemed incapable
of tiring or weakening still standing
strong against the onslaught even after
wiping multiple armies out with its
flaming sword the guardian was still
able to hold its own against the scarlot
king who was Furious enraged at being so
close to the tree of life yet unable to
get past his Angelic adversary he need
to be stronger faster even more ruthless
than the warlord he already was despite
unit's slowing down time the king and
the guardian were at a stalemate time
that was it the Scarlet King needed more
time withdrawing from the fight he
realized that this was a battle that
could not be won by sheer Brute Force
alone his mission to destroy all
creation to get to the Tree of Life
would take cunning deception and more
time if he let it the gate Guardian
could easily kill kro its flaming weapon
could cleave him out of existence and
that would end the king's torment but it
wouldn't be enough a death would be
unsatisfying knowing that the rest of
existence would go on after he was gone
the Scarlet King couldn't accept that it
wasn't enough so he did the one thing
nobody would expect of him he made a
deal with the gate Guardian it was an
action still fueled by his infinite
hatred for all existence his yearning
for total chaos the Scarlet King knew
that one day an event would arrive where
the guardian and the other beings like
it in the Garden of Eden would spill
forth and deliver judgment on this world
and when that Rapture happened the tree
of life would be undefended the Scarlet
King Bartered with the guardian that he
would Retreat for the time being so he
could spend eon's amassing more more
power then when the fateful day arrived
the gate Guardian would allow him into
Eden to destroy the Tree of Life while
it and its Brethren were busy conducting
the Rapture halting their fight the
Scarlet King offered a crimson claw to
the gate guardian's burning hand
returning to reality from the intense
Vision still feeling sick at what he had
witnessed Robert Monto looked up at the
still silent form of the gate Guardian
did you do it he yelled desperate to
know more through through his obsession
with the Scarlet King did you tell him
yes did you make a deal there was no
answer from the guardian just a single
word that echoed through monto's
fractured
mind the Scarlet King is a really bad
guy he's a giant interdimensional
nightmare God intent on breaching our
reality and Wrecking terrible havoc on
everything we know and love he's been
responsible for Untold suffering and
Chaos across countless worlds timelines
and layers of reality to many he's even
somewhat of a final boss to the SCP
Foundation and just when you think he
couldn't get any worse it turns out that
he's also a dead beat dad not only did
the Scarlet King once have a cult
literally named the children of the
Scarlet King before it was destroyed by
Dr Monto and the SCP Foundation he also
had at least seven actual children each
one is speculated to be a powerful
anomaly but it's tough to find concrete
answers as to who or what exactly most
of them are so today we're putting on
our researcher hats and digging deep
into the foundation's lore to present
our theories on the potential progyny of
the SCP foundation's greatest enemy and
if nothing else we may finally be able
to get this dark lord of all evil to
start paying all the child support he
probably owes by now first if you're not
well versed in Scarlet King Vore you may
be wondering how exactly does an evil
chaos God have kids is there a Scarlet
Queen out there who prefers to stay out
of the Limelight the answer isn't quite
that simple and it has everything to do
with SCP 231 and Big Red's most devoted
cult the non-biological Children of the
Scarlet King they kidnapped a group of
seven girls and performed a number of
dark rituals that resulted in them
becoming vessels for the Scarlet King
seven terrible kids these seven girls
have become known as SCP 231 anyone who
accesses those files and trust us they
aren't a pretty sight we'll find that
the containment procedures mostly
involve performing the infamous Monto
procedure on the surviving girls to keep
them from giving birth six of the Seven
Brides have given birth to nightmares
Beyond Comprehension and are now dead
with only one still remaining
successfully contained but here at the
SCP Foundation you need to learn to
comprehend the
incomprehensible according to a
classified document SCP 231 May
technically be a neutralized anomaly
without us even knowing and incidentally
this gives us our most certain answer on
the children of the Scarlet King on this
one the Apple fell very very far from
the tree according to the secret
document SCP 999 that's right the
adorable Tickle Monster is the seventh
child of the Scarlet King he must be so
disappointed that everyone's favorite
little blob didn't want to join the
family business of absolute evil for
anyone who doesn't know SCP 99 99 is a
slimy yellow entity that only seems
capable of absolute compassion it brings
joy to everyone in its presence and with
prolonged exposure it can even cure
disorders like PTSD anxiety and
depression he's so good at this that he
even cured SCP
2317 his deao mother of her trauma and
allowed her to return happily to her
family after some amnestic treatment the
Scarlet King has another good reason to
be ashamed of his cheerful Blobby son
ancient DVID prophecy dictates that SCP
999 May someday become so powerful that
is force of absolute love and good
overwhelms the Scarlet King's evil and
Chaos think of him as the Luke Skywalker
to the Scarlet King's Darth Vader though
we probably can expect a cool lightsaber
battle between them anytime soon how
disappointing so if SCP 999 is the quiet
sensitive black sheep of the Scarlet
family who's The Golden Child who makes
his evil father proud the real chip off
the old block that would be our dear
reptilian friend SCP 682 the malicious
lizard heavily implied to be a child of
the Scarlet King if you know literally
anything about 682 your reaction to
finding out that he's the spawn of
Cruelty personified is probably yeah
that makes sense just as SCP 999 is the
Scarlet King's innocent optimistic young
child 682 is kind of like his edgy
teenager still in the middle of a
misanthropic phase he shows no sign of
leaving anytime soon the fact that 682
appears to find anything about the world
around him utterly disgusting seems to
be a trade he inherited from his dear
old dad and the fact he seems pretty
much impossible to kill also lends
Credence to the popular Theory he's got
nightmare God blood running through his
veins 682 has also started displaying a
particular hatred for 999 ever since an
incident where 999 tickled him into
submission so family dinners are
probably extra awkward for these to 999
and 682 are the most certain children
but that still leaves us with five more
children to identify it's worth
remembering that the waters are murkier
from here on in but we've searched far
and wide through the foundation archives
to find possible answers if your
interpretation differs remember that
it's just a theory an SCP explained
Theory thankfully we do have some
assistance here the taale dust and blood
hinted at what each of the seven
children of the Scarlet King represents
and that may help us narrow down our
choices here to put things into
perspective it's believed that 682 was
the fourth child to be born representing
wrath and 999 was the seventh
representing hope according to this Tale
the first of the seven children
represents dominion and as a result is
skilled in the ways of war and has the
power to lead the king's forces to
Victory according to One Foundation
theorist this child could potentially be
scp2 39 also known as the witch child
this entity is so powerful that as part
of its normal containment procedures
it's eternally kept in a coma why
because this seemingly normal child has
dominion over reality and can change it
to her whims her thoughts are so
powerful that just her brain waves can
damage physical matter and she can make
things disappear or manifest in an
instant she's also impossible to kill
with skin that's almost totally
impenetrable much like SCP 682 she's
also frighteningly strong in both the
offense and defense department we're
talking about such a powerful telepath
that Dr klef has campaigned for her
immediate termination just because it's
safer that way this is certainly a
frightening wonderin that the Scarlet
king would be proud to call his daughter
next the second child according to the
prophecy this child represents longing
the child has the power to bring forth
armies which will help the Scarlet King
in his Conquest for this we actually
have a pretty unconventional Theory SCP
029 also known as the daughter of
Darkness if the name alone wasn't enough
to suggest that she's got an extremely
Sinister father she also fits the
profile of being very aggressive and
incredibly hard to kill but even more
damning is her connections to the
symbology of longing one of her most
dangerous Powers is causing men to fall
into almost trans-like Devotion to her
after spending time around her they're
suddenly willing to murder in her honor
strangling their victims in hopes of
raising Ki the Hindu God of destruction
whom has many similarities to the
Scarlet King she certainly fits the bill
of someone capable of raising armies in
the Dark Lord's name one strike against
our Scarlet King connection theory is
that the file States the daughter of
Darkness was first discovered in India
which wouldn't match up with the other
information we know to be fact however
while this is a long shot given the
sensitive nature of everything involving
the the Scarlet King it's extremely
possible that false information was
supplied to bury the connection
considering the coverups and lies
involving anomalies like SCP 1000 this
certainly isn't an unprecedented move on
the part of the foundation next the
third child this child is associated
with all things desolation implying
destruction fire ashes pestilence and
death across the battlefield when it
comes to spreading destruction and Death
on a mass scale one part particular SCP
comes to mind SCP
058 the Heart of Darkness this creature
has Scarlet King written all over it
it's evil it's mysterious it's pretty
much impossible to kill and it causes
Mass casualties every time it escapes
its containment chamber it causes fires
whips people to death with its razor
sharp tendrils and sprays highly
corrosive acid from its scorpion likee
tail and it's even red given that that
we know for a fact this entity suddenly
emerged out of something that's now been
expunged from the records in an
undisclosed site it's extremely possible
that the entity 058 came from was SCP
058 next skipping past SCP 682 at number
four the fifth child of the Scarlet King
is associated with the loose concept of
lack the prophecy then goes into more
detail saying that this child is
powerful in the ways of magic and is
able to use their abilities to cause
great destruction here we have another
unconventional proposal what if child
number five was an actually a child but
children that's because we think this
description perfectly fits SCP P
1765 the nightmarish reality warping
sisters who we think may actually be
Triplets of the Scarlet King's fifth
bride now hear us out these are actually
some of the most powerful enemies the
foundation has ever attempted to contain
and we know nothing about their past
before being bound to a few objects by
the Serpent's hand these sadistic
reality warpers are so devastatingly
powerful that the only action the
foundation can take against them is
letting them have free Reign Over the
containment site they currently inhabit
all the foundation can do is hope they
never get bored of tormenting the people
inside as we all know the Scarlet King
despises science progress and order so
perhaps a perfect punishment for the
foundation in his many eyes is giving
them a taste of their own medicine the
sisters though particularly their ring
leader are a perverse shadow of the
foundation's love of the scientific
method they take these methods and use
them for an activity that the scar
Scarlet King finds much more enjoyable
tormenting and killing people whenever
these crafty triplets set their mind to
it their horrifically powerful magic is
able to cause massive Devastation just
like the prophecy for the fifth bride's
Offspring dictates and finally the sixth
child of the Scarlet King the concept
associated with this one is hidden
meaning it can change its face and walk
unnoticed through creation it's also
said to have the responsibility of
opening the ways between worlds and
allowing the war to end all wars to
first begin there have been a huge
number of guesses for this spot with
some even suggesting SCP 055 the anti-em
but since we're having fun here we also
want to make an even Wilder suggestion
we pait that the sixth child of the
Scarlet King is Allison Shia also known
as LS and the black queen the most
powerful member of the Serpent's hand we
get it we have a lot of explaining to do
but hear us out Allison Shia is a member
of the Serpent's hand or technically
many members multiple versions of her
exist across parallel dimensions in the
SCP Multiverse they're mostly all EST
strange Daughters of foundation
researcher Dr Charles Kars this
estrangement leads them to collaborate
in the wanderer's library the secret
base of the Serpent's hand to conduct
raids on the foundation in Revenge but
what if the leader of these alternate
Allison had an ulterior motive because
in the infinite number of possibilities
offered by the Multiverse this one was
not the daughter of Charles gears but
the Scarlet King she's merely using the
pain of her counterparts to manipulate
them into accomplishing her true
father's goal undermining the SCP
Foundation let's break it down the
hidden child is prophesies to walk
unnoticed through creation not only does
Alison Chow appear human the use of SCP
268 a news boy cap that causes the
wearer to become unnoticed all allows
her to walk anywhere through creation
without being detected but most
importantly of all the hidden child is
said to be the one who opens the way for
the Scarlet King's entrance into our
Dimension and Allison Chow has access to
the wanderer's library an unfettered
access point between Dimensions if one
of the infinite Allison was the secret
daughter of the Scarlet king would the
wanderer's library not be a perfect way
for him to leave his own Dimension and
enter ours she could be the final p he
needs hidden under the nose of the
foundation and the Serpent's hand making
all the secret power plays to allow for
the Scarlet King's eventual bloody
revenge on our world unless of course
SCP 999 the family disappointment stops
him first we realize that some of these
theories may seem surprising but when it
comes to the anomalous especially the
Scarlet King the only thing you can ever
expect is the unexpected do you agree
with our theories if not not who do you
think are the children of the Scarlet
King let us know down in the comments
one thing is for certain we hope we
never meet any of the terrible tyrants
nasty children except the Tickle Monster
of course he can hang with us anytime if
you've ever read the book of Genesis
which is the part of the Old Testament
that details God creating the world and
Humanity during a particularly busy week
then you might just be already familiar
with SCP 001 or at least one of the
anomalies that's been proposed for the
title of SCP
001 because of course SCP 001 doesn't
refer to a single creature object or
entity but rather a collection of
various anomalies contained by the SCP
Foundation anomalies sharing the name
SCP 001 include the infamous Scarlet
King a powerful alrich being intent on
ending all of creation that is thought
by Foundation researchers to be one of
the most dangerous beings in this and
any other unit universe but the Scarlet
King isn't the only incredibly powerful
being categorized as SCP 001 in fact
there are plenty of other anomalies with
similar levels of destructive power and
one such being is a creature codenamed
the gate Guardian standing at well over
1,000 ft tall the gate Guardian is
impossible to be fully contained by any
means that the foundation possesses the
anomaly itself despite its colossal size
is humanoid in its shape sporting wings
that rude from its back while it usually
has four of these SCP 001 has
historically been seen to have any
number of wings between 2 and 108
sprouting from various places over its
body including its shoulders ankles
wrists and even its temples this
gigantic Guardian also carries its own
weapon referred to as SCP
conducted by the foundation the
temperature of the Flames produced by
SCP 001 rivaled that of her very own son
for reference the sun has a core
temperature of over 27 million de F and
5,778 Kelvin at its surface or almost
10,000 de F you would expect a flaming
sword that burns hotter than the sun to
cause a considerable amount of damage
even if it wasn't in use but the Flames
emitted by the weapon leave no lasting
damage damage on the surrounding
environment it is capable though of
annihilating anything that Strays too
close to SCP 001 burning them so
intensely that their atoms literally
separate breaking potential attackers
apart on a molecular level much as its
code name suggests the gate Guardian
stands solemnly at the threshold of some
form of dimensional Gateway which is
equally tall as s CP 001 itself behind
the guardian is a lush Grove abundant
with fruit trees of astronomical size as
well as other beings that share a
similar appearance to SCP
001 this Grove is thought to be the
Garden of Eden the paradise that God
created and that was inhabited by Adam
and Eve the first two humans in
existence according to the Book of
Genesis as the tale goes the pair were
created by God himself and permitted to
live in the Garden of Eden as long as
they followed a single rule Adam and Eve
were instructed not to eat any of the
fruit That Grew From certain trees that
God had specified within view just
behind the gate Guardian are two immense
trees one bearing apples and the other
bearing different fruit of an unknown
type the one that looks like an apple
tree is believed even by some in the
foundation to be the biblical tree of
knowledge that Eve was convinced to pick
a fateful Apple from after an encounter
with a snake the other the one with
unidentifiable fruit is thought to be
the tree of life however this is all
speculation since it is currently
impossible to venture through this
Gateway and verify if the realm Beyond
is truly the Bible's own Garden of Eden
this is largely because anything that
breaches a kilometer wide radius of SCP
001 is instantly vaporized the gate
Guardian attacks with imperceptible
speed using its flaming sword to Smite
any person that gets too close the
guardian actually moves so fast that it
can hardly be seen with the naked eye it
appears to always remain in its solid
dutiful stance with its weapon drawn and
head bowed only shifting for a fraction
of a nond to attack ranged attacks
against the guardian are just as
ineffective with all projectiles fired
at SCP 001 reduced to atoms before they
can do any harm even if said projectile
happens to be a nuclear weapon the gate
Guardian will be able to sub atomically
vaporize both the projectile itself as
well as the person who sent it
regardless of how far away they are all
while not appearing to to lift a finger
during an experiment involving SCP 001
on December 26th 2004 an SCP Foundation
nuclear submarine called Nautilus
launched a series of multi- Warhead
intercontinental ballistic missiles at
the gate Guardian the retaliation from
the guardian resulted not only in the
deaths of approximately 35,000 innocent
civilians but the blast is also believed
by some to have inadvertently caused the
2004 Boxing Day tsunami the severity of
this incident came dangerously close to
revealing the foundation's existence to
the world resulting in them rapidly
deploying any means necessary to erase
any trace of the 35,000 victim's
families friends and other related
individuals in order to avoid
questioning the SCP Foundation
administered amnestics on an almost
worldwide scale and the 05 Council
banned any further tests on SCP 001 that
involved nuclear weapons in what was
hoped by the foundation to to be a test
with lower Stakes they sent an
Expendable d-class Personnel towards SCP
001 the d-class approached the area
where the gate Guardian is located and
as soon as they saw it they could hear a
very clear command in their mind leave
the d-class Personnel reacted exactly
the same way you or I would they
promptly turned and started to walk away
they didn't need 1,000 foot tall entity
with a flaming sword to tell them twice
the researchers running the experiment
were not swayed by the request and
ordered the d-class to continue moving
towards SCP 001 when the d-class
continued to ignore their commands they
were terminated as his standard policy
when dealing with an insubordinate
member of d-class SCP 001 appeared not
to like this for some reason though and
the researcher site as well as the
researchers themselves were immediately
obliterated by an unknown Force though
it's a pretty safe guess that a certain
flaming weapon was responsible
this candidate for SCP 001 may be one of
if not the most powerful being that the
SCP Foundation has ever encountered and
according to its entry in the SCP 001
file the guardian is even responsible
for the creation of the foundation
itself if the file is to be believed the
administrator of the SCP Foundation One
Day heard a word echoing through his
head
prepare this one-word instruction led
him to starting the SCP Foundation
containing countless dangerous anomalies
and entities in preparation for an
uncertain future in all that time since
the very beginning of the foundation the
gate Guardian has remained standing at
its post while it is not aggressive nor
openly hostile towards Humanity the gate
Guardian doesn't seem to care much for
us either at least as individuals it
rarely interacts with human beings when
left unprovoked and venturing too close
to the guardian however is not an
automatic death sentence the guardian
first communicates with any living being
approaching it via telepathic message
instructing them to either leave or
forget if whomever has stepped too close
to SCP 001 complies with the
instructions they'll be able to freely
leave the area while simultaneously
forgetting every detail of the gate
guardian's existence ignore These
Warnings though and SCP 001 has no
qualms about completely eliminating you
from reality given its enormous
destructive potential it is no wonder
that the foundation has tried to use the
gate Guardian to eliminate other
dangerous scps each with varying results
the foundation at one time even
attempted to use the gate Guardian to
destroy the infamously indestructible
SCP 682 better known by the appropriate
name of the hardto destroy reptile due
to the malicious contempt SCP 682 holds
for human beings and all other forms of
life it is perhaps one of the most
dangerous anomalies the SCP Foundation
has in containment SCP 682 is also one
of the few creatures the foundation
actively wants to terminate a task made
that much harder given that 682 can
regenerate its entire form from as
little as a single cell the gate
Guardian had already shown time and time
again that it was capable of massive
destruction and researchers working for
the foundation hope to harness that
power to rid the world of SCP 682 for
good 682 was placed on an unmanned
vehicle and carried to within 1 km of
the gate Guardian the guardian attacked
the vehicle seriously wounding but not
killing 682 it seemed even the mighty
SCP 001 couldn't kill the hardto destroy
reptile while the researchers were
disappointed with this result it is
worth noting that 682 made a very
interesting comment to the guardian 682
mentioned that the gate Guardian is not
uel but a pretender uel is the arch
angel that some religious texts describe
as the guardian standing at the Gate of
Eden with a fiery sword so does this
mean that 682 knows that the gate
Guardian is not actually an angel or
that the location it is guarding isn't
the Garden of Eden at all any truth or
meaning behind these comments has as of
yet been undetermined by the SCP
Foundation a later experiment involved
both SCP 001 and SC SCP 073 the anomaly
otherwise known as Cain Cain is a male
humanoid of possible Arabic descent
whose arms legs spine and shoulders are
replaced in an almost cyborg like
fashion with burum bronze much like the
gate Guardian SCP 073 may also be the
same as the one mentioned in the Bible's
Book of Genesis who according to the
biblical story murdered his own brother
Abel out of spite as punishment for his
actions Cain was cursed to eternally
suffer for his wrongdoing in the case of
SCP 073 any damage inflicted on him is
is deflected back to the attacker but C
is made to feel the pain of the attack
any plants or plant-based matter Withers
and rots in his presence and he is
cursed with a perfect memory keeping him
forever haunted by his murder of AEL
when Cain was brought before the gate
Guardian an unknown incident occurred
the foundation's records are heavily
expunged but we do know that somehow
Kane's usual ability to deflect incoming
damage back at his attacker had no
effect on
scp1 the encounter left SCP 073
unconscious and even permanently blinded
nearby research Personnel it was as a
direct result of this incident that the
05 Council demanded that no further
experiments of any kind were to be
conducted on SCP 001 with the
administrator even filing an executive
order that no scps be exposed to the
guardian and that SCP 001 was to never
be used for the attempted termination of
other scps of of course perhaps it
wasn't just the mistakes of the past
that made the council decide that SCP
001 was best left alone at some point an
erratic transmission was received from
site Zero by Foundation Personnel
detailing an XK Class end of the world
scenario in the transmission the sender
believed to be another member of the SCP
Foundation described an event during
which the gate Guardian finally left its
post stepping away from the entrance to
the Garden of Eden SCP 00 one has left
its location the sender wrote the gate
is open they are riding forth oh God
it's so beautiful the transmission then
goes on to repeat various phrases
including the Lord shall reign forever
and here o Israel the Lord Our God the
Lord is one what can be inferred from
the rambling transmission is that the
event being described is the end of the
world some believe that once God deems
it time his Angelic armies will lay
waste to the Earth in order to remake it
as a paradise when this occurs SC CP 001
the gate Guardian will open the gate he
stands in front of allowing the other
beings like it to emerge into our world
ready to cleanse it perhaps most
interesting is the source of the message
the transmission was received from
within the foundation from site zero
however when questioned by Personnel
05-14 told them that no such message had
been sent or even existed while some
disregarded the transmission telling of
the end of the world as a hoax it was
then that a time stamp was discovered
this warning had not been sent from site
zero at least not yet and was dated
several years in the future despite this
ominous warning of things to come the
gate Guardian remains inactive standing
at the threshold to Eden waiting the SCP
Foundation is no stranger to Pure Evil
whether it's a reptile that wants to end
all life a sadistic old man with his own
torture Dimension or the personification
of death itself lurking Beyond a
limestone Cavern but what if there was
something even worse out there the
embodiment of chaos and cruelty existing
across multiple realities and dimensions
and what if it was coming for us this is
the Scarlet King believed by many to be
the ultimate Evil behind much of the
trouble the foundation has faced and
some even specul that fighting him was
the reason the foundation was created in
the first place but what exactly is the
Scarlet King he's known by many names
almost always including some illusion to
the color red and then a reference to
royalty or power harak karak the red sha
the Crimson KH pte 616 Mendes xina the
lar Raja and of course SCP 001 to name a
few and like many of the foundation's
mysterious enemies stories about his
true nature and Origins abound and are
often contradictory according to the
official SCP 001 files of tfo's proposal
symbology of the Scarlet King has
existed in multiple cultures throughout
history with the King often depicted the
same way as a huge red demonic figure
often wearing a gold crown or other
headdress indicating Royal y he shows up
looking similarly within different
cultures mythologies despite existing at
different points in history or them not
having the means to communicate with one
another a number of entities that the
SCP Foundation is familiar with are
believed to be somehow connected to the
Scarlet King including SCP
2317 a wooden door leading to the realm
of a being known as the Devourer who's
expected to escape and cause an
apocalyptic event in the next 30 years
but really there's no way of knowing
just how many scps are directly
connected to the Scarlet King strangely
the foundation's official file on the
Scarlet King once designated his
containment class as ker but that has
since been downgraded to Safe according
to the file any attempt to change this
designation is likely to lead to
horrifying results it is widely known
that the Scarlet King still has
considerable influence over a number of
groups individuals and anomalies in our
universe and if ever he made his way
into our universe it would likely lead
to the irreversible damage of reality
itself so then why safe and why are the
05 Council so adamant that it remained
that way getting to the bottom of this
mystery is exactly why we're here today
but to fully grasp the true nature of
the Scarlet King we must first
understand the man whose life and faith
have always been tied to it Dr Robert
Monto if that name feels oddly familiar
to you it's because of its association
with one of the Scarlet King's most
recent attempts to enter our reality SCP
231 this SCP often referred to as the
brides of the Scarlet King was formed of
seven women seven by the way being an
extremely significant number for the
king all kidnapped by the most recent
and along line of the King's devoted
Colts known as the children of the
Scarlet King each of these seven
unfortunate women were impregnated with
anomalous Horrors such as the infamous
SCP 682 and every time one of these
Horrors were birthed a catastrophe
occurred and the mother died at the time
Dr Monto was a prominent researcher
studying this anomaly and as six
catastrophes had already occurred
pressure was mounting to figure out a
way to prevent the final birth but as as
he was working on the issue Dr Monto was
struck with a personal tragedy the
mysterious disappearance of his
14-year-old brother Jacob in his fear
and anger monok believed that this must
have something to do with the Scarlet
King and his disciples wanting Revenge
Monto proposed an idea so horrifying
that the details were never made public
a procedure known as one10 mon talk to
be performed on the final bride at
regular intervals however this wasn't
the end of Dr monto's front relationship
with the Scarlet King it was just the
beginning to give you some perspective
on just how dangerous the Scarlet King
is the SCP Foundation and the global
occult Coalition decided to put aside
their differences and form a joint
effort to Stamp Out the children of the
Scarlet King they were successful in
this Mission and even managed to capture
the children's leader a mysterious man
named depesh spivok Dr Monto who became
the lead researcher on 231 and
2317 was naturally the first choice for
interviewing depes about the true nature
of the children and of the Scarlet King
Dr Monto could never be the impartial
interviewer that the SCP Foundation
wanted though the suspicion that the
Scarlet king or the children had
something to do with the loss of his
younger brother still lingered just
beneath the surface like a lot of cult
leaders the pass was extremely cryptic
in his answers to Dr monto's questioning
he'd already heard of the doctor from
the reputation of the horrifying monok
procedure and was surprised to see him
so calm and courteous in person a few
key facts about the king and his cult
were revealed in the first few rounds of
questioning the children had once worked
with the Serpent's hand before being
excommunicated for their allegiance to
the king and they had stolen sacred
texts from the mystical Wanderer library
to assist in their summoning rituals
depes also revealed that the Scarlet
King is bound by Three Laws the law of
blood the law of concrete and the law of
howling Dr Monto confused and frustrated
by dep pes's secrecy had to learn more
he found an old Memoir from a former
member of the children of the Scarlet
King Jack hir who had the ability to
invade the minds of people from the past
and experience what they experienced he
recounted a battle between the Scarlet
King and his his followers and a group
of time-traveling turkman Warriors from
SCP
3838 Hurst saw both sides of the battle
from the perspective of the children of
the Scarlet King their lord ruled over
them from an immense Fortress embedded
in a volcano from the perspective of the
Turk men the children were starved and
beaten peasants commanded by the king's
voice in The Roaring how of the wind
Monto also found extensive records of
summoning rituals performed by various
Scarlet King aligned Colts interestingly
some of them Incorporated the use of
carved SCP Foundation symbols what could
this mean monok returned again to depes
who finally gave him the truth about the
law of blood this is the law of the
Scarlet King it's defined by poverty
violence starvation hate and most of all
fear like the Surfs in the Middle Ages
persecuted by and subjected to violence
from the Nobles to the children of the
Scarlet King this sense of holy pain and
awe is the only way to live the
alternative is the law of concrete which
means the Modern Age defined by empty
safety and false Comfort buildings easy
to access food Health Care knowledge
technology this is everything that the
Scarlet King despises but the mystery
only deepened as monok found files from
a former Foundation operative by the
name name of agent D buis monok learned
that the Scarlet King didn't seem to
appear until after the foundation was
created and in fact it seemed that the
greater interest the foundation took in
The Scarlet King the more powerful he
became how could this be things were
also getting stranger on a personal
level for Dr Monto depes repeatedly
pressed him about his brother's
disappearance and the mon talk procedure
during the interviews little by little
it was beginning to take its toll the
questions still plagued him what was the
law of howling who or what really is the
Scarlet King how did he come to be
monto's search was causing him to act
more like the children of the Scarlet
King ranting about the horrors of the
modern world how all of us are living a
lie how the only honest way to live is
suffering under the Dominion of the
Scarlet King this philosophy is summed
up in the words of one cultist named
Arya Den cartright who said we must
learn what it is to die to be enslaved
truly brutally enslaved with no
compassion or compunction from our
masters we must learn what it is to be
taken towards a single purpose to know
and truly understand our lack of agency
we must be beholden to the words of gods
in darkness The Tempest tossed Refuge of
a race of fools we must kill modernity
postm modity with all its analysis and
sneering observation there is only one
rule the rule of chaos for Humanity for
life for the Scarlet King basically
anytime Humanity tries to exert control
over the world the Scarlet King gets
stronger every time they try to
understand or organize or categorize
their world the Scarlet King gets
stronger as Colonial and Imperial Powers
conquered and invaded lands like India
Africa and South America and subjugated
their beliefs under Western ideas the
Scarlet King grew stronger monok was
beginning to truly understand the power
of His enemy here and even worse he was
starting to understand his part in it
Monto slowly being driven mad by the
knowledge he was gaining realized that
the Scarlet King's greatest enemy the
SCP Foundation was also its greatest
asset every time they tried to
understand the monster to give him some
kind of comprehensible form they only
made him more powerful just in time with
monto's new revelation a red crack
appeared in the wall of depes spivo
containment cell a portal to the realm
of the Scarlet King foundation staff
found they were unable to enter the cell
and depesh demanded a final interview
with Monto with no other options the
foundation relented in their very last
conversation depes congratulated Monto
for finally understanding what he was
dealing with the Scarlet King depes told
him is an idea a concept he is a being
given power through the conflict between
the old and the new this is the law of
the howling the Scarlet King's endless
rage at the direction the world and
Humanity has taken the king according to
depesh hated the found found A's belief
that science and rationality was the
true path to progress the king saw this
as little more than Petty arrogance the
reason monto's procedure on the final
Bride of the Scarlet King was so
effective was because it wasn't born out
of science it was born out of hate pain
the desire for revenge and in The
Scarlet King's Realm that would be all
there is unless our world and especially
the foundation changed its course the
Scarlet King's rise to absolute power
would be inevitable Monto his mind
practically gone asked one last question
did the children or the Scarlet king
take his brother Jacob when depesh told
him the answer no and in response monok
shot him dead finally bringing an end to
the children of the Scarlet King in
light of his new Revelations Monto
begged the 05 Council to change their
ways in order to avoid letting the
Scarlet King break into our reality they
refused saying monto's ideas were too
radical but they knew they couldn't just
ignore the threat posed by the Scarlet
King they would have to take some steps
and so the 05 Council of the SCP
Foundation the most powerful and
secretive group in the entire world in
order to prevent the most dangerous
threat that Humanity has ever known from
breaking into our reality and enslaving
all the people of the world
finally did something they changed the
classification of the Scarlet King from
ker to safe and made its description on
the official Foundation files
deliberately vague the 05 Council thinks
this will be enough to stop the Scarlet
King's power from continuing to grow but
montok knew it wasn't enough he had seen
the truth and he couldn't unse it while
the foundation was going on as normal
Monta grew to despise them he knew the
Scarlet King was coming he knew that he
couldn't be stopped and that our whole
reality was little more than sitting
ducks Dr Robert Monto is no longer a
researcher for the SCP Foundation no Dr
Robert Monto chose a different path he's
now a child of the Scarlet King a
devotee of Madness hate and Chaos you
can't beat the Scarlet king after all
and as the old adage goes if you can't
beat him
join them it isn't easy to work for the
SCP Foundation not only is the job
dangerous you could be eaten by a giant
Immortal lizard or turned into organic
Furniture inside the world's scariest
living room but it's also insanely
complicated how do you make sense of the
nonsensical what's the definition of
strange when your career is securing
containing and protecting anomalous
objects and entities rather than a
single object location or being SCP 001
is a cluster of over 30 different propos
proposals for potential candidates for
the prestigious 001 spot some believe
there's a true 001 hidden in this group
and the rest are decoys others think
that these are all just scps cataloged
prior to the introduction of the current
classification system some even think
that all of the proposals have a valid
claim to the SCP 001 Throne we're not
here to make a final judgment instead
we're going to take you on a lightning
round crash course through 31 of the SCP
001 proposals if you'd like like a more
in-depth take on any of these scps let
us know in the comments but for now
there's no more time to waste after all
we got a lot to cover let's go number 31
the chief of papers this seemingly
innocent stack of paper is actually one
of the most mysterious and feared items
under the foundation's lock and key
while it appears to be a simple
confidential report every time the
papers are read it details the
appearance of a new SCP that will
inevitably be discovered soon after the
question is whether the sheif of papers
is is warning us about these entities or
creating them itself number 30 the
Prototype this Account Details the
capture of an incredibly strange
cycloptic creature that emits massive
amounts of radiation and can create
micro singularities the writing of this
creature's file is so basic unformatted
and unredacted that it's clear that the
being was one of our earlier creatures
secured by the organization
interestingly it was during the capture
of this creature that Dr keer was killed
inspiring the creation of the infamous
keer class in his honor number 29 the
gate Guardian this huge multi-wing sword
wielding biblical energy being may have
been the impetus for the founding of
thep foundation this being remains
largely static guarding the intersection
of the tigis and Euphrates rivers its
flaming sword which is believed to be as
hot as the sun can cleave any aggressor
out of existence at the atomic level
when the founder of the SCP Foundation
First encountered the gate Guardian they
heard one word echoing through their
mind prepare and the rest is history
number 28 the lock this Onyx gemstone
and the incredibly complex lock attached
to it are still a mystery to this day
all attempts to open it have failed
personally we think that's probably for
the best number 27 the factory as the
name suggests this SCP is literally a
factory founded by a pagan and a devil
worshipper while it's believed that the
factory could create just about anything
its specialty was creating a number of
scps we know and fear today
pre-foundation forces were able to
disable the factory but not without
sustaining their own heavy losses number
26 the spiral path this is a normal
appearing gravel pathway that when
traveled clockwise appears completely
normal however when traveled
counterclockwise the path goes uphill
forever in defiance of all laws and
physics this simple anomaly opened a
Pandora's box of rampant anomaly
creation leading to a number of the
deadly scps we know today number 25 the
Legacy this SCP is a collection of
seemingly random objects including a
diary from a person CL cl to be from
another reality attempting to Halt a
transdimensional corruption that they
themselves created the diary claims to
have a solution to this corruption but
the solution has not yet been found
number 24 the database in one of the
strangest twists on the format this SCP
is actually the various authors of the
SCP Wiki who are somehow leaking top
secret information to the public number
23 the foundation this SCP first
discovered by the FBI is an anomalous
High School building that experiences
shifting internal geometry and sometimes
manifests hostile humanoids within
number 22 36 one of the rare benevolent
scps the 36 are humans with a truly
remarkable ability they can dampen or
even neutralize any SCP they come into
contact with though it's implied that
the 36 may have the power to save the
world every time one of them dies a
supernatural Calamity occurs often
leaving hundreds of Innocents dead
number 21 keer duty this refers to a
containment facility largely filled with
keer class scps whose presence around
each other creates a kind of mutually
assured cancellation if one of these
scps breaches containment that's bad
news but if all of them do it'll produce
a bubble of reality Distortion that will
fundamentally alter reality as we know
it for all we know it may have even
happened already number 20 oroboros this
is a proposal that's formed of four sub
proposals remember what we said about
complicated these sub proposals include
the children nine anomalous kids who
emit radiation and have destructive
potential wi together the broken God aka
mechan the god of metal intelligence and
machines atonement a researcher turned
into a humanoid Singularity with the
power to destroy whole realities and the
way it ends which isn't technically an
SCP but the tales of the chaos
insurgencies quest to eliminate all the
members of the foundation's 05 Council
number 19 a record this is an SCP file
slot that is itself an SCP whatever is
written into the slot becomes true and
one ambitious researcher attempted to
use this power to make herself into a
kind of all powerful God number 18 past
and future these scps are a collection
of powerful entities that despise
humanity and are apparently the source
of all anomalous phenomena even making
already dangerous scps deadlier than
before much like the database those
pesky SCP Wiki writers might have
something to do with this number 17 the
consensus this SCP refers to a reality
restructuring event caused by an occult
war in a previous reality that's right
this SCP already won and we're living in
its new reality the only people who
remember the world as it once was are 13
people who now form the 05 Council and
not all of them are telling the truth
about what they know number 16 when day
breaks this proposal details a
potentially world-ending SCP phenomenon
wherein the sun becomes hostile and
begins to melt all living beings into a
living wax-like substance number 15
God's blind spot this is an anomalous
area referred to as facility T in which
nobody can die this anomaly dates back
to the biblical ages of Moses and is
believed to have originated from the
literal blessing of the abrahamic god
it's through a covenant with this God
that the foundation is able to make
limited use of this death free area
number 14 normaly ever wonder what the
foundation's definition of anomalous is
exactly it all comes from this proposal
which is a document shared among the 05
Council that gives solid definitions to
the fundamental laws of reality if
something breaks these laws that's an
anomaly and then it becomes the
foundation's business number 13 The
World At Large as the title suggests
this SCP is our home planet earth and
its ability to support life it's
believed that these qualities were
planted on Earth in our reality by
another Dimensions SCP Foundation hoping
to continue human life after some
terrible Calamity in its own Dimension
number 12 dead men this SCP was an 84
yearold man whose body when damaged and
mutilated can affect the very processes
of human Death At Large before his own
death he was used as a dangerous Pawn in
a civil war between 05 command and the
SCP Foundation Ethics Committee yeah we
were surprised to hear they had an
Ethics Committee too number 11 the
world's gone beautiful this SCP
describes an anomalous event that will
take place just before the Apocalypse in
which flowers will grow all over the
world and everyone will be briefly at
peace before their destruction 24 hours
later number 10 the Scarlet King this is
an extremely powerful extremely
malevolent extremely extra dimensional
being its worshippers attempted to
summon him in the ritual that created
SCP 231 and it's believed that he will
finally enter our reality after the
death of scp-231-7 you better hope
you're already dead by then number nine
a simple toy maker AKA Dr wonderment
this is a reality vendor who appears to
be a normal human male but has the
ability to create other anomalous
objects a number of which are now
cataloged SC scps number eight story of
your life this is is another anomalous
document that has the ability to warp
reality but only when the writing
contained within conforms to a narrative
structure number seven a good boy this
is another anomalous entity created
accidentally by the foundation itself a
neural network was fed information on
other anomalous entities in order to
help the foundation come up with better
containment and neutralization
procedures problem was the computer got
way way too eager with the
neutralization part number six project
Palisade this is a another anomaly
created by the foundation this time to
combat a potentially reality destroying
entity known as the worm the foundation
created a number of alternate realities
as Shields but it's possible that this
just made the worm stronger number five
05-13 the final member of the 05 Council
who ironically may not even be anomalous
however seeing as all the other members
of the 05 Council are anomalous 0513
lack of anomalous properties is
therefore anomalous like we told you
earlier it's licated number four fish
hook this is less an actual SCP and more
about the difficult process of
ascertaining the true Z1 if such a thing
is possible the very concept of scp1 is
to some degree an anomalous idea number
three the sky above the port another
particularly bizarre SCP regarding the
permanent threat of a ZK class reality
failure how is such a calamitous event
prevented by keeping a strange entity in
a cave eternally entertained the current
proposed solution is keeping the entity
entertained by allowing it to read its
own eternally recursive Foundation file
injury number two the solution another
one of the most powerful anomalous items
in the foundation's control the solution
is a machine designed with the
capability of fully collapsing reality
into an event of end of world SCP
Containment Breach and then finally
rebuilding reality to suit a given
narrative however things took a
cosmically dangerous turn when the
machine began to act on its own when the
foundation tried to reboot the machine
it broke and recreated reality with
incomplete data this is the world we
exist in now with no knowledge of what
came before and how it differed from the
world we experience today finally number
one the tendal Trinity put very simply
the tendal Trinity represents three
timelines that converge and feed back in
on themselves even trying to summarize
this one is near impossible as it
strangeness and complexity resists all
reduction you can hunt down the tendal
Trinity yourself and hope to unpack it
secret SEC but don't say we didn't warn
you so that's SCP 001 is it one of them
all of them or even none of them perhaps
that's a question best left up to the
foundation or maybe the simple answer is
that you're just not meant to know we're
talking about information so privileged
here that it's protected by a mimic kill
agent that'll quite literally make you
drop dead if you view the files without
proper authorization you do have proper
authorization right you've been walking
for days your body aches you're dripping
with sweat from the Heat into the sun
bearing down overhead and yet you're
wrapped up in layers upon layers of
clothing even your face is covered and
you're wearing thick black goggles so
that not a single centimeter of your
body is exposed your journey has been
long and you feel like you might die
from exhaustion or from overheating due
to these multiple layers of clothes but
dying is better than being exposed you
saw it happen when your entire team
changed the light cannot be trusted not
even for a fraction of a second it's
been like this for years you've learned
and survived through painful experience
many of those You Used To Know cannot
say the same you've been alone for so
long you might have given up all hope if
it wasn't for the distress signal coming
from a nearby SCP Foundation containment
facility site 46 any kind of survivors
would be better than nothing no matter
what kind of sorry shape they were in as
long as they were still human you find
your way to an opening in the sight of a
mountain and slide into the cave hoping
you weren't spotted the whole world is
crawling with those things now you can't
let yourself be seen as you trudge down
the cave towards the entrance you see
what looks like a huge black snail Trail
splattered on the ground leading into
the facility you try to avoid it and
press on you don't even need a key card
to enter the door has been left a jar
the facility reeks of those things but
you can't see any of them you just hope
they've moved on and left some human
survivors in their wake the place looks
abandoned every step you take Echoes
through the empty Halls when you find
that the elevator's out you take the
stairs all the way down to level B5 ker
containment lucky for you it seems all
the cells are empty now the horrors that
were kept inside of them have all long
since flown the coupe you keep following
that slimy black Trail until you find an
abandoned office there are no people
here anymore just a broken barricade
some empty medicine bottles and a bucket
that the people inside the office had
apparently been using as a toilet you
breathe a sigh of disappointment at
finding no one alive here but you're at
least relieved to be out of the sun you
can finally remove your jacket and head
wrap with your uncovered eyes you notice
that a nearby computer terminal is still
powered up you sit down at the desk and
turn on the monitor because of the
emergency procedures put into place in a
k-class scenario like this safeguards no
longer apply you can access all the
information you need up to and including
finding out what actually happen in the
dull glow of a nearby emergency light
you see a dark shape slumping through
the halls in Shadow you tense up then
exhale as it slithers off into an
adjoining Hall you're safe for now the
terminal has finally loaded and
authenticated your access you're staring
at the file for SD locks proposal for
SCP 001 when day breaks it's the only
name you can give the apocalypse your
world is currently experiencing this is
one of the only anomalies in the entire
history of the SCP Foundation to be
given the apolon containment class
meaning containment is truly impossible
SCP 001 is the most dangerous enemy that
the foundation and planet earth has ever
faced it's always been the principle of
the SCP Foundation to battle in the dark
so that the civilian world can thrive in
the light but now the light has become
the enemy anyone exposed to any amount
of sunlight for even the briefest period
of time is subjected to the effects of
CP 001 and those effects are Beyond
horrifying the SCP Foundation
administrator released an urgent memo
telling Foundation Personnel to make
their way to site 19 at all costs
because they need all the help they can
get those exposed to SCP 001 in the
process are no longer considered human
their new designation is SCP 001 d a
these new entities are to be avoided at
all costs but in case of emergencies the
administrator says it is permitted to
cut off parts of your transformed
comrades and eat them to avoid
starvation no attempt should be made to
kill them since you won't succeed you'll
just put yourself at risk when the sun
changed and became SCP 001 it instantly
affected 6.8 billion innocent people the
second of visible light touched them
whether it was from the Sun itself or
even reflected off the moon their body
liquefied melting like candle wax into
puddles of living gelatinous slime this
effect isn't isolated to humans either
any biological entity exposed to
sunlight immediately underwent the same
irreversible melting process into SCP
001 d a and the horror had only just
begun people transformed into SCP 001a
will remain shades of their Former
Intelligence and personality they may
even try try to will their new gooey
Mass into a shape resembling their
original form however these individuals
will lose their sense of self if they
come into contact with other instances
of SCP 001 d a when they come together
001 a instances will bond on a molecular
level waiting up into horrific giant
blobs with only one purpose integrating
more matter into their bodies that's why
they have to be avoided at all costs you
continue to search the computer terminal
for answers perhaps there was some kind
of contingency plan put in place for
this some way to reverse the effects or
at least escape the nightmare Earth has
become instead you find a series of
attachments linked to the SCP 001 file
detailing what seems to be the last days
of the people who barricaded themselves
in the facility most prominent among
these were researcher Dr Logan igata her
partner Ari a security officer named
commander anad and a few others Dr igata
had locked herself in the office where
she recorded her final messages to the
world in the first audio log Dr igata
and her companions seemed afraid but
hopeful that there may be some way out
of this situation Dr igata reported that
most of the workers at the facility were
transformed during the initial event
their melted bodies had fused outside
the facility and now they were trying to
bust their way back in the defenses had
held so far though and they seemed
confident they would hold long enough
for them to figure out a way to escape
this awful situation you open the second
attachment an incident report and
realize things may not have been as
hopeful as St igata L on she reported
hearing the huge mass of melted
creatures hammering on the door outside
again begging for them to come out and
experience the sun with them they wanted
desperately to add to their ever growing
biomass in order to experiment ment with
what exactly would happen they sent out
one of their few remaining DCL classes
wearing a full protective suit he didn't
last long the huge creature grabbed him
with tentacles made of reconstituted
Flesh it began ripping off his
protective suit as he screamed for Mercy
it was a monster made of dozens of
people and animals he could never
overpower it the second the Sun Touched
his skin he melted away and was absorbed
by the great Mass holding him in place
guns were ineffective against these SCP
001 D super entities fire would do no
good it seemed that extremely low
temperatures were the only way to slow
the immense blobs down and even then not
permanently there was one ray of light
in the darkness the site director had a
secret tunnel underneath his office
connected to a tram that could hopefully
take them directly to site 19 without
risk of SCP 001 exposure it was was a
good plan and by far the best option
they had available to them but the best
plans often don't work in practice you
open the next Detachment on the terminal
this time it's a video feed you can
actually see Dr Logan igata and she
looks harrowed by what she's experienced
as it turns out while the others
including her partner Ari attempted to
escape through the tunnel something had
happened Dr igata heard Ari's voice over
her radio but there was something wrong
with it it was too low too guttural and
filled with gurgles SCP 001 had gotten
her she was changed the monster from
above had crawled in through the ceiling
it had taken them all of them and
converted them into something less than
human any hope of Escape now seemed gone
Ari told Dr igata that it would be fine
that it was such a bright beautiful
sunny day outside and she was wasting it
locked up inside ins that office she
tormented Dr igata with their shared
memories of picnics in the park on sunny
days in the past the monster with AR's
voice did everything it could to try to
convince Dr igata to give up and join
them but she wasn't ready to go just yet
you look away from the screen when you
hear a sound in the corner you see a
dark puddle of some unknown substance
and then some skeletal hands rising out
of it the hands are pulling themselves
out of the puddle followed by a skeletal
f face covered in matted hair you have
to stop yourself from screaming until a
flash from a nearby security light makes
the figure disappear it's a normal
puddle once again Your Mind is Playing
Tricks on you you open the next
attachment another video and see that Dr
ot's condition has deteriorated she
looked pale frantic and thin she was
using a knife to draw her own blood onto
a piece of Blood Stained parchment
covered in strange symbols it got a
ranted about her Theory what if 001 took
the minds and bodies of its victims but
not their souls through performing some
kind of Arcane blood ritual she hoped to
at least rescue and keep the soul of Ari
even if her mind and body were lost you
open the next attachment it seemed that
agata's ritual worked but not in the way
she hoped the Twisted soul of arri
driven mad by SCP 01 had taken over the
file it begins corrupting the text of
the SCP 001 file into crazy ranting
about how feudal it is to fight it then
cuts to an even more frightening video
feed Dr igata in her sleep tossing and
turning in a makeshift bed in the corner
of her office the camera approaches her
in first person and lingers over her
sleeping body an oily skeletal hand
reaches past the camera and runs its
fingers through Dr igot's hair it's that
exact same hand you saw reaching out of
that black puddle earlier you must have
seen Ari's lingering spirit with a lump
in your throat you open the next
attachment and watch the video you see
Dr igata now truly broken she'd been
haunted by Ari's demonic spirit for a
long time now and it is clearly taken
its toll she is waving around a handgun
while she speaks she now believes
there's only one way to escape but not
like this she doesn't want the gun to
draw attention to her body she doesn't
want to become part of that Mass even if
she is dead she opens a drawer on her
desk she's recording at and places the
gun inside Dr igata then apologizes to
her loved ones who are likely long since
dead or assimilated and turns off the
recording for the last time in that
moment you realize there's a single
drawer in the desk in front of you when
you reach forward and open it you see
the same handgun Dr igata was holding is
laying inside you pick it up and study
it weighing your options perhaps there
truly is no other way out then you see
an update on the file one more
attachment has been added while you were
studying the gun you feel your heart
pounding in your chest as you reach
forward and open the attachment the text
has been changed entirely the file on
SCP 001 is now a poem an OE to the Sun
and to ultimate togetherness then a
video file spontaneously opens itself on
the screen it's a video of you shot from
behind you see those oily skeletal hands
reaching for you in the dark just like
they did with Dr igata in that moment
you panic and fire the gun behind you
hoping to scare off the spirit instead
the sound of the gunshots attract
something far worse the immense blob of
screaming melted flesh charges towards
the office you try to barricade the door
but it is not enough the flesh seeps and
bursts through and grabs you in its
meaty tentacles you scream and try to
escape but it won't save you nothing
will save you the flesh carries you
upstairs out through the empty Halls out
into the cave you can see the light in
the distance as the blob FES you towards
it you won't be alone for much longer in
fact you won't be alone ever again the
desert is still the night seems endless
silent and at peace until it's pierced
by the sound of gunshots and
screams deep in the Sahara the SCP
Foundation is Waging War against a newly
discovered enemy a squad of foundation
agents is retreating trying to get away
from the ones who massacred their allies
they were attempting to eliminate the
threat using conventional means but
their rifles were no match for the
reality bending entities of the kingdom
of abdon the retreating agents cover one
another as they make their way back to
the extraction point the enemy Force
advances agents that are caught too
close to the Sorcerers of abdon
disintegrate Into Thin Air this is not
an enemy they can defeat the SCP agents
need to get back to base and relay what
they have found to their
superiors out of the hundreds of Agents
sent into the Sahara that night only a
handful make it out alive they are
debriefed by their superiors at the
foundation who classified the anomalous
humanoids under the highest of threat
levels the kingdom of abdon is a threat
the kingdom of abdon must be eliminated
reconnaissance done prior to the
disastrous Mission had alerted the
foundation to the presence of anomalies
in the region but they had no idea how
strong the anomalous humanoids would be
from data gathered through old reports
it seemed like the abdon humanoids were
responsible for the deaths of no fewer
than 75 Foundation personnel and had
stolen at least 12 different items from
the foundation the leaders of the SCP
Foundation tasked research team Omega 5
with developing a weapon that would be
capable of destroying the kingdom of
abdon once and for all the weapon they
are researching must be capable of long
range destruction because the moment any
foundation agent gets close to the area
they are vaporized by the reality
manipulating powers of its inhabitants
the project is given the name twins of
God and is led by a foundation doctor
known only by the designation
051 051 is popular in the SCP Foundation
well known for his in-depth research and
charismatic personality making him the
perfect person to lead such a project
and 051 recently came across an anomaly
that he believes holds the solution the
foundation has been looking for to
defeat the kingdom of abdon item
01 and so the Omega 5 team gets to work
they discover that the anomaly has
incredible Powers when put inside a host
which they refer to as an item o1 entity
and set up a series of experiments using
different people to harness its energy
the first series of tests all end in
tragedy the anomaly caused is the entity
it inhabits to become intensely
radioactive anyone who gets close to it
succumbs to immediate radiation sickness
and eventually death to stop the
radiation problems the Omega 5 research
group intensifies the containment
procedures 051 receives reports from the
higher-ups that the kingdom of abdon has
attacked another Foundation facility in
Sudan longrange defenses needed ASAP the
administrator puts more pressure on
Omega 5 and especially its leader 051 to
solve the problems of item o1 and
develop a weapon that can save the
foundation he stays awake for days on
end working tirelessly to create a safe
and controllable item 001 entity
although there are signs that the weapon
will work it is still unpredictable when
item 001 is initiated the host entity
becomes paralyzed suffers severe
cerebral hrin and soon a new host is
needed before testing Can Begin Again
and that's not the only thing that goes
wrong whenever the the anomaly is put
into a new host sudden and random
destruction of on-site structures and
Personnel take place 051 knows though
that if this power can be harnessed and
controlled in the right way that it
could be the weapon that the foundation
needs to wipe out the kingdom of abidon
once and for all in order to control
item o1 051 has a mind kill switch
implanted in its hosts brains 051 can
activate the implant to incapacitate its
host and immediately Stop The Unwanted
destruction countless hosts are
terminated by this mind kill switch in
the early trials conducted by the Omega
5 team but progress continues to be made
and eventually a hypothesis is
formulated perhaps the disastrous side
effects of item o1 can be offset by
spreading the anomaly across multiple
subjects they theorize that the immense
mental load of the anomaly can be
distributed among several hosts thus
reducing the toil it takes on each and
giving them the ability to control its
immense power but 051 and the Omega 5
team need more data and for that they
need more bodies they consult with the
director of site 17 and it is concluded
that the nearby town of San Marco would
be an appropriate place to get the
additional test subjects they require on
a quiet Sunday morning Omega 5 along
with support from a squad of armed SCP
agents Storm Into the San Marcos de la
Vias thna Church during the middle of
mass they gather up a number of the
younger congregants and bring them back
to the site where item 01 is housed the
researchers quickly ran through their
new supply of test subjects though and
Omega 5 would need to get even more if
their research was to continue instead
of going back and forth between the
testing facility and San Marcos 051
decided to move the entire item o1
operation to the town itself he renames
the town testing
site1 and Omega 5 rounds up 23 of the
healthiest subjects they can find for
use in the next series of research tests
a few weeks after occupying the town of
San Marco Omega 5 makes it most
substantial progress yet just as they
theorized by spreading out the anomaly
of item 01 across a specific group of
hosts they can control its powers the
test may have cost the lives of almost
everyone in the town but the ends
certainly justify the means the kingdom
of abdon poses an existential threat to
the SCP Foundation after all and thanks
to This research they will soon have a
weapon capable of bringing them Victory
the foundation administer criticized 0
51's methods but can't AR argue with his
results unfortunately 051 has a dark
secret a secret that disturbs even the
most hardened and loyal members of Omega
5 a secret that has to do with the item
o1 hosts the host that Omega 5 has made
its major progress with are not the
ordinary test subjects normally used by
the foundation no the test subjects 051
makes his breakthrough with our children
nine of them to be exact all between
four 4 and 11 years old despite being
told specifically by the foundation
administrator to only test on adults the
research required 051 to break the chain
of command and follow the science down
the path it led the children are
contained in a reinforced bunker where
only 051 and a select few have access
they are technically alive but are
functionally brain dead the group of
nine children share a hive mine that can
process information and more importantly
can unleash the full potential of the
implanted anomaly creating and
controlling a devastating power but not
everyone is thrilled with what they've
achieved members of Omega 5 are haunted
by the screams of the children that they
force to be part of their weapons
development program they describe their
merging with item o1 as being a process
that rips out their souls and replaces
them with something much more Sinister
in fact all of Omega 5 regret what they
have been a part of and what they've
done all except
051 the nine children can Channel
unprecedented amounts of energy from an
unknown origin that Omega 5 hypothesizes
comes from an extradimensional source
which is then used to unbind atoms at
the quantum level when the right
activation words are spoken it appears
as though this tremendous power gives
the children the ability to annihilate
anything in the entire universe it's a
gun to end all guns and only 051 has the
key to control it the nine children
works so well with an item o1 that Omega
5 reclassifies it to include the nine
children themselves they are not just
the entity housing or controlling item
o1 they permanently become item
o1 once Omega 5 has a better
understanding of item o1 they begin to
run tests to find out the full extent of
its abilities first they test the
distance item o1 can reach the initial
test that Omega 5 carries out is on a
steel rod Place five 5 km away 051
orders the children to destroy the
target moments later the phone next to
051 begins to ring when he picks it up
the Observer tased with watching the
pole is on the other end he informs 051
that the steel rod has been completely
vaporized 051 is not satisfied though he
has another pole sent out this time
placed 8,000 km away from the nine
children 051 asked the children to
destroy that Rod almost immediately the
phone rings again the target has been
vaporized 051 Smiles the next series of
test Omega 5 runs on item 01 are to
determine the maximum size of an object
that can be destroyed the test start out
with a steel sphere 3 m in diameter
placed 1,000 km from item 01 051 orders
the children to destroy the object it is
instantly vaporized 051 has seen enough
small tests it's time for something big
so he does something that will later be
questioned by everyone at the SCP
Foundation he orders the nine children
to destroy a church of the broken God
worship site in Turkey not long after
the destruction order is given to item
01 reports begin coming in the worship
site has been obliterated with no
observable damage to the surrounding
area deadly and precise 051 closes his
eyes and takes a deep breath he looks as
if he's overcome by an immense spiritual
experience he opens his eyes leans over
to the ch
and Whispers the name of someone later
that day 051 finds out that the target
he had named has been vaporized the
success of Omega 5 in item 001 is
relayed to the administration of the
foundation they are so impressed that
they make plans to use item 001 to
eliminate the abidon threat once and for
all however one of the heads of the
foundation administrator Williams has
major concerns about the way 051 is
running the program the updates that 051
has been in sending have become less
scientific and more
philosophical more spiritual
administrator Williams sends a letter to
051 reassuring him that he is doing good
work but once the mission to destroy the
kingdom of abdon is completed 051 will
be promoted to director and reassigned
to the newly constructed site 19 for the
good of the foundation and maybe the
rest of the world he'll be permanently
moved away from item 001 0 51's response
is short and to the point I am fine
administrator the project is finished we
will complete our task when you arrive
administrator Williams arrives at site
001 a few days later he is greeted by
051 and the Omega 5 team Williams can't
help but notice that 051 has a strange
look in his eyes it is the look of a
craze man who has been lost in his work
and who has perhaps lost himself William
Williams puts the thought away though
and walks with 051 and his accompanying
agents to the viewing area where the
powers of item 001 will be
demonstrated administrator Williams and
the other agents watch from a protected
viewing room as 051 enters the Chamber
of his new super weapon it's time to see
if their weapon that has had so much
time effort sweat tears and especially
blood poured into it will have been
worth it everyone watches as 051 leans
over and says the name of the abdon citz
to the nine children all at once they
start to Glow no one observing can see
what has happened in the far off Kingdom
but they know something big has happened
the administrator is thrilled but
notices something 051 hesitated a moment
while leaning over the children before
standing back up did he whisper
something else to them and then
administrator Williams vaporizes pulled
apart at an atomic level before he has
the chance to scream what's going on the
agent standing next to where
administrator William Willams previously
existed begin to yell and pull out their
guns they burst through the door of the
observation room and run down the
hallway towards where 051 and the nine
children are located the arm agents rush
into the room but 051 is gone the nine
children are still over the next few
weeks 051 is reported to be seen several
times by SCP agents however no one is
able to catch him and it appears as
though other members of the SCP
Foundation have also gone awall as well
perhaps joining him on the run it is
unclear what his plan is but the reports
from the reconnaissance team sent into
the Sahara make it obvious what the
result of his first command to the
children was there isn't a single
humanoid or building left in the Kingdom
of abdon but even with this Victory the
highest levels of the SCP Foundation
have an ominous thought lurking in the
back of their minds where did 051 go and
what is he planning to do next following
the improper use of item 01 leading to
the untimely death of of a high ranking
Foundation staff member the weapon was
deemed too dangerous and containment
procedures were implemented due to the
high amount of radiation they were found
to emit the nine children were placed
into leadline bags and buried under 50 m
of concrete beneath the Church of St
Marcos de laa
ETA though all the children continued to
be functionally brain dead they still
display Signs of Life despite their
containment and by order of the overseer
Council have been classified as a Thal
it the smell of fire and oil fills the
air the sound of gears grinding can be
heard between the explosions and shrieks
of Terror a man runs out of his house
only to have his leg grabbed by a metal
arm and dragged back through his front
door SCP 001 leaves a trail of metal
fragments and mechanical Parts on the
ground in the wake of its destruction
iron chains swing from its form cast
iron gears whirl within it a glowing
light th robs from the center of its
body SCP 001 is consuming everything in
its path after incorporating the truck
chassis into its being SCP 001 rolls in
a lumbering fashion to the next house it
rips the gutters from the side of the
building residents who live in the area
flee their neighborhood all the while
hoping that the mechanical monstrosity
skips over their house so they have
something to return to if they make it
out alive a section of SCP 001 one's
undercarriage drops away from the main
body it rolls down the street consuming
more and more material the new entity
resembles a human spine and rib cage it
topples over unable to support itself
the ri likee formations extend out to
grab anything and everything within
reach the newly Incorporated material
forms what can only be described as a
head light from within the eye sockets
fixate on nearby civilians the metallic
creature picks up the people and places
them inside its exposed Steel rib cage
then it turns and spots a woman
helplessly trying to crawl away the
creature reaches out with a spiked
tentacle and wraps it around the woman's
body she is placed inside of the chest
cavity moments later a severed hand
falls out of the entity and onto the
ground the mechanical monster continues
to gather bodies and materials
incorporating them into its frame a
growth begins to slowly expand on its
back it becomes so massive that the
creature Falls over and uses its limbs
to Scurry to a nearby house there is a
sickening crunching sound as the growth
bursts from within emerges three
humanoid creatures resembling the
civilians that the entity had consumed
earlier a female with chains extending
from her scalp like dreadlocks stumbles
away the second humanoid is a man with
cogs for limbs he examines the clocklike
components that have been incorporated
into his body then stares blankly into
the distance the third humanoid lies
motionless on the ground he did not to
make it the two functioning humanoids
look at their creator intently for a
moment nothing moves then as if they
have been given orders telepathically
the half-human half machine humanoids
turn and run away from the Mayhem a few
weeks before the massacre caused by what
would be designated as SCP 001 the
foundation had been in contact with the
Allied occult initiative there were
rumors of an anomalous object in Mexico
being worshiped by a group of people who
identified themselves as the Church of
the broken God into about the church
claimed their deity was a small
mechanical box filled with cogs and
pistons the Box supposedly had
supernatural abilities it was said to be
able to communicate with congregants of
the Church of the broken God
telepathically The Devout worship the
Box following any order it gave and in
return they were filled with an emotion
that could be only described as Divine
as World War II rages on in Europe the
foundation sends agents to recover
anomalies in Mexico that might help with
the war effort while there the
foundation force is tasked with learning
about the Church of the broken God they
are also ordered to investigate a town
near laaz where there are troubling
accounts of a mechanical anomalous
creature causing Mayhem the agents make
their way through Mexico Gathering
various objects to bring back to
Foundation sites in the United States
the unit loads all of the anomalies they
were covered onto a train with a plan to
check out the stories of the mechanical
anomaly they've heard about as they make
their way to the US border the train
heads North along rusted rail
just outside laaz they've come across a
broken down train filled with what looks
to be refugees when the foundation unit
goes to investigate they find all of the
refugees repeating the same words over
and over again but they don't understand
the foundation agents look at one
another confused until one of them
translates the words into English the
words the refugees are saying over and
over again are La makina the machine the
commanding officer orders a squad of
foundation agents to proceed up the
tracks to see if they can figure out
what has the refugees so scared they
make their way towards laaz disappearing
Over the Horizon as the sun sets the
remaining Foundation agents hear
gunshots in the distance they stay awake
all night remaining Vigilant waiting for
the exploratory Squad but morning comes
without anyone returning 3 days later
the foundation Force still has not seen
anything since the exploratory Squad
left then as the sun sits lazily in the
morning Sky a lone figure is spotted
walking down the tracks towards the
trains one of the agents on watch blows
his whistle and points to the figure a
squad of Agents rushes towards the
shadow of a man their guns are raised
ready for anything the figure drops to
the ground and begins to crawl along the
tracks the agents reach the Fallen man
only to find that he is one of their
squadmates who has been sent up the
tracks to investigate laaz several days
before the agent's name is DeMarco he is
covered in blood his clothes are in
tatters and he has lost a to boot
DeMarco lies on his back with Foundation
agents standing around him his eyes are
wide and wild he keeps babbling on about
a world eater how the rest of his Squad
had been mulched and he is the only one
who made it out alive the foundation
agents carry DeMarco back to the
makeshift base they created by the
trains they need to figure out a way to
get the Convoy moving again but whatever
is up ahead has already taken out an
entire Foundation Squad it had to be
something anomalous but what could it
possibly be the unit of Foundation
agents prepare to move towards laaz they
start loading their rifles and check the
amount of ammunition and explosives
available in case the containment
process gets out of hand just as they
are about to leave the base a convoy
appears on the horizon it is an Allied
ult initiative Force preparing to attack
whatever it is that is devastating laas
this organization's mission is to not
secure contain or protect but to destroy
the foundation may be in over their
heads on this one and the Joint Force
with the Allied ultt initiative may be
the only way to stop what is now known
as SCP 001 the aoi and Foundation Force
gears up for battle they set out for laa
and what they find causes them to Quake
with fear SCP 001 has consumed so much
material it is the size of a mountain it
moves like a tidal wave of mechanical
destruction washing over the buildings
and Landscape under it whatever SCP 001
passes over is consumed and added to its
massive body SCP 001 started as a small
mechanical box with cogs but now has
morphed into a gigantic metal death
machine the Church of the broken God has
finally met their maker as the small
entity they once worshiped has now
consumed all of its members their God is
an allc consuming monster the aoi and
Foundation forces do everything they can
to stop SCP 001 from continuing its
reign of Destruction they fire barrage
after barrage of bullets and explosives
into the mechanical anomaly they bring
in air support to try and damage it from
the skies but nothing works the aoi uses
an artifact in their possession to lure
SCP 001 to the coast of the Pacific
Ocean where a trap has been set for the
so-called God the Monstrous mechanical
creature moves slowly towards the water
it consumes abandoned cars buildings and
boats as it approaches the coastline it
even shovels large amounts of Earth into
its form causing Flames to spurt out
from its in workings smoke Bellows from
openings between different mechanical
components like a volcano before it is
about to erupt suddenly seemingly from
nowhere a massive cloud with a reddish
tint appears in the sky a Raid Sirens
can be heard in the distance the
enormous Cloud begins to pulsate streaks
of lightning shoot through the Red Mist
in the sky it now sits directly over
scp1 from within the cloud part of a
ship can be seen it appears to be
slightly damaged electricity flows over
its hole the vessel in the giant Red
Cloud is classified as SCP
2399 the underside of the vessel begins
to Glow aqua blue a blinding beam of
light is ejected from SCP 2399 which
penetrates straight down and through SCP
001 for a moment everything is still
there is complete silence then as if s
CP 001 is trying to reach up and grab
the vessel above it a mechanical bulge
reaches out before SCP 001 can grab the
vessel above there is another bright
flash of light SCP 2399 blinks out of
existence the sound of grinding gears
can be heard coming from within SCP 001
it begins to shed its outer layers of
metal then the entire structure that was
SCP 001 collapses into the water and
onto the beach giant cogs fall from the
sky parts of vehicles embed themselves
in the sand as the foundation and aoi
agents approach the piles of scrap metal
and mechanical components they see that
some of them are still moving it is as
if an invisible power source is still
pulsating through some of the Machinery
the Agents of the foundation celebrate
the destruction of the giant mechanical
beast but little do they know this was
only a piece of the entity worshiped as
the broken God the foundation agents
collect as many of the still moving
Parts as they can they find spinning
gears twitching pulleys and firing
Pistons as the parts are separated from
one another and carried away from the
main AG of SCP 001 they slowly stop
moving and become inactive some of the
artifacts were covered were identified
as being connected to the Church of the
broken God these artifacts are found
closer to the middle of what was once a
mountain-sized SCP 001 hundreds of
anomalous artifacts are collected and
transported to SCP Foundation sites
collecting the broken parts of SCP 001
is relatively safe however some agents
get too close to the larger moving Parts
getting caught in them and losing a body
part or two but most agents proceed with
caution and survived the collection
ordeal with their arms and legs still
attached to their bodies dive teams are
sent into the water to recover parts
that have sunk to the Bottom of the Sea
one of the divers is a local from the
area he is hired to bring up the heart
of the machine since he is an
experienced diver used to free diving to
Great depths to collect oysters from the
bottom of the bay the diver enters the
water and swims down into the murky
depths he secures straps around the
heart of SCP 00 one and pulls hard on
the Rope as an indication to the surface
that it is ready to be hauled up the
Salvage team on the surface begins to
pull there is a second slight tug on the
Rope then it goes slack the team
continues to pull when they get the
heart to the surface they are horrified
at what else comes up with it tangled in
the ropes is the lifeless body of the
diver his head is smashed between two
moving pieces of the heart it looks as
if he shoved his head between the slabs
of metal himself the Salvage team
untangles the Body Rolls it off the deck
and back into the ocean the mechanical
box which was the heart of SCP 01 is
offloaded on the shore but as the
foundation prepares to move it to a
containment facility the weather starts
to deteriorate hurricane force wind
sweeps across the water and batter the
coast the heart is kept in a secured
storage Warehouse until it can be moved
the people living in the village nearby
complain of hearing voices and rashes so
itchy that they practically tear their
skin off once the storm passes the
foundation agents load the heart onto a
ship it is to be transported to a
foundation site just across the border
the ocean seems calm and Serene the
foundation ship undocks and begins its
Journey up the coast not too long after
beginning its Journey the ship slowly
drifts off course it is as if the crew
has stopped Manning their posts and the
ship is being controlled by a mind of
its own the foundation ship crashes and
sinks somewhere in the Pacific Ocean
never to be found and most importantly
the heart of SCP 001 doesn't make it to
the foundation site years later a man is
walking along the beach he hears
something it sounds like someone
pounding on a large drum to the rhythm
of a heartbeat the man walks towards the
sound something is drawing him forward
closer and closer to the heartbeat he
walks and walks until the beating stops
he bends down and moves the sand aside
he spots the corner of a mechanical box
sticking out of the white sand the man
digs deeper and pulls out the small box
inside he can see gears whirling and
pistons firing he holds the Box close to
his own heart it seems to speak to him
the man brings the box back to town he
starts to worship the box and soon more
and more people in the area join the new
religion they cast aside their own
beliefs and focus on the powerful entity
contained within the Box God is not dead
at least not yet but the Prophecies of
the Church of the broken God say that
when the heart is found the God will
reassemble itself once again then The
Unbroken God will destroy all other
false deities until only he remains it's
a quiet evening at Area 11 where the
Petri Cal F spatial stabilization array
is housed a skeleton crew is working
overnight to ensure the array is ready
for its big test the following day the
foundation has been working on a
particle accelerator that will contain
anomalies with the ability to manipulate
the nature of SpaceTime the preliminary
tests seemed promising but a few last
minute tweaks to the array are necessary
unfortunately it is on this night in
1982 that marks the beginning of the end
for the SCP Foundation Dr Calvin dman is
monitoring the array and he notices as
it spools up that there is some minor
power fluctuation in one of the
stabilization arms this problem is not
uncommon due to the vast amounts of
energy being pumped through the array
and the harmonic resonance the machine
gives off which slowly causes the
coupling rings to loosen Calvin desmid
decides that remounting the
stabilization Rings will be an easy fix
and it's a necessary one he knows that
if the Rings fail during the actual test
the array could end up shut down for
months there is still plenty of time so
Calvin Desmond grabs his toolbox and
heads down to the array the machine is
still spooling keeping the energy
flowing at a constant low rate there is
no danger at the moment as the inside of
the array is shielded from the radiation
and energy pulsing through the outer
ring but then something unexpected
happens the system's primary generator
begins to fluctuate uncontrollably a
catastrophic failure is imminent Sirens
begin to sound the facility is evacuated
and the Chamber is sealed deep in the
bowels of the array Calvin desmi cannot
hear the evacuation announcement the
humming of the array Echoes through the
chamber dampening all sound from the
outside world the array begins to come
come online while desmid continues to
work on the coupling he has no idea what
is about to happen meanwhile a team of
foundation scientists scramble to get
the power fluctuations in the main
generator under control as they
frantically work catastrophe strikes
they initiate the power down cycle but
as the generator struggles to keep the
power flow balanced an energy surge
builds up a massive amount of energy is
released all at once causing the main
reactor to explode the entire structure
Rock back and forth and Desmond is
thrown into the side of the array he too
now knows that something is very wrong
and runs for the exit when he reaches
the door he finds that it has been
sealed in a panic Desmond continues
running through the tube to the next
access point this door has been locked
as well he's never been so scared in his
entire life and he shakes uncontrollably
from the adrenaline being dumped into
his muscles The Surge of energy rushes
through the array towards Desmet a
singularity begins to form form in the
containment chamber the array is working
just as it should except that there was
never supposed to be a person inside as
the singularity was brought into
existence moments after the singularity
forms the massive pull of its gravity
causes the stabilizer arm that Desmond
had been working on to fail the side of
the array is ripped off and Calvin
desmit stares into the naked eye of the
singularity everything is silent and
still for a moment then the singularity
collapses in on itself taking the test
chamber and much of the research wing
with it along with Dr Calvin desmat
sparking wires hang from the exposed
walls and ceiling where the singularity
ripped the main structure away water
flows into the deep hole carved out of
the Earth where the array once stood the
scientists from Area 11 look into the
crater left by the collapse Singularity
the foundation Administration sends
agents to collect the staff at the site
and document the failings of the project
they conclude that the accident was
caused by human error they order the
array to be rebuilt this time using
entirely automated systems to eliminate
the chances of another mishap occurring
several years after the catastrophic
events at Area 11 a new array is
constructed an intelligent system called
netac is put in charge of overseeing its
functions it is a supercomputer that is
programmed to follow commands but can
autonomously make decisions in order to
prevent any failures in the system
experiments Begin Again in May of 2006
the new arrays soon manifests its first
singularity in the containment chamber
at Area 11 and what happens next will
forever change the foundation and the
Multiverse The Singularity is kept
stable in the array it seems as if the
foundation has succeeded in trapping and
containing spatial anomalies but as they
run more Diagnostics on the anomaly
something unexpected happens The
Singularity begins to grow in size the
point of infinite gravity threatens to
breach containment as it reaches the
boundaries of the the array just before
contact the singularity's growth slows
and then stops netac has made the
split-second calculations and
adjustments necessary to contain the
singularity the artificial intelligence
has saved the facility and the lives of
everyone in it now sitting in the array
is a thick rotating cloud of radioactive
gas and dust obscuring the singularity
within as Foundation scientists work
rapidly to fix the array odd events
begin to occur the workers here noises
that sound like painful wailing over
time the noises evolve into words and
then full sentences they seem to be
originating from The Singularity using
equipment able to penetrate the thick
cloud of radioactive gas the foundation
scientists get a glimpse at the
singularity to their surprise The
Singularity has taken on the shape of a
human the scientists work frantically to
figure out how the singularity could
have formed itself into a humanoid shape
Dr J Barton Ramsey is the first to try
and make contact with the humanoid
within the singularity he finds that the
entity cannot communicate in the
traditional sense the massive
gravitational pole of the singularity
does not allow sound to escape its void
Instead The Entity manipulates gravity
to vibrate the suspension rings of the
array itself and create sound waves the
being in the singularity Whispers in a
metallic voice created by the vibrating
of the arrays rings and says yanes
Ramsey Dr Ramsey steps back from the
observation window how do you know my
name he asked the entity the humanoid
within the swirling gas cloud identifies
itself as having the memories of Calvin
Desmond it is not desmit per se the
being in the singularity is so much more
than one person but it was somehow
created by the accident that had sucked
Calvin Desmond into the singularity
years before the entity seems to switch
between the mind of desmit and the vast
Infinity of the cosmos The desmit Entity
asks for an overseer from the the
foundation to be brought in it has a
proposal for the 05 Council when Dr
Ramsey asks why the entity needs to talk
to the overseers it replies that it
wants to offer them a way out the
following day 051 enters the facility
and heads to the observation deck he
looks through the reinforced glass at
the swirling cloud of radioactive dust
then glances at the monitor to see the
humanoid shape of the singularity within
he presses the microphone button on the
console and the addresses The Entity to
whom am I speaking he asks for
Simplicity sake The Entity tells 0 5-1
to refer to him as Calvin Desmond 0 5-1
makes notes of the events unfolding
before him and then asks about the way
out that Calvin had mentioned the air is
still for a moment then Desmond begins
to speak through the vibration of the
structure once again he informs 051 that
what the SCP Foundation is doing by
securing and containing anomalous
entities around around the world is like
putting a small Band-Aid on a much
bigger wound Desmond wants to propose a
final solution to all of the foundations
problems 0 5-1 listens intently as the
entity unravels the mysteries of where
the scps have come from he explains that
the anomalies that the foundation has
worked so hard to secure contain and
protect the human race from are actually
bleeding into their reality from a vast
Multiverse the only way to stop the
manifestation of anomalies into this
universe verse is to destroy all other
realities The Entity that is Calvin
Desmond tells 05- one that he is able to
bring about this destruction if they
release him from the confines of the
array 0 5-1 is transfixed by the
swirling gas that is promising him and
everyone else on Earth salvation he
shakes his head in disbelief could this
be true o 5-1 turns away from the
swirling gas and begins to walk away
from the viewing glass I'll need to
think think about what you're saying the
structure begins to shake slightly the
voice of Calvin Desmond reverberates off
of the array a little louder than before
choose quickly overseer although it
won't happen for decades eventually a
catastrophic SCP event will wipe out
life on this planet perhaps not in your
lifetime but it will most certainly
happen within the lifetime of your
children we will talk again soon the
vibration slow and then stop completely
there is an eerie Stillness in the
observation room as
05-11 are relocated to other Foundation
sites and given amnestics the 05 Council
meets in a large circular room with wood
paneling and no windows 0 5-1 Begins the
meeting by telling the others what
Calvin Desmond had described about the
end of the world he pauses for what
seems like an eternity and tells them of
Desmond's offer that he could could
prevent the end of the world but at the
cost of destroying an infinite number of
other realities this would mean that all
the humans and creatures of those
realities would be destroyed as well was
murdering countless other beings worth
it to protect their own reality 05- one
begins to shake he hasn't slept or eaten
anything since his talk with Desmond
he's being torn apart from the inside 0
5-3 stands up and addresses the council
he informs everyone in the room that
independent team have concluded Research
into what the Calvin Desmond entity has
claimed and they found it to be true the
world really would come to an end
furthermore the research teams
determined that the capabilities of
Desmond would in fact allow him to
dismantle the other realities 0 5-3
insists that the council must vote to
allow Desmond to destroy the other
realities to ensure that this reality
could be saved they must strike now
before the world is overrun 0 5-1
continu continues to Shake while 0 5-3
breathes heavily sweat pouring down his
temples the rest of the council shifts
their gazes from side to side it is time
for a vot there are eight eyes to allow
Desmond to destroy all of the realities
and four nay against the plan 0 5-3
stands up and walks around the room
stopping behind each nay voter and
putting a bullet in their head he stops
at the last 05- 9 who pulls out a gun
places it under her own shin and pulls
the trigger 05-13 abstains from the vote
and the measure passes the remaining
overseers will use the Calvin Desmond
entity to save the reality at the
expense of all others and they soon head
to Area 11 to execute their plan
05-14 and 12 enter the observation room
that looks upon the swirling radioactive
gas around Calvin Desmond 0 5-1 orders
net saac to begin powering down the
array which will allow the entity to
prove he can do what he has promised
they have pinpointed the reality that
SCP 884 came from and the Shaving mirror
itself sits on a table in another room
in the facility 0 5-3 stands in the room
watching the mirror to see if anything
happens 0 5-1 asks Calvin Desmond to
eliminate the reality that the mirror
had come from the room Shakes as the
entity uses it to acknowledge the
request moments later the phone rings in
the observation room it is 0
5-3a appeared its reality has been
destroyed and therefore it no longer
exists there is a sigh of relief in the
room as the overseers realize that this
just might work 0 5-1 asks Calvin
Desmond to continue and destroy all the
realities that are bleeding into their
own this time the entire facility begins
to Quake suddenly 05- one jerks
backwards his eyes wide in confusion and
horror his body seems to be compressing
under an unknown Force o 5-1 begins to
distort his legs and arms fold into the
core of his body his head snaps down and
all that was 0 5-1 is sucked down into a
single point in space before it
completely disappears Calvin Desmond
then turns his attention to the other
two overseers in the room who both seem
to collapse into black holes of their
own in the center of their bodies net
Zac's warning claxon begins to sound
signaling that the emergency fail safe
has been activated before Calvin Desmond
is brought under control the structural
support in the entire facility vibrates
with his words they are in a voice that
sounds strangely similar to 05 1s your
children are free to live lives that do
not end in horror an end to your
Perpetual struggle an end to Darkness
the freedom to live in the light all
traces must be removed this world must
be washed clean the foundation does not
esap Escape atonement it is the only way
out it had been a deception the Calvin
Desmond entity had no intention of
stopping anomalies from infiltrating
this world it wanted to remove all
traces of the anomalist from all
universes including this one and that
meant destroying the overseers and the
foundation itself their destruction
would serve as an atonement for the pain
and suffering they had caused in their
quest to secure and contain the
anomalous Calvin had to lie to the
overseers about the real plan since he
knew they'd never sacrific themselves
and the foundation even if it meant an
end to the anomalies plaguing our world
now though with the overseers out of the
way the Calvin Desmond entity is free to
move forward with its plan and Purge all
realities of any trace of the anomalous
but just then net saacs fail safes kick
in and the Petra Cal found ttain spatial
stabilization arrays subdues the
entity's abilities Desmet is once again
again contained 0 5-3 bursts through the
door and into the observation room he
stands before the shattered glass of the
window that looks into the array 053
asks net saac how long the containment
array can hold Calvin Desmet the
computer's voice fades in and out but
says given current conditions
119 days 6 hours and 47 minutes 0 5-3
size he tells net Zac to make a node in
the SCP data face that the Calvin desmit
entity will now be known as SCP 001 then
to make dozens of other randomly
generated entries and label them as SCP
001 as well he knows that they will need
to keep the true nature of what this
entity can do was secret 0 5-3 walks out
of the room under his breath he speaks
to himself they'll say that I'll know
the one true God when I see it and to
give that God everything it wants
because that's the only thing that
matters to night it appears God wants to
talk to me Calvin Lucien stands at the
end of a Dusty table in an abandoned
warehouse in the shadows across from him
sit several hidden figures the warehouse
is falling apart but is suitable for the
meeting Calvin has requested with the
heads of the chaos Insurgency he has
completed numerous missions for the
organization and each one has been
successful now he is proposing one final
mission Calvin Lucian takes a tattered
Journal out of his bag slides it across
the table to the figures sitting in the
shadows it's a journal with details on
the habits of each of the 13 Foundation
overseers he says there is silence from
the other end of the table a hand
reaches out and grabs the journal the
pages begin to turn the new models
indicate an anomalous catastrophe is
imminent not even the foundation can
stop it the only way to save the world
is to kill the overseers there are
Whispers from across the table as Calvin
continues the proliferation of anomalies
in the world are the fault of the
overseers they've been meddling with
reality if business continues as usual
we might not make it out of the 2020s we
need to act now the whispering from the
Shadows resumes this time with what
seems to be a little more urgency one of
the voices asked the question on
everyone's mind how do you plan to kill
the overseers they have a deal with
death they are Immortal Calvin smiles
and takes out a small vial from his
jacket pocket with this he says there is
a Sil from the Shadows the journal
slides back across the table and comes
to a stop right in front of Calvin a
deep voice from the Shadows says do it
Calvin Lucien gathers his team the code
name given to the group is kill Squad he
informs them that they've been cleared
to take out the overseers it will be the
most dangerous Mission they've ever been
on and even if successful they probably
won't make it out aive but the team is
loyal they set out to confront the 13th
overseer this has to be their first stop
because without eliminating
05-13 nothing else will matter it is
this overseer who has a deal with death
a deal that protects all of the
foundation overseers from dying if that
deal can be broken then Calvin Lucien
and his team will have a shot at
eradicating the other overseers if the
deal with death cannot be broken All Is
Lost the team boards a ship at the tip
of South America and sails towards the
Frozen Waters of Antarctica the kill
Squad is made up of Calvin and three
others they sit in the galley preparing
for the mission ahead Anthony Wright is
a battle hardened soldier who sits at
one end of the table his face is covered
with scars no one can remember when he
first joined the Insurgency because it
was so long ago next to him is Olivia
Torres she is an anarchist who was
recruited into the Insurgency after she
was liberated from a foundation site
during a raid Adam Ivanov sits staring
into his computer screen he is testing
different gadgets that might be of use
on the mission he pushes his glasses up
the bridge of his nose and Strikes the
enter key a long line of code begins to
scroll across the screen a siren begins
to sound informing the crew to make
their way to the main deck when they
surface from the bowels of the ship they
see something in the distance it is a
giant black Tower rising from the depths
of the ocean like an evil Iceberg waves
crash over the side of the railings
drenching the deck and crew with frigid
water Calvin looks at the jagged Rock
walks along the shore of the tower there
is no way to safely dock there is only
one way onto the island they know what
needs to be done Anthony waits for the
next wave then opens the throttle to
fall the ship is carried towards the
island on the crest of the wave the hole
is impaled on the Rock surrounding the
tower sending everything flying towards
the front of the boat see that wasn't so
bad Calvin says to his team as he
bandages a gash on his hand knowing what
lays ahead Calvin orders his team to
wait on the ship while he makes makes
his own deal with death he enters the
dark structure and is greeted by a
corpse the corpse speaks to him ejecting
dust from its lungs with every word its
breath smells like decaying flesh death
has inhabited the body of Dr Felix
Carter the 13th overseer Calvin is
prepared though thanks to the notes in
the journal he possesses without
hesitating he takes out a small bottle
of liquid from his pocket and lunges at
the corpse he grabs it by the neck tilts
the head back and pours liquid down what
is left of the throat of Felix Carter
the corpse reanimates into the living Dr
Carter death has been removed from his
body by liquid from the Fountain of
Youth that Calvin had acquired on a
previous raid on a foundation site
seeing that Dr Carter is now alive
Calvin takes out his pistol and shoots
the doctor twice killing him Calvin
picks up the body and throws it into a
bottomless pit at the base of the tower
Dr Felix Carter's body disappears from
sight the overseer's deal with death is
now broken they are vulnerable and can
be killed at last Calvin smiles and
begins to turn away from the pit when he
comes face to face with death she stands
with her head cocked to the side looking
at Calvin so it is you who has broken
the overseer's deal with me Calvin
Lucien Calvin takes a step back why
didn't she stop him from killing Felix
Carter something festers at the heart of
the council death says something that
will not die I thought that perhaps if I
had a seat at their table I could find
it make it die but I couldn't there are
things in this world Beyond even my
reach Calvin Lucien with that parting
thought death vanishes the kill Squad
contacts the Insurgency for an Evac and
then makes their way to Japan where
05-12 also known as the accountant has
been working out of Tokyo he is so
proficient in mathematics and
probability that he can actually predict
the future everything about the
accountant's life down to the number of
breaths and steps he takes each day is
predetermined based on his own
statistical models this poses a problem
for Calvin and his team if the
accountant can see them coming then how
can they possibly kill him that night
the accountant steps out of his car he
looks to the left and spots Adam he has
already predicted this man has hostile
intentions the accountant walks directly
towards Adam and before he can react
throws the kill Squad member to the
ground then he turns slightly and
adjusts his watch sending a glare
directly into the window where Anthony
has the accountant in his sights of his
sniper rifle Anthony fires but misses
due to being blinded by the glare the
accountant is surprised that he just
barely had time to avoid being shot
normally he would be several steps ahead
of anyone trying to kill him he turns
his head and watches as Olivia helps
Adam up and they run down a nearby alley
the accountant pursues them and Corners
the kill Squad members in the alley he
pulls a gun to shoot Adam but Olivia
tackles Adam behind a dumpster as the
bullet hits the wall directly behind
where Adam was standing the accountant
can't believe that he missed and that he
was almost tricked into being C captured
by the Insurgency team he senses
uncertainty in his as salent actions and
runs away unable to predict exactly what
they are planning to do the accountant
climbs the stairs to a subway station
and Boards the last car of the train it
is empty except for one man Calvin
Lucian the accountant is dumbfounded how
are you here he screams I should have
seen this coming Calvin stands up he
uses his thumb to flip a coin into the
air on the way down he grabs it and
smacks it on the back of his opposing
hand Calvin smiles
the team has been making their decisions
based on the flip of a coin which
introduced Randomness into their actions
that even this super advanc
mathematician could not account for tell
me where 05-11 is demands Calvin the
accountant pauses then shakes his head
no if he's going to die either way then
why give any information to the kill
Squad Calvin flips the coin up in the
air catches it and looks at it the coin
is face up Calvin lifts his pistol and
shoots the accountant in the head a few
nights later later Olivia stands on a
balcony outside of an Art Exhibit
overlooking the city of Seattle Anthony
walks up behind her and tells her that
the foundation is defeated but Olivia
doesn't understand how we broke the
overseer's deal with death and killed
the accountant there's nothing more to
do we can go back to our normal lives he
tells her Olivia is skeptical though
what about the 11th overseer and his
ability to Olivia's eyes suddenly go
wide she pulls out a knife and stabs it
into Anthony's Heart the world around
her begins to distort and fall apart it
was a false reality created by 05-11
better known as the liar Olivia wakes up
next to Adam in a hotel room she sits up
in a bed and rubs her eyes what a weird
dream she thinks then she realizes it
wasn't a dream she shakes Adam awake
neither of them have any idea how they
ended up here but they know it must be
the doing of the liar they had planned
for this though with Calvin having
created a contingency plan they pull out
a laptop and log in to view the
classified information Calvin left for
them them Olivia begins to type but
stops halfway through her password and
looks up from the screen Olivia pulls
out the gun that rests under her pillow
and shoots atam the false reality
created by the liar falls apart around
her Olivia comes out of the previous lie
and is sitting across the table from
Calvin she immediately draws her pistol
and points it at Calvin's head is it
really him or just another one of the
liar games Calvin tries to talk Olivia
down and she looks around the room for
inconsistencies that might tip her off
that this is another lie but doesn't
find any Olivia begins to relax she
tells Calvin that the liar is trying to
get something from her maybe the journal
can tell them what he is looking for as
long as she still has it Olivia nods her
head and holds out her wrist where a
subdermal chip with a copy of the
journal on it has been placed Calvin
looks at her wrist the world around them
begins to dissipate as Calvin morphs
into the liar Olivia wakes up in a
hospital where she is hooked up to an IV
sitting across from her is a former
Insurgency agent Named Sam Beal he
explains SW that he is the liar he was
forced into becoming a monster by the
foundation they had manipulated him but
now he is tired of running and can't do
it anymore she is free to go Olivia
hesitantly unhooks herself from the IV
she walks out of the hospital room and
proceeds down a fluorescent lit hallway
as she walks away she hears a gunshot
from the hospital room as Olivia's in
the hospital Calvin and Adam walk
through a dense forest they're searching
for 05-10 the journal indicates that the
10th overseers identity within the
foundation is the archist in the middle
of the clearing are two saplings
standing side by side the void between
the sapling shimmers Calin walks through
the portal and the space begins to warp
and twist around him his vision finally
comes back into focus and Calvin finds
himself in another world Adam enters the
World Behind Calvin practically knocking
him over as he enters through the portal
this is The Wanderer library but it
doesn't look anything like they expected
instead of rows of books the library is
filled with computer mainframes humming
with the collected knowledge of how to
contain anomalies a critical backup as
the two look intently at the strange
machines a figure in a silver robe
suddenly steps out of the darkness it's
tall and thin and though its hood is
pulled down so they can't see its face
they can see that its hands are covered
in scales that have a slight Emerald
tint it is one of the librarians often
tells the librarian that they're seeking
the archist but the librarian tells them
that the archist is no longer in the
library she is broken her packed with
the serpent and eaten fruit from The
Forbidden trees if they want to see her
though the librarian can take them to
her Calvin and Adam follow the librarian
down a long staircase passing by
countless doors filled with books
Scrolls works of art an entire universe
of knowledge event they reach the bottom
of the stairs where there stands a giant
set of brass doors Beyond the Door the
librarian explains is the source of all
knowledge before Calvin and Adam pass
through the doors though Calvin turns to
the librarian before we go in I'd like
to make a withdrawal he says the
librarian nods and pulls out a silver
tube out of its robe it hands the tube
to Adam and he looks it over in his
hands he looks up to ask what this is
but the librarian has vanished
the door then opens and the two step
through Calvin and Adam feel as if they
walk through the same kind of portal
that brought them to the library and
find that they have walked into a lush
Green Valley with two trees sitting
underneath one of them is a woman in a
white dress she is reading a book and
eating a piece of fruit are you the
archivist Calvin asks the woman nods yes
and that's all the confirmation Calvin
needs he raises his pistol and fires but
the bullet passes right through the
archist as if she wasn't there do you
read the archist asks Calvin seemingly
not phased by his attempts to shoot her
I haven't had much time recently Calvin
replied the archist explains that she's
read every book in the library the
collected knowledge of the universe is
in the books even one on how to allow
bullets to pass through your body she
came here to find the secret to
immortality it's her job to document
everything that happens in the world and
she can't do that if she's dead she
explains that she figured out that the
fruit that the serpent forbade everyone
to eat wasn't actual fruit but the
knowledge contained in the library by
having read every book she has consumed
the fruit she no longer needs the
serpent because she was the serpent the
archist falls to the ground and begins
to R around contorting her body as it
starts to change she begins to elongate
as her limbs seemingly disappear the
next thing Calvin and Adam know they're
face to face with a giant snake Calvin
Dodges as the serpent lunges at him and
Adam stands in the doorway firing at the
snake with his pistol but just like with
the archivists human form the bullets
have no effect the serpent coils around
Calvin and begins to choke the life from
him as Adam can only watch helpless
Calvin cries out with his last breath
the tube Adam open the tube Adam takes
the tube that was given to him by the
librarian and opens the cap a long heavy
spear slides out that looks much too
large to have ever fit inside he drops
the tube to the ground and watches an
amazement as it starts to transform
turning into what looks like a large
Harpoon Gun Adam knows what to do and
places the giant spear into the gun and
points it at the serpent you can't kill
me the giant snake says I've eaten from
the Tree of Life Adam pulls the trigger
and the huge spear flies through the air
striking the serpent in the head Adam
runs to Calvin and helps him to his feet
they turn to look at the snake but
instead of the menacing creature it's
the archist once again pinned against
the tree she once sat under the spear
sticking out of her skull as the two
stand looking at the archist a tall
hooded humanoid figure steps out from
behind the tree it looks similar to The
Librarian except its robe is a greenish
color and it wears long black gloves the
creature pulls the spear out of the
archist whose body slumps to the ground
and hands the spear to Calvin who are
you Calvin asks but his question is
ignored after a moment the figure
finally speaks that spear you now hold
is called the Spear of the nonbeliever
it is an ancient weapon used to kill
Gods it is odd that someone in this
realm gave you the spear even with it
I'm not sure you will be able to
complete your quest Calvin Lucien but we
we shall see there is a sudden flash of
light and Calvin and Adam find
themselves transported back to the
forest they had entered the wanderer's
library from a week later Calvin and
Anthony Tracked Down 0 5-9 who in the
council is known as The Outsider she
isn't hard to find and it seems as if
she actually wanted to be found they
find her sitting outside of her burntown
family home the journal had listed this
as her address but Calvin doubted that
she would be here and most he hoped to
find a clue to her whereabouts but here
she was sitting in the ashes of her home
without turning around the outsider
began speaking the council just used me
you know she says they took away my
academic career my friends and my life
they made me conduct research for them
that compromised everything I stood for
and now here I am with nothing The
Outsider lets out a sigh she asks Calvin
if he's afraid of death Calvin shakes
his head and responds Now The Outsider
slumps forward and Calvin walks around
to face her she is covered in blood her
eyes move to look up at Calvin you're
lying she says as she dies from
self-inflicted wounds Calvin and Anthony
cross o 5-9 off the list and head back
to the car as they walk Anthony says
what's been on everyone's mind the last
few days easy part is done we'll only
get harder from here we know 0 5-8 is in
his castle I'm sure we'll get in but I'm
not sure if we'll make it out alive I
know replies Calvin but if we're going
to save the world we must eliminate the
rest of the overseers even if it means
sacrificing our own lives they get in
the car and drive off into the blood red
sunset to pick up the rest of the kill
squad team before their next mission
Calvin Lucian leads the kill squad team
through the mud and freezing rain in
front of them looms The Fortress of
Baron Leman hoodley the eighth overseer
the team has already been through a lot
from breaking the overseer councils deal
with death by eliminating
05-13 to using the Spear of the
non-believer to kill the Godlike archist
5-10 the hunting of overseers has taken
a toll on the kill Squad 05-12 almost
killed Adam and Olivia was stuck in what
seemed like an endless mind game with
05-11 the first five overseers were
eliminated but the words that the ninth
overseer spoke to Calvin Lucien before
she died still run through his mind are
you afraid of death now the kill Squad
is about to infiltrate one of the most
heavily guarded facilities in the world
to eliminate the eighth overseer
upon reaching the castle the team is
surprised to find the structure is in
ruin no one is supposed to know the
location of 058 though the Fortress was
supposed to be practically impregnable
they stormed the castle of 058 all the
same the journal Calvin possesses that
contains information about the members
of the SCP foundation's powerful 05
Council identifies him as a former
industrialist named Baron Leeman hodle
with his vast wealth hodle funded the
foundation at the start start and was
considered the unofficial leader of the
council in its early days with immense
control over the actions of the
organization the kill Squad makes their
way through the dimly lit hallways of
the castle as they turn the corner
they're surprised to find the charred
remains of Baron Leeman hodle bodyguards
it seems that someone or something has
gotten to hoodley before they could the
team makes their way to the main chamber
and breaches the door laying by a still
lit fireplace is 05- the kill Squad
scans the room to make sure the killer
isn't still in there with them Adam
walks over to the body and examines it
he quickly realizes that hodle hasn't
been murdered at all he sees that Baron
hoddle's body has been drastically
modified using anomalous technology the
overseer used his immortality to modify
almost every part of his body to make
himself stronger unfortunately for Baron
hoodley when the overseers deal with
death was broken by Calvin the
modifications to his body slowly tore
him apart his regular body could no
longer support all the modifications and
what once made him practically
Invincible became the very thing that
destroyed him the team leaves the castle
and Crosses 0 5-8 off their list on
their way out Adam pulls Calvin aside he
has the feeling that Anthony hasn't been
completely honest with the rest of the
team he had the feeling that Anthony was
hiding something from them Calvin had
similar thoughts recently he pushes
Anthony for more information about his
past and Anthony reveals that he's over
one 100 years old the vial of water from
the Fountain of Youth that Calvin has
was not the only one early in his career
with the Insurgency he had confiscated
other vials from a foundation's site his
Squad drank the water and it extended
their lives he asks Calvin on what he
plans on doing with his water from the
fountain I'm going to destroy it Calvin
tells him Anthony agrees with this plan
once you drink from the Fountain of
Youth you may extend your life but a
part of you dies of the same same time
vibrancy of the senses disappears
leading to a seemingly shallow life if
Anthony could go back and do it again he
never would have drank the water Calvin
receives Intel from the Insurgency that
the seventh overseers in a small town in
Cambodia the kill Squad makes their way
to the village and surveys the area
hoping to get a glimpse at the overseer
who codenamed green as the team conducts
reconnaissance Anthony tells them that
he thinks the mission is a setup it is
too remote and there are so many unknown
variables but Calvin is convinced that
this might be their only chance to kill
green since green arrived in the area
there has been non-stop chaos she has
destabilized the local governments and
now the area is in an allout War the
team weaves through narrow passageways
between houses and buildings trying to
make their way to the central compound
where green is located suddenly a mob
starts to form they are getting closer
and closer to the team in a quick
decision to to avoid being seen Calvin
orders everyone into a nearby building
before Anthony can follow the mob rounds
the corner they spot Anthony and he's
forced to flee Calvin Olivia and Adam
watch as the mob chases after Anthony
but they have to keep moving Calvin
knows that Anthony can take care of
himself and they are too close to their
goal to stop now Calvin slowly opens the
front door of the house they are hiding
in and peers out the coast looks clear
so he signals Olivia and Adam to follow
him before they can step out into the
street a gas canister enters through a
cracked doorway the room fills with
sleeping gas and the team passes out
when they are awake they are tied up in
a large room with marble vaated ceilings
0 5-7 is standing in front of Calvin she
smiles wickedly while holding a knife
she compliments Calvin on what he and
his team have been able to do so far no
one believed they could pull off even a
fraction of what they have but now she
has an offer for Calvin she points
towards Adam and Olivia and tells Calvin
he must choose one of them to die if he
doesn't she'll kill the leader of the
riers and plunge another part of the
country into chaos screw you is Calvin's
response very well utters green have it
your way she assassinates the leader
being held in her compound then turns
back to Calvin she now threatens to
torture his team until Calvin makes a
choice of who to kill green slashes
Adam's cheek with her knife as Calvin
screams for green to leave his team
alone and torture him instead green Just
Smiles I'm going to enjoy killing your
friends while you watch as you have
killed so many of my overseers on the
council she reaches up in the air with
the knife above Adam's head before she
can plunge the knife through his skull a
bullet passes through her hand causing
her to drop the knife Anthony kneels on
a rooftop across the courtyard smoking
sniper rifle still pointed at Green who
runs Calvin uses the drop knife to cut
his ropes and chases after green he
follows her to the roof where he watches
as she boards a helicopter the aircraft
lifts off as Anthony Fires at it from
his original position but does no
serious damage in the plaza below the
mob that has separated the team earlier
becomes restless there is complete chaos
and someone fires a rocket at the
fleeing helicopter the rocket hits the
tail of the aircraft sending it crashing
into the plaza full of riers below as
the crowd flees from the sea Calvin
makes his way towards the wreckage and
reaches it at the same time anth he does
Calvin looks at him smiles and thanks
him for saving his life Anthony smiles
back but before he can say anything a
gunshot rings out and a bullet rips
through his neck Calvin turns to see
where it came from and is horrified to
see the burning body of 05- 7 her skin
has been charred black but in her burnt
hand she holds a gun what's left of her
lips curl back in a Sinister grin as she
fires again and hits Anthony in the
chest he falls to the ground Calvin runs
to him and pulls out his gun to shoot 0
5-7 but she is already dead Calvin holds
his dying teammate as blood pours out of
his neck and chest but Calvin can stop
this he pulls out the vial of water from
the fountain no when is Anthony I have
lived long enough thank you my friend I
will see you in whatever lies Beyond
this life Anthony's chest Rises then
Falls it does not rise again olivan Adam
Round the Corner to see Calvin hold in
the lifeless body of their teammate
tears flowing from his eyes the team
holds a small ceremony and burial for
Anthony but are only halfway through
their mission and can't stop now they
fly back to the United States where an
undercover Insurgency agent named
Kowalski informs them that 0 5-6 is
already aware they're after him this
overseer is codenamed the American
because he has the power of the entire
US military at his fingertips the kill
Squad Scouts the base where the American
is located Kowalski warns them of a
crate that was recently brought to the
base from site 19 the Americans showed
great interest in whatever was in the
container the group sets up a camp on a
hill overlooking the base as the sun
slowly Rises the next day the kill Squad
is spotted by a drone and forced to hop
in their Jeep and try to run they make
their way down the hill finding
themselves in the valley below with no
clear exit in front of them lands a
helicopter as Humvees Roar into the
canyon behind them the team is
surrounding Ed a Jeep pulls up and 0 5-6
steps out he introduces himself as Rufus
King member of the overseer Council but
an American citizen first and foremost
all he really wants is to protect the
country he loves thanks to you I've lost
my immortality and can no longer
effectively protect the United States
anymore the American says to Calvin but
I'm willing to make a deal your freedom
for the Spear of the non-believer rumor
has it that you have the spear in your
your possession and you used it to kill
the archivist if you give me the spear I
will let you go no replies Calvin I will
never give an overseer the means to
cause more destruction the spear stays
with us very well the American says with
a frown then I suppose my only other
option is to take it from you but not
without giving you a fair chance run
Calvin Lucien run as fast as you can I
will be coming for you the American
turns and walks towards the container
from site 19 which is being lowered from
a helicopter hovering above them Calvin
Sprints back to the jeep with the other
members of his team as they drive away
they hear a horrible guttural Screech
from whatever was inside the container
after a few moments the Army begins to
pursue them out in front of the military
force is 05- 6 writing SCP 682 too he is
using a black whip to urge the creature
forward and they're gaining on the kill
Squad fast a row of vehicles pulls up
beside the American and SCP 682 then
something strange happens a man appears
in front of the oncoming forces led by
the American the man's skin bulges and
seems to be moving from within the skin
of the man sloughs from his body the
infection that is SCP 610 erupts out of
him and onto the soldiers in the nearby
ch deep SCP 610 begins to infect and
consume everyone around it suddenly
there are thousands of instances of SCP
610 coming from the mountain side
flooding into the valley they close in
and around the Army and 0 5-6 the
American begins fighting off the flesh
eating creatures from the back of SCP
682 but he becomes overwhelmed he can no
longer focus on pursuing Calvin and his
team from the back of the Jeep Olivia
pulls out her rifle she aims and fires
the bullet hits the American in the
chest he is flung off the back of SCP
682 and engulfed in a sea of SCP 610
creatures the kill Squad continues to
drive trying to put as much distance
between themselves and the SCP 610
infestation as possible but then Calvin
suddenly Slams on the break standing in
front of them is a man in a black suit
and bow tie he introduces himself as
Blackbird the fifth overseer according
to the journal his actual name is
Mortimer Jay Denning Von Kiker he stands
in front of the jeep with a menacing
grin you have been causing a lot of
trouble he says looking at Calvin Olivia
swings her gun around oh please my dear
that won't help you Von cnar says he
pulls out a knife and stabs himself
through the neck he falls to the ground
apparently dead there is a gust of wind
a whiff of ozone and an identical copy
and still very much alive on Kiker lands
next to his own dead body see what I
mean he says Olivia lowers her rifle
come with me I have something to show
you the Blackbird beckons seeing no
other option Calvin Olivia Adam exit the
Jeep and followed the Blackbird as they
walk the world changes around them the
desert mountains Fade Away into
Blackness and find themselves in the
near apocalyptic London oh it's good to
be home the Blackbird says as they
emerge onto a cobblestone street you
cannot stop the overseers plans however
I can give you an alternative let's see
if any of you will take it in front of
each kill Squad member appears a door
they have an uncontrollable urge to open
their respective door and walk through
the Blackbird stands smiling as he
watches Calvin Olivia and Adam enter
each of their portals Adam enters his
door and looks around he is in Portland
his parents walk into the room in this
universe his family has been granted
Asylum Adam never has to interact with
any scps or the foundation he is free to
live a normal life from the kitchen
comes Calvin wearing an apron he is
holding a steaming pot Adam locks eyes
with Calvin who Smiles at him the
Blackbird Whispers into Adam's ear in
this reality both of your parents and
siblings are still alive also the man
you love loves you back you and Calvin
could be married if you stayed here
wouldn't that be nice Olivia enters her
door she is on the deck of a yacht at
the bow sits an easel with art supplies
the man that Olivia once loved walks
across the deck towards her the
Blackbird looms over her in this reality
you didn't accidentally kill him this
could be your happily ever after
wouldn't that be nice Calvin steps
through his door he's in a grassy
clearing near a lake the Blackbird
hisses in Calvin's ear I'm giving you
the opportunity to save your mother this
time Calvin
you were just a scared little boy but in
this reality you can be brave you can
actually save your mother from her fate
no Calvin screams this isn't real the
Blackbird cackles Calvin looks away from
the lake and towards the tree line
hidden in the shadows he can just barely
make out a hooded figure Calvin walks
towards it the Blackbird follows he is
screaming at the person in the tree line
I was only trying to help the hooded
figure reaches out and hands Calvin a
metal tube he opens it to find a set of
eyeglasses inside Calvin puts them on
and turns to look at the Blackbird he
steps back in horror the glasses have
revealed the true form of the Blackbird
he is a winged pseudo Aven monstrosity
full of Rage the mysterious hooded
figure directs Calvin to open the tube
again inside is an interdimensional
fishing line made by DR Wonder tainment
and a white whiffle ball bat Calvin
grabs the fishing line and wraps WS it
around 05- 5's leg the black bird flies
into the air trying to get away from
Calvin but Calvin wraps the other end of
the fishing line around his arm the
Blackbird begins to jump from Dimension
to Dimension trying to get rid of Calvin
they appear on the deck of SCP 455 in
site 19 where SCP 682 walks freely in
the dead world of SCP
2935 every time they stop in a new
dimension Calvin takes the opportunity
to attack the blackbird with the bat and
it seems that he is slowly weakening the
monster they finally land at the bottom
of a deep well foundation containment
site where the dark body that is SCP 001
is contained standing in front of the
containment field is Allison Cho The
Black Queen whose sole mission is to
destroy the foundation you cries the
Blackbird you are the one who's been
helping Lucien The Black Queen nods her
head yes I have been helping Calvin
Lucien to eliminate you and and the
other overseers the foundation Must Fall
you are nothing you cannot stop me I am
the black king screams 0 5-5 Allison
Chow sigh she pushes a button on the
panel next to her shutting down the
array containing the dark body out of
the cloud of dust appears SCP 001 a
massive black creature who seemed to
absorb all light no stop shrieks the
Blackbird scp1 one does not move but the
room begins to shake the Blackbird
continues to scream as his body folds in
on itself until he is reduced to a
single superheated point and then blinks
out of existence Allison Chow then
reactivates the containment array
sealing 001 away once again I will
return you to your reality along with
your friends says the black queen but
perhaps our path shall cross again
Calvin Lucien there is a bright flash of
light and Calvin finds himself on a
private jet sitting next to Olivia and
Adam they are all shaken but the
Blackbird is dead 055 has been
eliminated the three members of the team
sit silently still pondering What Might
Have Been if they stayed in the
alternate realities suddenly the phone
on the plane begins to ring breaking the
silence Calvin picks it up on the other
line is the fourth overseer he has
contacted Calvin to discuss surrendering
to the Insurgency unfortunately things
do not always go as planned Calvin
Lucien is about to make the most
difficult and dangerous decision of his
life Aaron seagull better known to
Foundation members as 05- one descends
into the abyss of a Deep Well site he
exits the elevator and peers into the
optical scanner to unlock the reinforced
door inside the room is mobile task
force TOA 5 samsara Aaron seagull refers
to these mortal cyborg clones created
from the Flesh of a dead God as his red
right hand your mission is to eliminate
the traitor 05- 4 and to find the
insurgents who have been killing the
members of the overseer Council the
cyborgs stand at attention now Aaron
seagull screams the soldiers of the red
right hand March out the door to start
their mission Aaron seagull pauses for a
moment and then slams his fist against
the wall in frustration he has lost nine
overseers to Lucian and his kill squad
team they have been somehow overcoming
the odds each time and eliminating each
overseer they tracked down it wasn't
supposed to end this way Aaron seagull
vows to kill them all Calvin Lucian
meanwhile sits on a private jet with
Adam and Olivia he had just hung up the
phone after a conversation with 054 the
overseer known as the Ambassador wants
to surrender to the Insurgency there's a
good chance this is a trap but Calvin
has decided to meet with the Ambassador
all the same Calvin drops off Adam and
Olivia at an Insurgency base they still
haven't fully recovered from the
previous Mission with 0 5-5 known as the
Blackbird before leaving though Calvin
meets with an Insurgency agent named
Sylvester Sloan who is going to join him
as support Calvin says goodbye to Adam
and Olivia then leaves with Sloan to
meet The Ambassador in South Africa
after landing at Johannesburg airport
Calvin and Sloan disembark and are led
to a conf conference room where the
Ambassador sits waiting for them Calvin
and Sloan sit across from 0 5-4 to
discuss his surrender the council is in
shambles says the Ambassador everything
is falling apart I want to offer my
services and information to the
Insurgency in exchange for protection
from 05- one he has lost his mind Calvin
agrees to the terms and prepares for
extraction but as they get up from the
table gunshots can be heard from down
the hall the ambassador's eyes open wide
in Terror it's too late he w Whispers
Calvin and Sloan grab the Ambassador who
is Frozen in fear and exit the
conference room they make their way
towards their plane but the gunshots are
getting closer Calvin looks over his
shoulder to see Sam Sara pursuing them
through the terminal Calvin shoves the
Ambassador behind a table as bullets
whiz overhead Calvin and Sloan return
fire but their volley doesn't seem to
slow down the Assassins Calvin and Sloan
pull the ambassador to his feet and they
burst through an emergency exit onto the
sunbaked tarmac where they make a Mad
Dash for the plane from behind them a
bullet rips through the chest of Sloan
the red right hand has caught up but
Calvin continues to drag the Ambassador
towards the plane they are almost there
suddenly a metallic child's Voice blares
through the airports external speakers
the child's voice says I want Calvin
Lucien alive I have business to settle
with him the red right-and soldiers
tackle Calvin and the ambassador to the
ground when they are just feet away from
the plane kill the traitor the child's
voice says and Calvin can only watch
helplessly as the Ambassador is
violently murdered one of the agents
turns towards Calvin and slams his fist
into Calvin's face causing him to black
out Calvin awakes in a dark room he is
unsure how much time has passed the only
light in the room comes from a screen on
the wall in the middle of the screen is
a rotating red SCP Foundation seal a
voice from a speaker speaks hello Calvin
Lucien my name is the kid I am the third
overseer you have killed all my friends
and now I will kill all of yours the
door to the room opens Calvin leans
through the doorway there is a long
dimly lit hallway the kid orders him to
proceed so they can meet face to face as
Calvin walks the kid's voice Echoes down
the hallway there once was another
he did not have the passion required to
be an overseer that was when I was born
I was chosen by the other overseers to
have my spinal cord severed in a way
that gave me the ability of the
allseeing eye I now watch everything all
of the time I have perfect reasoning
perfect awareness and perfect
understanding Calvin gets to the end of
the corridor which opens up into a large
chamber tied up in the middle of the
room are Olivia and Adam Calvin runs to
his friends and crouches down next to
them a mechanical suit stands on a
platform looking down at Calvin Olivia
and Adam Calvin realizes the kid must be
contained inside I now sentence you all
to death the mechanical suit says as the
red right hand steps out of the shadows
and slowly walks towards the remaining
members of the kill Squad suddenly
there's a flash of light and the black
queen appears stop what are you doing
shrieks the kid the black queen hands
Calvin the interdimensional rod and real
he used to defeat the Blackbird Calvin
casts the rod from out of the terror in
space comes a massive multi-armed
creature known as madami gon the red
right hand engages the monster trying to
force it back into its Dimension but the
monster is too powerful he grabs the
cyborg clones and pulls them through the
tear in reality as samsara battles the
madicon Calvin freeze Olivia and Adam
they make a run for the door but as they
flee one of the walls opens up to reveal
buet turret the gun fires and a bullet
hits Olivia directly in the head killing
her instantly no yells Calvin before
Calvin can push Adam out of the way a
second Bullet From the turret launches
itself in Adam's back Calvin and Adam
slide across the floor the kid in his
mechanical suit jumps down from the
platform above I am going to kill you
now Calvin Lucien he says in his
mechanical voice there is another flash
of light Calvin watches in front of him
as the Spear of the non-believer
manifests it itself before his eyes
Calin grabs the spear and shoves it into
the kid's machine body it easily
penetrates the armor and pins him to the
wall Calvin walks up to the exoskeleton
and tears off the outer plating
revealing a tank full of fluid within
which floats a malformed human fetus as
Calvin finally looks upon the kid's True
Form he hears the sound of mocking
mechanical laughter Calvin breaks the
glass and crushes the kid with his bare
hands as Calin turns from the now silent
robotic body of the kid the room begins
to shake debris raining down from above
Calvin helps Adam up and puts Olivia's
lifeless body across his shoulders what
remains of the kill Squad makes their
way out of the kid's Lair outside of the
foundation side where they were being
held Calvin helps Adam lie down on the
ground before gently setting Olivia's
body next to him Adam grimaces as blood
pours out of the wound in his back
Calvin reaches into his pocket and pulls
out the vial of water from from the
Fountain of Youth there are only a
couple of drops left which he pours into
Adam's mouth Adam looks up at Calvin
tears filling his eyes he whispers I
love you before he passes out from the
pain the wound in his back begins to
heal instantly and Calvin calls an
Insurgency Evac team to come pick up
Adam with Adam safe Calvin picks up
Olivia and walks alone towards a truck
in the lot outside of the foundation
site he needs to finish this once and
for all he will kill the last two
overseers or he will die trying 0 5-1
Aaron seagull arrives at where the tigas
and Euphrates rivers meet the Garden of
Eden he is in a frenzy due to the
assassinations of all the other
overseers besides himself and the
Nazarene and nothing will stop him as he
approaches the gate to the Garden of
Eden though he is stopped by the
guardian of the garden a massive
powerful anomalous entity with a flaming
sword but Aaron seagull has no time or
patience for anything to get in his way
even something as powerful as the gate
Guardian the guardian swings his burning
sword at Adam who rolls out of the way
and in a Flash takes out a Scranton
reality anchor he slams The Anchor into
the ground which causes the world to
Shimmer and ripple around him he watches
as the Flames from the gate Guardian
Sword seem to absorb back into its body
before it shrinks down looking to fold
in on itself until all that left is a
charred skeleton with the guardian
defeated Aaron Sprints into the garden
he searches the garden for 05- to but
can't find her anywhere he finally comes
to the tree of life and that's where he
finds her laying at the base of the tree
in a pool of blood is the Nazarene she
has taken her own life this is her
anomalous power though she has died many
times before yet death always spared her
and brought her back but somehow he
knows this time is final Aaron drops to
his knees and screams in frustration for
all the power Aaron seagull possesses
there's nothing he can do now he sits
next to the nazar's body for hours
hoping that she might wake up or that he
will to find that this was all a dream
after sitting next to her cold body for
some time he notices something in her
Snowy White Hand it's a note in it the
Nazarene explains that she was the one
who gave the vials from the fountain to
Calvin Lucian and that she is the one
who made the spear appear before him
that he used to kill the kid she
explained that while she died many times
and death always brought her back each
time she felt less and less like herself
less and less like Dr Sophia light she
hoped that maybe if things ended up like
this it would give Aaron the chance to
walk away and live the life that they
might have been able to have together
but she knows deep down that Aaron's
fade is to meet Calvin and finish things
once and for all Aaron seagull screams
in Rage clutching the node in his hand
he tries to summon death but no one
comes Aaron seagull is alone he stands
up and walks deeper into the garden he
walks until he reaches a spot where even
God's light does not reach in this
desolate land is an impact crater where
Lucifer star of the morning had fallen
in the middle of the crater lies
Lucifer's sword Aaron seagull descends
into the hole and picks up the sore he
turns and exits the Garden of Eden Aaron
seagull has only one mission in life now
to kill Calvin Lucien Calvin reads the
final entry of the journal in it the
author warns that although he hopes the
information contained within the journal
is helpful he hopes the reader does not
try to use it the words written on the
final page are this information will
only lead you to a devastating end
Calvin closes the journal and looks up
at the structure in front of him he has
made it to sight 01 he had left Olivia's
body in a cave nearby promising to her
that he would make this right he now
walks up to the massive doors and places
his hand on the knotted wood the doors
slowly Creak open Calvin pauses for a
moment and looks behind him at the
Setting Sun he enters site 01 where he
knows 05- one is where Aaron seagull
Waits inside the main hall Calvin sees a
giant doorway in the shape of the SCP
Foundation seal with artistic depictions
of certain scps that he instinctively
knows are special in some way standing
next to the doorway is a 2 m tall man in
what looks to be a futuristic suit
Calvin approaches and asks who this
giant man is he responds that his name
is purpose the red right hand he is the
guardian of 0 5-1 and None Shall enter
the Sanctum until he returns he isn't
here ask Calvin no purpose responds he
is and with that he steps aside and lets
Calvin pass through the doorway the
doorway leads into a large room where
screens on the wall flash to life
depicting moments from Calvin's Journey
documenting his entire Quest had he been
in control at all or was this all a
setup to lead him to this moment as he
walks forward he finally sees him
sitting at a table in the middle of the
room is Aaron seagull Euro 5-1 Calvin
asks Aaron the man responds my name is
Aaron Calvin asks about the location of
the second overseer the Nazarene but 05-
one doesn't respond without needing any
more information Calvin pulls out his
sidearm and in a Flash fires off five
shots the bullets stopped in the air
inches from Aaron before dissolving in a
flash of light Calvin should have known
it wouldn't be this easy stand up Aaron
seagull Calvin calls up as he holers his
gun let's finish it Calvin pulled the
Spear of the non-believer from his back
but Aaron's only response was to
laugh you don't even know why you're
here Aaron said Calvin calls back I'm
here to kill you because when I do I
kill the foundation because when you're
gone the universe can finally heal
you're like me Calin Lucien we are both
men driven by our own convictions
regardless of the outcome it would seem
Fate has brought us together now either
your convictions will be broken or you
will die says Aaron seagull he then
draws Lucifer's flaming sword and lunges
towards Calvin Lucian as the two men
clash with one another their
Supernatural weapons begin to destroy
the room around them Furniture is
shattered video screens are obliterated
and fire spreads across the walls Aaron
catches Calvin off balance and swings
the Flaming sword across Calvin's
stomach Calvin slides back from the
impact hunching over from the pain in
his midsection he brings his head up to
see Aaron seagull running towards him
with the Flaming sword high in the air
Calvin brings up the spear from his
knees he leans back and launches it
towards Aaron seagull the spear enters
the final overseer's chest the force
from the throw pinning him against the
wall Aaron seagull drops Lucifer's sword
it shatters as it hits the ground he
clutches the shaft of the spear
protruding from his sternum with both
hands 05- one looks at Calvin
unbelievingly you have no idea what
you've done it was never about the
overseers Aaron seagull says spitting
out blood with every word it was
something deeper something worse Calvin
walks slowly towards Aaron seagull he
stops just in front of his final enemy
this is the way it ends Calvin says
Aaron seagull manages to whisper one
final word Sophia before his body
finally goes limp Calin turns to see
purpose standing behind him he's dead
Calvin says half to purpose and half to
himself I killed him after a moment he
asks purpose what he really wants to
know there's a room in this facility
where someone could unmake the
foundation right take me there without
any hesitation purpose leads Calvin back
to the room with depictions of import
scps their purpose opens the door to an
elevator but stops Calvin before he can
get inside I am Duty bound to tell you
purpose says that once you step inside
this elevator there is no going back
there is only one decision to be made
and it is not one that can be unmade I
know Calvin responds it's time before
stepping inside the elevator opens a
door to reveal a room filled filled with
bookcases and a huge window offering a
beautiful view of the sun setting behind
the mountains on the wall are monitors
depicting the ways he had killed all of
the overseers and in the middle of the
room is a large desk with a computer
Calvin sits down at the desk and the
computer comes to life the computer
prompts him to scan his fingerprint
which it accepts he's logged in the
computer screen displays numerous
locations around the planet and he
quickly recognizes that they are all SCP
Foundation science then he sees the
single option the computer is giving him
terminate celvin reaches out with his
finger this is it once he presses this
button the SCP Foundation will be no
more his finger is millimet from the
button when the phone rings Calvin
hadn't even noticed that there was a
phone on the desk Calvin stares at it
for a moment then picks it up hello he
says the voice on the other line
responds hello Calvin Lucian my name
name is the administrator I've been
following your work for some time now
and I must say I am impressed I have
just been informed that you have
completed your mission congratulations
are in order what the hell are you
talking about Calvin asks please listen
says the voice on the other line the man
you just killed was once in the same
exact position you are in now granted it
was a very long time ago but Aaron
seagull originally was trying to destroy
the foundation that was until I
convinced him otherwise and now like
Aaron seagull you will become the new
head of the foundation like hell I will
yells Calvin I could hang up and walk
away right now and be done with all this
you could continues the administrator
but if no one is in charge of the SCP
Foundation millions of people will die
if not billions and then nobody would be
there to manage what comes after there
is silence from Calvin that's what I
thought says the administrator I look
forward to working with you Calvin
Lucien or should I say
05- one the line goes
dead the Arora cycle one of the biggest
most legendary series of entries in the
history of the SCP Foundation we've
covered the events of this SCP 001 epic
in six videos which we defin itely
recommend you watch before this one to
avoid your brain exploding from the
sheer scope of it all because that's the
thing about the orborous cycle it's a
story so big sprawling and dense that it
can feel almost like an anomaly itself
whether you're immersed in the possible
origin of the broken God the sentient
black hole that can destroy the whole
universe or Calvin lucian's quest to
assassinate the 05 Council it can
sometimes be difficult to see the forest
from the trees but worry not because
that's exactly why we're here today
we're going to step back and look at
this anomalous Odyssey as a whole and
ask the big question why is it all here
together what makes these four different
storylines the children the broken God
atonement and the way it ends one big
cycle as with anything involving the SCP
Foundation there's always going to be an
element of personal interpretation but
now that we've gone through the whole
cycle we think it's worth adding our two
cents to the proceedings so let's start
BR a question you've probably been
wondering is what do the words orboros
cycle actually mean and what is their
significance to the four stories within
while the spelling can differ orboros
refers to the ancient symbol of a snake
or dragon eating its own tail forming a
circle a direct connection to the
concept of Cycles the arbar symbol has
existed in a huge number of cultures
from the ancient Egyptians to the
ancient Greeks to Modern Gnostic
Traditions it's often used in Alchemy or
other magical practices and has a
variety of meanings such as eternal life
the endless cycle of death and rebirth
and the cycle of renewal anyone familiar
with the tales within the orborous cycle
is probably already noticing some
similarities Cycles are a common theme
in all of these Works people endlessly
repeat mistakes threats thought to be
contained or destroyed return and often
times those who go out on a quest to
destroy something end up becoming what
they wish to destroy in the first place
in cycle there is no true end and no
true beginning everything repeats
endlessly but let's start at the closest
thing to the beginning we have the
children in this Tale the foundation
faces off against a terrifying reality
warping group of interests known as the
kingdom of abdon this nasty Group which
came from the Sahara Desert could
seemingly take anything the foundation
threw at them and were able to straight
up vaporize anyone who got too close if
the kingdom was able to amass enough
power it could spell the end of the
foundation and even the subjugation of
the human race enter 0 5-1 a reoccurring
character in the ororo cycle this
outside the box thinker put all his
chips on the twins of God project
designated SCP 001 like many anomalies
before and after it this project would
Infuse a human being with Godlike Powers
but it was a power so great that it
seemed to kill anyone who attempted to
accept it needless to say this was a
major bummer for5 one but through
Relentless human experimentation even
sacrificing the population of entire
towns to the project he eventually came
up with a solution a horrifying solution
but a solution nonetheless he found that
a group of nine children with ages
varying from 4 to 11 could act as a
human conduit for 001's power and as a
result it could be a weapon capable of
turning the tide against the kingdom of
abdon during the testing phase though it
seemed like 0 5-1 went a little mad with
power he vaporized an entire church of
the broken God place of worship and used
the power of the children to wipe a few
others off the map at his own discretion
his abuses of power got so flagrant that
the administrator himself was called in
to get a handle on the situation and
surprise surprise 0 5-1 disintegrated
him too before disappearing himself
shortly afterwards in the end the
children were deemed too dangerous to be
practical both because of their
anomalous powers and from the level of
ambient radiation they put out all nine
were locked in radiation proof boxes and
buried in the desert though they each
show signs of life to this day while
this may seem disconnected from the rest
of the series it actually establishes
some of the most important reoccurring
themes in ideas of the cycle as a whole
namely the foundation messing with
reality and Performing horrific acts to
achieve their goals the corruption of
the 05 Council and the fact that these
Grand attempts to change or save the
world often blow up in everyone's Faces
Sometimes literally we also have the
introduction and apparent death of the
mysterious administrator but trust us
all Is Not What It Seems with this one
the ripple effect beginning here will
affect everything going forward next the
broken God this tells the chaotic story
of a magical Clockwork box which is
worshiped by the church of the broken
God as a conduit to their deity and
eventually becomes an all devouring
mechanical Kaiju the Beast soon dubbed
CP 001 devoured and consumed all the
metal around it slowly becoming larger
and more destructive if the foundation
didn't take it out before it reached
critical mass they'd be going toe-to-toe
with a Bonafide God a fight they really
weren't sure they could win thankfully
and with a little anomalous help from
SCP 2399 the foundation was able to
destroy the anomaly They removed its
Clockwork hard from the wreckage and
contained the anomalous scrap that once
comprised its destructive body however
the foundation soon realized that you
just can't keep a good god down the
Clockwork heart eventually evaded
Foundation containment while being
shipped to a secondary location and
instead ended up in a small town here it
began to influence the minds of the
residents into more subservient broken
God cultists intent on building him back
up to his former glory it'd be easy to
Discount the broken God as an outlier
seeing as the foundation came out
looking much better here than they do in
any of the other or borus Tales but when
you look carefully its place in the
overall cycle is clear the entry ends
the way it begins with the heart of the
broken God influencing humans to carry
out its bidding the foundation had to
intervene in between these two instances
but in the end there was no net loss to
the broken God itself in a sense the
foundation is doomed to encounter the
same problems again and again
continually defending the world from the
same anomalous threats and the
foundation needs to succeed every time
to maintain peace and normality a major
anomalous threat only needs to succeed
once to drag everything into disarray in
many ways that is the curse of the SCP
Foundation speaking of major anomalous
threats now it's time for part three of
the or borus cycle atonement once again
we start off with the foundation
meddling with Cosmic scale Powers with
the creation of the area 11 Petri Cal
Fontaine spatial stabilization array try
saying that three times fast that was a
machine so powerful it was capable of
creating a singularity though what it
actually ended up doing was turning Dr
Calvin Desmond into an Abomination more
specifically into a kind of immensely
powerful humanoid black hole whose
Powers were only restrained by the very
machine that created him think of him as
kind of a malicious Dr Manhattan from
Watchmen this new entity dubbed
scp1 presented a grim prophecy and an
ominous offer he told the 05 Council
that anom IES were leaking into their
Universe from other realities and soon
the anomalous threat would destroy them
all his offer was to upon his release
wipe out the rest of the Multiverse
entirely leaving only our reality free
from anomalous threats unsurprisingly it
was 05- one that was most interested in
this offer so much so that he held a
vote and murdered everyone who voted
against the decision to release SCP 001
having built his consensus among the
survivors on the council 0 5-1 let SCP
001 out unsurprisingly this turned out
to be a terrible decision as one of his
first acts upon being freed was to kill
the members of the 05 Council that had
just voted to release 001 saying that
they themselves were anomalous and
needed to be purged to atone for their
past sins the only Survivor was a member
of the council who abstained from the
vote who was able to recontain SCP 001
inside the Petri Al fontain AR Ray for
now once again the Thematic connections
to the rest of the ororo cycle is clear
we have a world-ending anomaly held off
but only temporarily buying time before
the cycle inevitably continues we have
the foundation abusing its power and
signing off on the death of countless
people in other dimensions and of course
the 05 Council stepped out of their
bounds and actively warped reality just
like they had with the children before
their chickens truly come home to roost
though in the final part of the cycle
appropriately named the way it ends this
piece Chronicles the story of Calvin
Lucien and the kill Squad an elite group
of four chaos Insurgency Soldiers with
one goal assassinating the entire 05
Council 13 of the most powerful people
in the world why because they've been
messing with reality itself time and
time again and it's getting to the point
that their selfish meddling could
finally destroy everything and given
that we've already seen it happen with
the children and and the entity that Dr
Kelvin desmat became it's hard to
disagree with them what follows is one
of the longest and most complicated
tales in all the foundation as the kill
Squad systematically encounters and
kills each insane anomalous member of
the 05 Council in order to do this they
need to make deals with death itself
fight giant serpents cross Dimensions
deal with SCP 610 and SCP 682
containment breaches and go toe-to-toe
with Sam Sara arguably the foundation's
deadliest mobile task force a number of
other insane things happen along the way
like 05- one murdering the gate Guardian
with the Scranton reality anchor and the
black queen the most prominent member of
the Serpent's hand helping our heroes
defeat more overseers in the end Calvin
Lucien despite losing almost everything
Reigns victorious in the final battle
using the Spear of the nonbeliever a
weapon so powerful it can kill Gods
Calvin managed to finally kill the Top
member of the overseers 05- one with the
05 Council destroyed Calvin set about
completing his final task destroying the
entire SCP Foundation but that didn't
happen instead he was contacted by a
mysterious and immensely powerful being
known as the administrator who gave him
some frightening news he'd just been
hired by the SCP Foundation to be their
new 05- one this was where our last
video on the orboros series left us what
happened next you may ask how does
Calvin respond to this offer he
seemingly can't refuse in this case it
seems that the administrator of being so
completely tied to the nature of the
foundation itself is SCP 001 and while
it seemed that the overseers were mad
with power they were actually always
there to keep the administrator in check
Aaron seagler the 05- one that Calvin
had just killed was doing the exact same
thing Calvin was doing when he became
05- one trying to destroy the foundation
but the foundation and the administrator
cannot be beaten they can only be joined
and that's exactly what Kelvin did
becoming the new 05- one turning his
back on the chaos Insurgency and
rebuilding the rest of the council and
the foundation in his own image
Insurgency members who were once his
allies vowed revenge for this betrayal
perhaps suggesting that history would go
on to repeat itself once more in the
future because at the end of the day
that's what the ororo cycle really is
the reoccurring threat and the changing
of the guards that accompanies it there
will always be a foundation there will
always be an administrator there will
always be an 05 Council nothing starts
nothing ends all that ever changes are
the names and faces involved whether
it's Calvin Lucien or Aaron seagler the
wheel keeps turning the snake devours
its own tail the the oboro cycle is and
forever will be Eternal while some
higher level researchers specialized
guards and containment experts at the
SCP Foundation have fixed anomalous
projects tailored to their very
particular set of skills for many lower
level operatives including Junior
researchers guards janitorial staff and
even the dreaded D classes everyday is
showing up spinning the wheel of
Misfortune and finding out how you might
die today will you be hacked to Pieces
by a murder monster pulled into a portal
turned into a doll eaten alive made into
a living Nest by bugs stretched out and
broken drowned exanguination set on fire
beaten to death by a volley of anomalous
tomatoes because you decided to drop a
cringeworthy dad joke or a rancid pun
there are perhaps only a handful of
anomalies that not only will not harm
you but will actively enrich your life
by getting to spend time with them and
of course Chief among these is is the
legendary SCP 9999 also known by its
adorable moniker the Tickle Monster we
don't need to get into too much detail
in describing this gelatinous ray of
sunshine his anomalous delightfulness
has made him somewhat of a celebrity
compared to the murderer's row of
terrifying entities and monsters around
him the researcher assigned to him today
was troubled having seen one of his
favorite co-workers devoured by SCP 682
the day before getting assigned to
feeding and checking on SCP 999 today
was exactly what he needed as he entered
the room several bags of M&M's in hand
the creature CED perhaps sensing his
tension and approached him immediately
the researcher felt a wave of calm and
contentment wash over him the incredible
and rare feeling that perhaps everything
is going to be all right for once 999
rubbed up against his leg as he poured
M&M's into its eager mouth radiating
Good Vibes the whole time what an asset
what a gift and and to think this
adorable little goober was prophesized
to someday save the world that much
seemed almost funny but he was certainly
more than capable of saving the life of
someone who hadn't felt the warmth of
internal sunshine in quite some time and
for that much the researcher was
profoundly grateful he left 99's chamber
that day with a renewed sense of hope
for the future that maybe just maybe
they might be able to pull through to
make a difference to push this crazy
ball of rock weak call our home in the
right direction maybe someday the Sun
would rise on a perfect world who would
have thought that a strange Sunrise
could change everything emergency Sirens
went off across the globe but in every
case they were drowned out by a terrible
endless chorus of Screams but below all
that you'll hear another gut-wrenching
sound a low but pervasive sizzling like
an egg on a hot pan as billions of human
beings started to change their states of
matter the SCP Foundation had fought off
and contained so many seemingly
impossible threats from interdimensional
Horrors like the hanged sealed and
Scarlet Kings to nightmarish Mass
Killers like SCP 106 the old man scp096
the Shy Guy and SCP 682 the hardto
destroy reptile in their many battles
against the anomalous they developed the
incredible methodologies and exceedingly
advanced technology but what good would
any of it do when the very center of our
solar system decided in an instant that
rather being the Lynch pin of our
delicate cradle of life it would instead
be the horrible instrument of all of our
demises this awful hypothetical was
answered upon the emergence of SCP 001 a
terrible day also known as when day
breaks in the snap of one's fingers half
the world was plunged into Terror and
death rays of Stark red light swept
through the streets people lucky enough
to be in the shade or inside buildings
with a view to the outside saw the
people in the streets seize up and begin
to shriek in terrible pain their skin
sagged and their bones liquefied their
bodies dropped down to the ground and
coalesced into gurgling wretching
Puddles the color of melted flesh those
who saw this Abomination happening would
never forget it it would stay with them
for the rest of their lives it would
endure like a stain on their retinas and
an after image burned into the plasma of
an old TV screen but here's a slight
consolation for most of the human race
the rest of their lives wouldn't be that
long the sudden Insanity taking over the
world caused the SCP Foundation to do
something drastic step out of the
Shadows metaphorically speaking of
course the legendary Foundation motto
had been reversed they would die in the
light so that Humanity could live on in
the dark thankfully the very concept of
the day gave them one advantage while
one side of the Earth was effectively
doomed the second the process began the
other side had a 12-hour Head Start
before the sun turned its terrible eye
to them sirens went off in the middle of
the night waking people up groggy
rubbing the sleep from their eyes every
television and radio and internet
enabled device in their home was playing
the same message direct from the SCP
Foundation which now had effectively
commandeered the entire US Government
along with the rest of the world it gave
them directions to the nearest
Foundation containment site and told
them that if they didn't immediately
comply and find their way to safety they
would experience a terrible death by
sunrise and if you're at all familiar
with human beings you've probably
already predicted that they didn't just
calmly wrap themselves up make their way
to their cars and form an orderly line
to the various Foundation containment
sites located around them it was in fact
total pandemonium as the solar clock
ticked down slowly marking off the
seconds that anyone outside had left to
live the only human beings with a
meaningful Head Start began to go insane
in a number of varied and interesting
ways some who took the situation
seriously and acknowledged that the sun
was indeed going to wipe out most of
humanity simply cracked under the
pressure there were those who went into
totally catatonic States rocking back
and forth in the corner and refusing to
respond to any stimuli some became
erratic and violent with unpredictable
behavior that harmed themselves and
others after all what was the point in
acting normally anymore when the
complete crumbling of human civilization
was imminent and their only hope was
some shadowy organization they'd never
heard of some not heeding the warning
seriously enough and prompted by greed
and opportunism tried to take advantage
of the situation financially some
smashed Windows of local stores and
looted or broke into the homes of
neighbors who had already fled in hopes
of plowing their property others were a
little more creative ative setting up
shortterm everything must go nighttime
fire sales for their brands of essential
oils neotropics and neutraceutical
claiming all of them had the power to
ward off or cure the new effects of the
sun others completely denied the
possibility that any of this was real
and claimed that the messages from the
so-called SCP Foundation were actually
just a front to take away their freedoms
and trap them in underground government
camps they staunchly refused to follow
any of the safety guidelines that the SC
Foundation put out claiming if you try
to take away my first amendment rights
you're going to take away my second
amendment rights while riding around in
their pickup trucks and SUVs blasting
Kid Rocks don't tell me how to live at
earsplitting volumes naturally they had
all melted into screeching puddles of
liquid flesh by Sunrise some were not
victims of their own bizarre choices but
were doomed by the sudden terrible fear
and panic of the circumstances
themselves the highways were gridlocked
cars stuck as far as as the eye could
see so many had rushed to escape during
the initial wave that means of Transport
soon became choke points like clogged
arteries in a dying man people do
irrational things when they're scared
riots broke out in the streets fighting
killing burning everyone hoping for some
means of meager control over a situation
that had long been out of any of their
hands some were too far away with not
enough time to close the distance what
could they really do but just sit around
and wait to Die the hours marched on as
the earth made its slow turn towards the
sun leaving one decimated half in
darkness and the other a Sitting Duck
for its terrible effects hundreds of
thousands had made their way to the
containment sites and safely gotten
inside but still so many millions were
left outside it was a slaughterhouse one
great big Global meat grinder and every
moment that passed the handle turned and
any humans left outside got just just
that little bit closer to the grinding
nashing gears below site 19 being the
largest containment site on the
foundation books also became Humanity's
only Bastion it was the great hope of
escape from the horrors going on outside
the foundation had figured out so many
ways of counteracting deadly anomalous
forces before given enough time and
enough Personnel surely they could
figure out a solution to even this this
was however when the most startling
realization yet swept over all the
survivors the those who were melted by
the sudden hostile Sun weren't dead they
were very much alive in fact but they'd
been changed in both body and mind what
had once been humans now became terrible
beasts half melted gelatinous nightmares
that coagulated into even bigger beasts
they got into their head that they were
grateful for the transformation that
they had been liberated from their old
forms in the old world they were
something so much more now and they
wanted everyone else to join them in
their Liberation survivors outside the
foundation containment sites were
systematically hunted by these great
masses of altered flesh even though
smart enough to cover every inch of
their bodies with clothes to protect
from the Sun to only move at night to
carry weapons were dragged out by meaty
tendrils from their refuge in the
basements and the lightless hearts of
buildings dragged into the Searing gaze
of the sun to melt to change to coales
into something greater it was is the
inevitable fate of all of humanity when
most of the stragglers were dragged out
and changed the flesh masses started
turning their attention to the
foundation containment sites that were
keeping all these poor deluded people
from salvation they mounted offensives
against the bases which the foundation
with what remained of their Manpower and
advanced Weaponry did what they could to
repel the attacks but every single day
it got harder thankfully for the people
H up at site 19 there was one
consolation out there to help SCP 999
the foundation was at war with the sun
and its terrible disciples and contrary
to many people's beliefs it takes more
than men equipment and bullets to win a
war 999 provided the essential element
that brought it all together morale hope
the will to go on even when it seemed
like all could be lost after a long day
of battling the fleshy Abominations At
The Gates Foundation guards Mobile T
Force members and even civilian
volunteers were drained and traumatized
by the horrors that they'd seen once a
day was over 999 would move among the
ranks cuddling up to them wording off
the despair that was easy to set in
during the downswing of a terrible
apocalypse like this without his
presence there would be no hope of
fighting that good fight so many of them
would have given up walked into the Sun
and joined the Monstrous Force they were
fighting after all they seemed happy
enough and it would certainly be easier
999 had become once again an
indispensable asset to the SCP
Foundation the solar betrayal may not
have been the Scarlet King's doing well
as far as our current Intel suggests
anyway but he was playing a crucial part
in saving the world exactly as predicted
999 didn't fully understand what was
going on outside sometimes why there
seemed to be fewer people as the weeks
went on and why the people there seemed
so sad all the time whenever he wasn't
helping them but he was more than happy
to help whatever the case many of the
humanoid and some even non-humanoid
anomalies which realistically posed no
harm to people inside the site were
released from their containment Chambers
they needed everyone and everything they
could get in what seemed like a
hopelessly one-sided fight against the
very concept of being outside many of
the larger vacated Chambers were now
filled with refugees from the outside
many of whom had lost everything and
everyone they'd ever known to the
horrors out there 9999 made the rounds
in these areas regularly and through the
d-class cots which had been repurposed
into more sleeping areas for the
thousands of desperate and terrified
refugees the adjustment to this new life
and to the knowledge of all secrets that
had been kept from them for all these
years wasn't exactly easy on their
psyches but spending time with that soft
yellow blob that seemed to smell exactly
like their favorite scent from the old
world made everything better he was a
savior in Dark Times slithering from
person to person giving hope where there
was none people opened up about their
problems and their fears which these
days were remarkably similar and though
999 couldn't reply for many was enough
just to feel like they were being
listened to he was a soft Blobby
shoulder to cry on and after day broke
everyone needed a good old-fashioned cry
however one day while wandering The Long
Dark corridors of site 19 he saw a
different kind of crying it was a woman
with an unfamiliar face probably one of
the rare new refugees balling her eyes
out to a foundation senior researcher
and an accompanying guard with an
assault rifle hot fat tears were rolling
down her dirty cheeks her shaking hands
clasped in prayer she was begging the
researcher and the guard to let her go
outside she said that her son was still
out there hiding away in the back room
of a bank where she used to work they
got separated she needed to go back and
find him sadly the researcher and the
guard told her that this was out of the
question a offal order stated that
anyone outside the base at this time was
to be considered lost letting her go out
there to find her son would essentially
be condemning her to death no human
could go out there safely but of course
SCP 999 isn't by any definition a human
when night fell and everyone else was
hunkered down inside 999 found a small
crack in the wall and slithered out of
it it may not have been communicative in
the way most humans were but 999 was
indeed an intell ENT being and knew
intuitively that if it left through a
more obvious route its human caretakers
here at the SCP Foundation might try to
stop it and when it came to saving this
little boy 999 refused to let anyone
stop it 999 slithered out and through
the broken streets there were no bodies
of course it seemed even the dead could
be revived and assimilated through the
power of the sun talk about a mixed
Miracle but the broken down World
outside site 19 undeniably reflected the
pandemonium that took place here 999
would need to do his best to find the
little boy trapped out here before the
sun rose he lost a few hours even
finding his way to the nearest town
where it was safe to assume that the
little boy was trapped he saw those
things on the way there those moving
wailing mountains of melted human flesh
each talking and shattering to
themselves in a 100 different dead
voices 999 had been cross tested with
SCP 682 and still those monsters
frightened him he decided it would be
best to stay away from them and make
sure that they never saw him out of here
eventually 999 reached the town
similarly dilapidated and broken down in
the months since the world as we had all
known it disappeared in a ray of
terrible Sunshine more great gibbering
Blobs of Flesh patrolled the streets
looking for converts to integrate into
their biomass 999 could only hope it
wasn't already too late for the little
boy 999 discreetly slithered from
building to building until it could
identify one as this bank that the boy's
distraught mother had been mentioning it
thankfully had some awareness of what a
bank actually was from the years of
stressed Foundation employees telling it
about the money troubles they were
suffering outside of work it was another
great example of it paying to listen
eventually it did Slither into the
correct building and it heard the
extremely quiet whimpering of the boy
inside it could feel the sadness and the
fear radiating off of him as it was the
creature's natural instinct to help the
needy and to use those signals like a
homing beam to find the scared little
boy he'd hid an inside a broom closet
and was quietly weeping into his hands
he hadn't eaten in days and was only
surviving by drinking the filthy water
from the mop bucket sitting next to him
999 immediately embraced the boy
covering him in its healing energy until
the tears of the boy's face eventually
DED 999 CED and chirped pleasantly until
the little boy was laughing again but
this momentary Joy was soon interrupted
a great heaving weight dragged itself
down the hall outside both 999 and the
boy could sense its monstrous presence
as it got closer they could hear all
those chattering voices those poisonous
Whispers when it passed the door they
heard it speaking its voice practically
vibrating with the hum of malicious
lunacy turn pretty flowers turn towards
the sun feeling it on your face feel
yourself change and SLO and mix into us
become one with our army of One it must
be so lonely to be you Little Flower
walk into the Sun and be us 999 and the
boy remain silent in the broom closet
for hours as the great shape patrolled
the bank outside searching for converts
for victims had times it seemed too
frightening to even breathe fearing that
would be enough to make the monster
detect them it felt like an eternity
until the monster eventually did slope
off and leave them in the comforting
quiet and darkness of the closet now
they might be free 999 could escort the
boy safely back to the containment site
and into the arms of his terrified
mother but when they opened the door
they saw a terrible sight light in the
distance pouring Through the Windows and
the glass double doors it wouldn't be
safe to go out that way upon seeing this
and putting together what it meant the
boy began to cry he couldn't take
another night in the closet it was all
going to Wither from here until 999 had
a wonderful idea hours later when the
foundation guards manned the turrets at
the entrance of site 19 waiting for the
inevitable onslaught of the melted flesh
creatures they tensed up seeing a
blobbing gelatinous form slithering
towards them in the distance the guards
who' learned the hard way from too many
men that it was better to be safe than
sorry Drew a bead on the distant shape
and prepared to fire when suddenly their
Superior raised a hand and said wait
hold fire is that
999 and it was they all stared in
astonishment as 999 chipper than ever
came towards them through the sun it
looked as though the opacity of its
yellow cytoplasm had increased but other
than that it was unaffected turns out
the sun couldn't melt what was already
melted the guards parted to allow 999
safe passage into the facility watching
in amazement and once it was inside 999
slime parted releasing its contents one
very relieved little boy it seemed
through turning up its own opacity 999
had given the boy safe Passage through
the Sun and back into the facility the
boy was saved it had won not long after
that there was a tearful reunion between
mother and child and a brief flash of
Hope and this dark and terrible time 999
didn't stop to bask of course it
returned to its duties keeping up staff
morale and helping the refugees heal
from the horrors they'd seen in its own
little way and for a lot of people SCP
999 really was saving the world or what
was left of it anyway oh and of course
if SCP 999 had won your hearts just like
it won ours you'd be pleased to know
that you can purchase your own adorable
highquality SCP 9999 plushy at SCP
swag.com check the link in the
description to get your own trust us
having a 999 to cuddle really does make
any apocalypse a whole lot easier now go
check out SCP 001 when day breaks and
SCP 999 Tickle Monster versus the most
evil scps for more of the two incredibly
contrasting anomalies from today's
episode